foreign
looking clean
[Music]
wow
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
whoops
relax
foreign
[Music]
number seven Fabiano caruana in the big
winner final but before that in just a
few moments four players will enter the
play zone to fight for survival among
them Wesley saw and Magnus Carlsen we
are so excited this is day three of the
chessable Masters
how on Earth have you save this position
well Magnus just widening his eyes
they're shocked by this last decision
more than five minutes wow he's showing
no fear whatsoever is inching up this is
Checkmate incoming and then King goes to
A6 and there are no checks on the boys
throwing a thorn into the white side
holding on here for dear life look at
that celebration
you see the bar go back to equal oh my
gosh it is beautiful awareness
hello and welcome everyone we've had
nail biting action so far we started
with eight players we're down to six
things are heating up in the chessable
Masters and to guide us through the
action in the studio got Master David
house
PJ Master James Canty let's go and
Grandmaster Robert Hess
we had two epic armageddon's David what
was the highlight for you on day two so
many armageddons so many highlights I
should have said we saw Magnus squeeze
through but also that match between
Fabiano caruana and vladislav artemie it
was really really close in the end but
Fabiano when it mattered came up with
those incredible moves yeah yeah so much
action on day two James what was your
big takeaway Fabiano Queen f8 and we
great it was all over the Internet it
was ridiculous yeah
yeah what a move by Fabi you found in
seconds that one is going to go down in
history books and that has been so
exciting Robert to see the players play
with barely anytime on the clock now
traditionally we've seen the
armageddon's but here it is the bidding
Armageddon do you enjoy that twist oh
who doesn't enjoy it because you pick
your own time so if you bid too low that
could be a problem for you we've seen
that in the past matches and for five
minute Corona it worked out yesterday
but today's a new day and he faced off
insecara Nakamura yeah big matches
coming up today let's take a look at our
bracket this is where we stand going
into day three wow I look at that losers
quarterfinals and it just seems you know
what you lose one game you have a tough
day and that's the mix you'll end up in
that right there is a nightmare David
we're going to focus a little bit on
that
who in that bracket whose chest has
impressed you the most well you would
expect me to say maybe Magnus Carlsen
but actually I'm going to say vladislav
artemiev in the lower half of that loses
quarterfinal he was really unlucky to
actually have to drop down to this
bracket yesterday he was very close
against Fabiano caruana and uh love on
Iranian will have his handful dealing
with him
you've seen our time you have play God
lover chess we're just seconds on the
clock but James he's got to be careful
to not go so low on the clock today in
fact I mean our Timmy have is just you
know a different kind of Grisha you know
they they have to be related the way
that they play this chess right they get
lower on time and they play better chess
they gotta be related somehow but of
course if our team gets low on time he
gets stronger right so I think it's the
other way around
Bobby said that as well that our Italian
style is so much like Grisha he comes
into these time scrambles but then
displays incredible chess Robert do you
agree oh of course how could you not the
Siberian elephant is over 3 100 in
bullet on chess.com he's one of the very
best and we saw it yesterday we saw it
the day before he continues to impress
with mere seconds on the clock yeah I
love it we've been enjoying the play but
our time is in the losers bracket today
and now this is such an exciting time
for the Chess World Chess has never been
bigger and the tour has played a big
role in evolving it into the East boy
now take a look at the road map of the
biggest ever season of the Champions
chest star
the 2023 Champions chess tour is the
biggest tour yet with a thrilling brand
new format and two million dollars in
prizes it's the richest online
tournament of all time
the tour begins with six elite events
taking place between February and
September
each event features an open
qualification system with qualifiers and
plans locking in 56 players to the main
events
their players are grouped into three
divisions and compete for 235 thousand
dollars in prizes each time
victory in division one in any of the
six events secures a spot directly to
the eight player Champions chess tour
playoffs in December
players will also accumulate toward
leaderboard points across the six events
competing for another one hundred
thousand dollars in prize money and the
unsecured playoff spots will go directly
to the top leaderboard finishers
the end of the year we have two weeks of
incredible chess beginning with the
playoffs for which just four players
will advance to the Champions chest tour
finals to a single elimination bracket
which will ultimately determine our
champion
together the playoffs and finals feature
a whopping 500 thousand dollars in
prizes
in December of 2023 an Undisputed tour
Champion will be crowned
let the games begin
our action will be on division one of
the 235 thousand dollar adjustable
Masters but of course action is on in
division two and three as well Robert it
is so critical it is also the path to
division one for the next event yeah the
winner of division two gets automatic
placement in division one you get that
prize money and those tour points and we
know how important that is yeah and you
got some really big names fighting there
as well uh yes we do indeed you have
former world champions no matter where
you look in the winners bracket of
division two right now it is super
exciting take a look at that just the
sheer strength of division two and in
the winner semi-final Robert I see a
clash of teenagers there nodded back up
to such off taking on Dennis lazovic
what do you expect from that it's one of
the former world champions the world
rapid Champion a few years ago notary
Rick abusive he leads he is let his
country Uzbek sent to a gold medal in
the Olympiad and Maxine vashilagrove a
former world Blitz Champion he is
leading the 14th World Champion Vladimir
krummick right now but their second game
is underway and it's super exciting yeah
the Frenchman with three names taking on
the 14 World Champion we saw that
Vladimir kramnik is on the back foot
there what does he need to do against
the player like mvl to strike back uh
you you see this your Peak rating and
your Peak ranking and you beat Gary
Kasparov to become the world champion
that's the form that he needs to refine
here and he's doing that in game two he
is really inspired in his second game
the white side of the Sassoon uh
Vladimir crowd playing E4 maybe it is
best by test after all I love it he is
one of the 14 players to have ever
broken into 2800 rating in the history
of the game the 14th World Champion
Robert as just as getting younger
especially in this format we see that it
is kramnik who's holding the flag for
the old God how does he do it it's not
just Vlad it's also Rich for nothing on
it a lot of these players they may hear
all those calls oh they can't play the
youngsters anymore they certainly can he
played on the internet chess club way
back in the day he's played a lot of
Blitz in his life in fact yesterday he
was playing Armageddon blitz so he is
fresh he is ready and he's inspired I
love it we'd love to see Vladimir crime
rate in division one in the speed chess
format well there is also action on in
division three let's bring up our
bracket and look at that we've got Amin
tabatabai versus
had a brilliant performance in the
Olympiad what are you expecting in this
one Robert yeah that's one that's hard
to call because these two players they
go under the radar because they're not
at that super GM 2700 level but I see in
the quarterfinals in the losers bracket
Alexis Serrano he was in division one of
the air things Masters he already takes
out way Yi and the FFL gotta comp key
he's still afloat down there he's taking
on one of the quarterfinals of the
official random World Championship in
Matthias bluebound yeah absolutely so
much action on in the chessable Masters
there is prize money at stake there's
store points and the golden ticket to
the tour final with all that online
action is heating up on day three of the
trustable Masters but first before we
get to it let's take a look at day two
a decision has been made by Wesley to
retreat with the Knight and Robert I see
that expression you are surprised it's
not just another blunder in one by
Wesley dropping upon David yes simply
he's forgotten that Knight takes D4 is
not available now
white is paralyzed could barely barely
move look at this poor White Knight it's
stuck defending the A2 Square the White
Queen is stuck defending that night and
uh I think it's good night here for
Wesley so three queens on the board but
the queen can always fall back and no
Perpetual there and with that we see
Hikaru he knows he's done it
like Rook is diving jumped in both sides
creating threats here on every turn oh
that black king is in big big trouble
and six seconds on the clock Wesley if
you can land check mate with two seconds
left he's gonna be happy but it's gonna
be so hard to navigate this one if we
can just quickly get an update on that
one
what is happening Rook F7 is a maiden
one let's stay right here I think you
can just take the bishop he knows that
he's calculating but he knows he's done
it
what what what why does he say that we
don't because the black Rook can drop
down with a check and go behind save
oh these players are so good I've got to
say drop that Rook down Hikaru and you
will not lose this game and it is
official hikarnakamura has drawn his
game against Wesley which means Wesley
moves on to the losers bracket
oh my gosh that Bishop State hits the
queen and the rook in a row but also it
goes from the F2 Pawn so it's kind of a
double threat what a move from Fabiano
world class move from fabianos this is a
game-ending move double attack if he
finds it he wins on the spot look at
that the engine says seven plus seven
for black that's it he finds it and
leans back he knows this is a big moment
has missed it and our Tamia realizes
this is busted for white
[Music]
a big day of stress coming up with a big
All-American Clash there in the winners
final as Fabiano caruana takes on Hikaru
Nakamura in division one we will talk
about that match really quickly but
before that Robert we've got a huge
update coming in from division two we
have a heartbreaking update because
Vladimir kramnik has Mouse slipped and
blundered his Queen in a strong position
against Maxine for shoulder off he's now
down two games to none
yeah tough moment there for the world
champion Mouse lips these are this is
the curse of online rapid play it just
happens but it is part of the skill set
as well yeah there's no one better at it
than Hikaru Nakamura he's won all these
major speed test events and he does not
Mouse up pretty much ever yeah I've
never seen that happen well he's got a
big match ahead of him James Hikaru
versus Fabi what's your take on that
okay that's fabulous Fabi Flex a lot
Fabi in the gym now you know trying to
do his thing he's doing good in chess
obviously but then you got your car
Nakamura who's a man a myth a legend
everything else we have man we don't
know the rest right that man is very
strong and Fabio is going to be up
against some very strong opposition
today so you have to really bring his
best yeah before I've played some great
chess yesterday against our time I mean
that queen f8 move I know we've been
speaking about it but we can't stop
talking about that it really was one of
the big moments in the chessable Masters
we will get to that Winners final but
before that there is action in the
elimination bracket with Wesley so
taking on Magnus and our tummy have
against Levon David is there a heavy
favorite in this one I'm going to say no
Tanya I've already praised artemia's
play he's been fantastic so far one of
the dark courses for the event but live
on a Rooney if he does bring his best
maybe his ceiling is a bit higher maybe
at his best he uh will be able to push
our team into tough Corners push him off
the board so if Artemis isn't able to
combat level in those difficult Dynamic
positions then he might struggle but uh
yeah it's gonna be a close one that's
for sure really close live on irony and
one of the most creative players has
been showing fantastic chess in the
chessable Masters our Tamia has to keep
control on the clock the this is our
other big big classic matchup in the
Chess World with a Wesley store taking
on Magnus Carlsen Robert what's going to
be the key area in this matchup I have
to say I'm shocked by that graphic and
it's not because of all the draws it's
about the fact that Magnus 23 wins but
Wesley has 19 in Rapid chess we usually
Magnus have 25 and then everyone else
have five so the fact that they're that
close they're that neck and neck it's
shocking to see but it shows that Wesley
can hang with him
James 19 wins for Wesley does that
surprise you as much I mean yes it does
but I did not have to remember oh it's
flexly so oh okay he wanted to flex on
everybody just now to let you know I can
hey with Magnus 19 wins of course now
when the time gets faster obviously
Magnus is winning there but in Rapid
chess Even In classical he's like yeah I
can swing with you big fella I know
you're World Champ but guess what I'm
coming at you man it's so close they
played 74 rapid games against each other
the scores are almost balanced we
mentioned the other matches would be
close this one Anything could happen
it's only two games in this match we
might well see a close Armageddon as
well oh my God a bidding Armageddon on
this that's going to be fun let's take a
look at the format it's not a far way
off because the players play a best of
two match first and if that is a tie
then we will have the better Armageddon
they start with 15 minutes on the clock
with a three second increment it is
going to be all about nerves and keeping
them in control on those time scrambles
Wesley so one of the toughest players to
beat in Elite chess he just knows when
he gets those opportunities to strike at
them keeps everything under control
plays fast what is Robert according to
you Wesley's biggest strength that makes
him such a beast in these formats he is
ultra precise he doesn't take many risks
that's been a criticism we've had and
many have had about his style because it
may prevent him against the absolute top
as world champion but he beat Magnus
Carlson in a Fisher random World
Championship in 2019. he just beat him
he crushed him he made Magnus look like
an amateur in that match and pretty much
nobody on the planet can do that so I
think Wesley's precise style the fact
that he is stoic he plays the board at
all times I think that actually benefits
him in a match against the world
champion yeah and we just saw the world
champion open the window he's gonna need
all the fresh air that he can get in
this match we will get the update on the
air condition in his playing side with
our air tanks device but action is off
we've got we've got a sicilian on the
board yeah Sicilian and this is magnus's
world Championship repertoire from 2018
against Fabiano caruana this last move
though E5 it's really trendy at the
moment Magnus has popularized it uh it's
been played by all the top players I've
even seen Hikaru recently play this
against Wesley so himself uh Wesley now
pausing maybe he's just gonna Castle his
King this tends to end up in a very
maneuvering battle reminiscent of the
Spanish opening Black Sea points on a
different square but uh everything else
there uh very very similar so
interesting start both players choosing
I think their ultimate repertoire their
uh their best openings and this bishop
move still standard stuff so far
absolutely yeah the stand-up it looks
weird James it is weird in fact I mean
there are some chessable courses on this
if you want to go first Camille please
actually has it with his uh lifetime
repertoire of accelerated Dragon here
where he actually goes into with the
Knight C6 line and then he goes with his
Bishop D6 stuff against russellimo
there's also another one by Pepe Quinta
who just uh dropped the uh classic one
who actually covers obviously this
Knight C6 move order with Bishop D6 in
here so it's very fun there's actually
some type of uh you look at it like
Danny kopeck system in a way in Reverse
when you put the bishop back on C7
You'll Play D5 you play Knight G to E7
right and you'll play D5 and you you
just want to actually open up the game
the bishop is very strange here don't
try this at home if you don't know what
you're doing because the bishop
shouldn't be on D6 but it's for a reason
B4 that ain't in the book
right there that's off the head my guy
that's a pawn sacrifice he just gives up
a pawn in the center of the board and
Magnus takes it and Wesley's thinking
against her David I've seen this before
in magnus's own games but surprise me
that you give up a pawn and then start
thinking yeah really surprising either
you've done your homework or you haven't
and then you play a quieter line but
what could the idea be here Magnus after
grabbing this Pawn with his Knight he's
saying to Wesley okay if you take me
back I might even take this way I'm
gonna say with the E Pawn first opening
up the black Bishop but surely the idea
at some point will be to throw a pawn
forward try to open up lines further
while the black king is still stuck in
the center there is a pin on this file
and I think white will win the pawn back
in the short term however perhaps
Wesley's thinking of something else this
move dropping the bishop back is the top
recommendation as far as I can see from
the engine maybe targeting a loose Pawn
on the F7 Square this is really
complicated stuff I've got to say yes
you're a pawn down but Black's Bishop is
a Target on the D file blacks pieces us
are asleep this one still struggling
stuck at home and of course the black
king big big Target
what do we think uh surprisingly Wesley
think as you mentioned but looking uh
looking promising I'm shocked by that
though he just gave up a pawn and it's a
very important part it's one in the
center and now Wesley is thinking well
these two of course levana Ronin blast
overtime they're about to get underway
but I just still can't believe the fact
that Wesley would volunteer upon and
then start thinking after it yeah and
Wesley has just moved in that game but
uh here we see the other uh game the
other clash in the losers bracket yeah
we see lavender moving his camera just
adjusting to get ready to make sure that
he's comfortable to start his game again
so vladislava time you have it is a best
of two our time will he start with one
E4 or 1d4 we saw both of them by him
yesterday and Knight F3 Knight F3 Knight
F3 definitely going with the Knight of
three I think our teammates should just
play his game right Knight of three and
just play his game against uh Lebron
aronia here LeBron is very ferocious
right you know this all right while we
wait for them to get things started we
already have action on this one I have
to say Wesley is sacrificing a pawn so
early on in the opening it's not
something that we get to see every day
he usually plays a lot more solid keeps
everything under control David are you
surprised with how aggressive Wesley is
I'm slightly surprised but I'm also very
pleased it's refreshing to see Wesley
just throw things at his opponent we saw
yesterday against Hikaru it nearly paid
off Wesley was taking more risks he was
in a must-win situation and that style
of play really suited him he nearly took
down him covered there but I think the
plus side for for Wesley is that the
pawn sacrifice is just temporary most
likely he's going to regain the pawn in
the center of the board so it always
helps taking risks when you know there's
a backup plan there's a safety net and
Magnus meanwhile snacking he snapped on
one point on the board now he's snacking
on the is that a sandwich as well should
I say his burritos burritos Jazz yeah
burritos burritos this man is always
eating Magnus just going crazy on the
fool here and on the board as well I
mean it's almost like he just doesn't
care right I'm eating I'm relaxed it's
kind of hard to do that when you have to
calculate in such a intense match I
don't have any appetite when I'm like
playing because I'm really focused right
about you remember yeah I don't really
like to eat when I'm playing either in
fact I you know I'm just too nervous to
focus on anything but the chest I'm just
trying to be as focused as possible but
for Magnus I mean we saw this yesterday
he doesn't mind playing The Lunchbox
Gambit he gives away a minute on the
clock here and there and he's just
trying to be as well nourished as
possible do you think that's mind games
from Magnus a little bit just eating in
front of his opponent well I don't know
if Westy's got his eyes on the camera or
not but he hasn't made a move is that so
of psychologically a little disturbing
for Wesley uh it could be disturbing but
it could also boost Wesley's confidence
the fact that Magnus is tanking right
now thinking clearly Wesley with that uh
Pawn sacrifice earlier he surprised
himself but he's also surprised Magnus
and uh I think that's one of the
differences between online chess and
over the board chess if it's over the
board I will tell my opponent off if
they're eating I will tell them to get
away move off stop disturbing me stop
dropping crumbs on the board but uh yeah
this is one of the perks of online chess
you can kind of do what you want in your
own home and I thought you were a nice
guy wow so I know if we play I I'm gonna
eat at the board on purpose now just to
bother you the gloves come off Robert
once I sit down at the chessboard
no prisoners wow wow so you're only Mr
Nice Guy off the board that's the thing
about chess players right they could be
the most humble the kindest the nicest
people off the board but absolute beast
on the board and that's what we've been
seeing from vladislav our tummy up
throughout this event while he's playing
against Levon the game is underway let's
get a quick opening update on that one
as the two players make their first
moves yeah and we mentioned one E4 one
D4 one Knight F3 of course vladislava
team didn't choose any of those he chose
one C for the English opening and this
is the result it looks like a Sicilian
Defense just with reverse colors it
looks like a sicilian Dragon white has
been catch with his bishop and other
than that everything balanced what do
you think of this uh opening James I
actually like this oh there is
accessible course in fact on these um
you actually have few a few English
courses you have the ones from Christoph
selecki who has a part one and part two
and you also have Simon Williams who has
the bobbinic English but this is not the
buffing English at all in fact you need
pawns on C4 E4 and D3 so this is a
little bit different you actually can
face this a lot from uh the Kristoff
selecki covers a little bit of this but
this actually is a reverse Sicilian so
of course a lot of the ideas are the
same Knight A4 Knight to C5 right the
long the longer diagonal Bishop on G2
which is really strong now of course
it's not uh you don't have the the
dragon type aggression here but you do
have the dragon type bishop and you have
a lot of Queen side play for white yep
just uh I really like that maneuver you
mentioned bringing the White Knight into
the black cough and uh maybe going for
the bishop pack trying to force black to
trade off long term white does have a
small Advantage strategically just
because you have one extra Central Pawn
and the semi-open C file but early days
in this one Robert yeah I'd like when
you just pointed out the semi-open file
because the pawn structure is not
symmetrical white has the C file black
has the D file but the D file doesn't
amount to much of anything because a
Pawn's best friend is another pawn and
we just saw the Knight hop to E4 same
idea as hopping A4 it's trying to go
into C5 to win the bishop pair if the
Knight hops into C5 you probably have to
take it as black and then once that's
captured The Rook gets in the game white
has a pair of Bishops white has that
strong Bishop run G2 and has really good
access down the c-line yep looking very
promising that meanwhile uh level and
running just gained space on the queen
side maybe hinting that he'll push this
Pawn even further forward he's
activating his Rook without moving it
really nice strategy there so a clash of
styles Clash of ideas and very
imbalanced uh meanwhile flag time we
have we saw it yesterday that was the
theme of the day him tanking he's
spending loads of time on the clock and
I wouldn't be surprised if uh okay I was
gonna say if he spends a long time there
uh wondering what to do but he
immediately goes for the plan that we
highlighted he's got the Bishops and
long term white is doing very well short
term however black is very active nicely
centralized and that compensates for the
bishop pair
we've been talking about this Apon
Advance by 11 aronian is it dangerous
for our Tammy have if left decides to
push it one square further and actually
Target those Queen side pawns is A3
something that Robert or tamiab needs to
watch out for absolutely because what
that move does is it challenges white
setup on the queen side you're putting
Pawns in Target with one another so
there could be a pawn capture white does
not want to exchange pawns that Rook on
8 it's undeveloped for the moment but as
soon as that pawn gets out the way then
that Rook is active but the alternative
doesn't look that much prettier for
white because while the A2 Pawn will be
safe and sound for the time being
playing B3 that's a cemented weakness
and a knight will jump in Target that
pawn on A2 and it could be a big issue
yeah massive issue long term you might
have to tie down your queen or a very
strong kind of heavy piece just to
defend this loan uh this loan weakness
on A2 but okay he doesn't rush into this
level of ronin he keeps his options open
first kicking away the white Rook maybe
asking it to step back and then he might
go for this plan that we highlighted
still very similar very thematic from
the Sicilian Defense of course both of
these players play that opening too so
they'll be using their patent pattern
recognition using some of the ideas
borrowing them for this middle game okay
the White Queen slides across looks like
slightly superficial I actually like
it's a fancy move there is that if when
A3 happens we can actually take on A3
now of course and you can't take back
and I'm just going to say okay cool yeah
I have the double Pawn here I know it's
weak but it is a pawn right now a pawn
is a pawn right as the Astro says you
know uh the president of the president
of the pond Grabbers Club you know like
he likes to have the that extra Pawn so
I can't take it and hold it there and
the queen is doing a great job of
defending the rook and actually stopping
in a potential A3 for the time being
yeah actually the more I look at it the
more I like it a multi-purpose move as
you mentioned that James and uh still
difficult for level and if he can't push
his a pawn forward to come up with the
plan
um okay wow talking of a plan he moves
his Rook I said the last move was
superficial for white the White Queen
looks odd there but the black looks uh
black Rook looks even odd on the F7
Square what do we think of this one I
think he's just defending along the
seventh rank so that now his Knight is
more free to move both Knights are
actually capable of jumping and I just
want to give a quick shout out to Maxine
Russia lagrav he actually threw his
third game he lost on purpose because
Vladimir kramuck Mouse slipped in a
great position so Maxine decided to
return the favor and give him the third
game so it is two to one in Maxim's
favor but that is a really great gesture
of sportsmanship so shout out to the
friendship with three names for giving
chronic that game back yeah wow we don't
see that happen so often but when it
does it really is amazing Maxine washer
legraff throws the third game because
Vladimir kramnik had a big mouth slip
losing the game losing his Queen in that
one so Robert that's really nice yeah
and we've seen this from dingley Wren
and Magus Carlson so in this online play
and I think Vladimir crumb is also
playing on his phone because he had some
PC issues so that's when Mouse tips are
even more likely so I gotta give a shout
out to both of those players in
particular Maxine vashilograph it's
really great Sportsman I think it was
nehal Serene as well everybody at this
point yeah
wow all right well so that much still
continues as does this one and we see
with the last move no more ideas of
Levon advancing with that a pawn it has
been stopped by vladislavartame I'm just
happy that ladislavartamyab doesn't have
two minutes on the clock right now not
yet Tanya he has fixed the structure on
that Queen side we've been talking about
black pushing his apron forward he's
prevented that forever but that does
come at the cost of holes and if you
look on that left side of the board the
Queen side there all of the light
squares belong to Black I'm really
liking how levon's just retreated his
Knight Black's light Square Bishop
actually exerts influence on both sides
of the board and white lacks Pawn breaks
uh Roberts mentioned it in previous days
Pawn breaks are the essence of nearly
every middle game position if you have
access to pawn breaks if you can change
the nature of the position open things
up for example for White's Bishops here
then you will have an advantage but
white is a bit stuck if you can't push
pawns forward then you're purely
maneuvering with pieces and that could
be uh fought against here I don't see
how you can maneuver those white pieces
effectively it is stuck it feels pretty
gross actually I mean the queen on C1
like it feels okay with the queen on C1
maybe we just need to Triple everything
on on the C file like Queen C2 and oh
Bishop E3 so you want the bishop E3
route maybe he wants to reroute with
Knight D2 and we already have a move
from Lavon there playing Knight F5
hitting the bishop there yeah this is
already looking kind of great for black
not gonna lie here yeah this does not
look very pleasant for artemio I think
something has gone wrong Lavon is
playing quickly and confidently and I
want to make mention of artemi of time
usage I think he knows that Lavon will
punish him unlike Fabiano who struggled
in some of the scrambles that they had
when they did not have much time Lavon
he plays very quickly throughout the
entire game and so I think he has a
totally different match strategy against
Levon it's only a two-game match before
you get a potential Armageddon with
bidding and I love the way that Lavon is
handling game one he's just getting
active he gave up the bishop pair but
that night hop into F5 saying I might
just get the bishop pair right back yeah
100 that last move by left retreating
the night was only retreated to go
forward anyway so very surprising
decision by our time you have moving the
bishop one step ahead head provoking
asking love to do exactly what he wanted
and now that night can actually go
further on to the center of the board on
that D4 square at the right moment as
well and we see our tamiyev going into
the think tank things have gone wrong
for white in the opening that's quite
clear James in this one absolutely it's
definitely wrong here so you may have to
make uh you know make it Dynamic of
course that just actually in terms of
speaking of chesterboard just bought the
syrup book today so I'm deaf and I went
through like the first three chapters so
I'm already feeling sure off like I'm
just feeling aggressive and dynamic like
we do every day but definitely more
today with uh something like Knight to
D2 yeah okay whatever you get the bishop
here but after I take back on E3 now you
can't put anything on D4 my knight can
actually swing into E4 and my light
Square Bishop is super strong look at
the bishop now I'm hitting C6 and I can
go into E4 maybe I go Queen C2 or C3 and
then and then put the Rook on the uh on
the uh the C file as well so you know I
got some plans here but definitely
something
um for artemia to think about yeah an
interesting move he's just it's Rook
across I like those ideas James I
preferred that one but okay simple
threat attacking a pawn he's trying to
loosen up that long diagonal that we
pointed out if for example black played
a careless move like pushing his Pawn
forward there will be tricks along this
diagonal suddenly this Black Knight on
C6 is loose so it's just uh he's just
asking a question he's just saying okay
how are you going to deal with that one
mate and uh it's not clear love on a
running of course solid position we like
Black's chances but a big threat to deal
with and uh we'll let him make that
decision meanwhile the game between
Wesley so and Magnus Carlson looks like
it's heating up some strange stuff going
on in that one very creative play by
Wesley so he's actually sacrificed a
second Pawn why does two pawns down for
the moment and okay three more at the
moment and black has got a Pawn on C3
the king is still in the center but this
looks like very materialistic play by
Magnus Carlsen and it could be very
dangerous for him right now it could be
but he's still munching away on his food
munching away on those pawns and he's
munching away on the clock as well yes
Wesley's the one munching away on the
clock really behind here five minutes
and it's only one move 14 here Wesley
needs to compensate for those two pawns
and black is only one move away from
castling if Magnus gets one more move
gets that black king to safety he's
gonna happily enjoy his material
advantage yeah this is a big problem for
Wesley so because sometimes when you
Gambit a couple pawns you get a quick
attack you get some checks against the
king that King is about to Castle and
White's Rook Pawn is also under attack
black has two pieces staring right at
that pawn so you know if you think oh
I'll just bring my knight backwards for
white take this Pawn on C3 You're Gonna
Lose That Rook Pawn as well and black
will be two pawns to the good this is
not looking good for Wesley so and you
know I keep shouting them out but I want
to give one more shout out to Vladimir
kramnik now because on the first move of
his game he pushes Pawn one square and
when uh maximum responded he then pushed
his Pawn the second Square so he
essentially gave the color back to
Maxine Russell
players are just the tip top in terms of
being General in the game wow some
amazing stuff going on in division two
and in this position as well you've been
mentioning about giving a check on D6 we
see that the black Bishop is the one
that is defending that square James can
Wesley be thinking about trying to trade
those Bishops by bringing it forward to
that E3 square and maybe if you take it
just put an intermediate check on D6
that's exactly what I was thinking about
in fact Bishop E3 I'm not sure why he
didn't play it as fast as I was thinking
it Bishop E3 is just like the automatic
move if Queen E7 we have Knight C7 there
right so Bishop E3 is really strong it
actually hits the bishop or of course
the engine's like nope not a move but of
course he's down material too as well
probably materialistic but Bishop B3 is
a really strong move here I think I mean
there's lots of even tricks even if you
play D6 Pawn D6 it loses the bishop C5
or maybe that loses but after takes I
can play Knight to D6 maybe oh I can't
play it yet pinky seven afterwards wow
lots of tactics yeah Queen takes check
King E7 gross it's about holding on for
black just about holding on correct but
Bishop B3 is very strong here but Magnus
is a calculator he is the World Champ
he's going to be able to see this so
Bishop B3 you got to get your pieces out
right what is Wesley doing
doing it's make a move it went so fast
the game has just started yeah the game
has just started I really like that
bishop move you suggested that and what
else I think that's the question
sometimes when you're getting low on
time which I always do myself you have
to just stop and ask yourself okay I'm
gonna be suffering anyway on the clock
so I need to create some Chaos on the
board and the only way to do that here
is to play Bishop E3 is to do something
create a threat set a trap otherwise
you're just six minutes down on the
clock and you're gonna be a clear Pawn
down or two for nothing so uh Wesley I
think he's in his own head too much just
uh kind of regretting his earlier
decisions but he needs to be in the
moment and just uh try to make the best
of this bad situation
that's yeah struggling here I think we
all sense it right when he gave away a
pawn and then started thinking after
Max's reply so I think he knew the idea
but not the specifics behind it and
that's a big problem when you're playing
at this highest level and I I want to
give a shout out to Wesley because he
decided to play ambitious chess today uh
but it's not going well and if Magnus
can convert this Advantage win the game
he'll have the white pieces and it's
only a two-game match that's scary so
for for Wesley he's doing what he did
yesterday we all were crediting him for
uh surviving the game against Hikaru he
blundered but he didn't lose that game
he needs to do that here as well well
the good thing is that the last few
moves he's played it quite fast and now
David is he looking at a jump with the
Knight too that really really juicy
Square on D5 yep you called it Tanya
that white knight is looking nice and
pretty in the center of the board that's
what we call an outpost it's cemented
there anchored by a white Pawn as well
we could see a scenario later where
Black's Bishop blacks light Square
Bishop that's still trapped at home uh
comes out and captures that Knight but
then we'll go down to an opposite color
Bishop position where drawing chances
the drawing margin will be very high so
white has one good piece that's a start
uh he needs to back it up however and uh
of course white will be the one on the
defensive because he's simply a pawn
down one strong piece is not enough to
compensate here because Black's dot
Square Bishop is just as strong as that
white knight this looks like a position
we'd get from the special Club opening
for example except there it would be
level material white is just a pawn down
now but active pieces Wesley's done a
good job over the last few moves I
notice how quickly Magnus is playing
James do you think he's playing now on
Wesley's clock he absolutely is he's
like yeah quick moves I mean I can just
make easy moves right improving the
position okay the work is a little bit
better on A7 and this A8 the reason
being is I can now double put more
pressure on the a pawn if I need to
maybe even play B5 or B6 at some point
right in the Rook can actually be active
on the seventh rank there so of course
Wesley is in time trouble here and he's
down a pawn and he's playing Magnus this
is just lots of things you gotta get
that out of your head like okay I gotta
just play the board here right but of
course magnet is moving very quickly and
confidently here and having a pawn he's
trying to convert yeah and right here
you see the Bishops the black Bishop
staring at the Knight you don't want to
take that if you are Magnus Carlson
because you take this Knight on D5 we
get a position with opposite color
Bishops you see the eval bar reacting
now we're equal because oftentimes with
Bishops of opposite colors even though a
side is down upon the position remains
balanced because you control one color
complex I control the other and that
means that we can't fend off on the
competing Square so I do not think that
Magnus just because he developed that
Bishop he's planning to take he wants to
eventually as James was saying bring
more pieces to the a file attack that
loose Pawn on A5 yeah nice multi-purpose
move that by Magnus Carlson on the last
go and Robert called it the black queen
came out white defended by stepping a
pawn forward holding on to this Central
Pawn and the Black Brook immediately
activated Wesley now uh on under
pressure in trouble actually on the
board and the clock because two of his
pieces will be tied down defending this
Pawn meanwhile black is going to start
earthquake asking questions uh to this
white king look how trapped it is
actually on this light Square on the
dark squares black is going to try and
come forward and break through later you
could definitely imagine this queen at
the right moment trying to dive in
either trading Queens off or going for a
checkmating attack white is a bit stuck
that's the problem it's hard to imagine
maximizing the white pieces even further
whereas blacks pieces uh could certainly
be improved I wouldn't be surprised as
well if the black porn later starts
stepping forward the black queen moves
out the way and it uses itself as a
battering ram to open up this weak white
king so uh yeah Advantage black he's
moved his Queen out the way first going
for that white Pawn in the corner and uh
later we'll see
black H pull nesting I think start
advancing this feels like a crush in
fact the reason why I say that is even
Wesley said I think in the interview
maybe yesterday or day before but he was
saying um he was like yeah you know I
had like two minutes and like versus 11
and like they I can't win that against
anybody and this is a situation where
he's down a lot of times I mean like
nine minutes almost for Magnus he's
under a minute here Wesley and there's a
lot of pressure on his position the
pieces don't look the greatest A5 is
actually uh attacked many times my
pieces look good I got a great night on
D5 but then what do I do all the pieces
are on the queen side of the board just
holding the pawn here right so we're
hoping for something here and I don't
have enough time says Wesley yeah this
is just very shocking and Magnus is
making it look really easy now we see
three pieces attacking the A5 Pawn only
two pieces for white are defending that
A5 Bond the queen and the Rook Magnus is
thinking about capturing that Bond but
then Wesley will manage to get some Play
Because Westy's Rook can jump to the
seventh rank also capture ring magnus's
Pawn on B7 and that's perhaps why he's
taking so much time in the position if
that's not what you go well he does it
he does it yeah the big problem for
white is even if you just say I get my
Pawn back your king is very unsafe back
there in the corner if your Rook ever
leaves the first rank it's not
immediately a back rank Checkmate but
with the dark squares being occupied by
Black's pieces notably that Bishop on C5
we are going to see some issues down on
the first rank yep first he's traded off
a set of Rooks this bishop is pretty
much pinned uh if it ever moves the
Black Rack uh Black Rack
will uh be vulnerable the black Rook
will dive down and uh this will end in a
checkmating attack so I wouldn't be
surprised if Magnus starts using his
Queen again he's kind of yo-yoed back
and forth with that black queen but
imagine her jumping in I could imagine
this queen move coming now massive
thread on the board if white does
nothing if white for example sidesteps
the queen then Rook takes Bishop will be
a threat the queen now distracted and
this will end in Checkmate very typical
meeting a pattern here with the black
queen and this white king so that's the
first move that comes to my mind maybe
there are others I'm sure Magnus will
find just as strong a move as this one
but uh yeah Wesley it's hard to imagine
him defending this one one minute left
and this is such a defenseless King such
a helpless King right now for white yeah
it feels like Magnus is playing all over
the board the king side and the queen
side He's Got The Rook coming into the
attack from the a file the two Bishops
which are targeting White's King and
with the black pieces to get this kind
of a position right out of the opening
where Wesley's down a minute it could
not have gone worse for him yeah just uh
already as Robert mentioned from move
four or five it was a quick downhill
spiral for Wesley so when you get caught
in the opening especially with white it
seems in this tournament uh you do tend
to get punished black scoring extremely
highly in the chessable Masters so far
um all of these top players just so well
prepared it might be a lesson in playing
to your style and James I mean Magnus we
know that he likes to swing Wesley he
usually likes to play Common so you
think he made the wrong choice of course
the game looks bad for him but just
psychologically yeah psychologically I
think he should have just went solid I
mean he actually has an E4 course where
he actually against he plays the solid
stuff in his course but didn't play it
here against Magnus right so that's what
he recommends yeah this queen H4 move is
now on the board I mean I was even
thinking even if you play King H2 here
in this position you might be able to
still play Rook A2 and queen E1 this is
such a very very bad position Bishop H3
might be on top there's King H2 we still
might be able to get away with Rook A2
here but uh is there anything else
stronger I could imagine the black Dart
score Bishop coming in as well just
controlling some squares inching towards
that white king Wesley shaking his head
um yeah it's very much about the Styles
here Wesley just feels like he's just
not in the flow today and in this kind
of Sprint towards the Finishing Line
two-game match that is a bad sign Magnus
just ruthless in this game you've got to
say really merciless and will he find
the killer blow he doesn't need to he
takes a timeout himself whites King got
safe the black king got safe and now the
threat will persist you know these are
the most dangerous kind of moves in this
position where you just pass the ball to
your opponent and they're already very
difficult position to defend and Wesley
down on Seconds come back comes back
brings The Rook back to the defense is
there an immediate blow because we see
the eval Bar says that this is game over
for white do you guys see an immediate
finish here the thing is you don't need
an immediate finish you're a pawn up
you've got more active pieces your
opponent's got a weaker King the
evaluation bar might reflect that just
the fact that the advantage long term
it's not going away anytime soon you can
cash in whenever you want I'm not sure I
don't see anything immediate do uh do
you James Robert but nothing yet I mean
I like a rook A3 just to put a piece
there and then maybe
um I'm hinting at Bishop H3 things but I
need more wow
[Applause]
sometimes I forget I'm a Jedi
yeah what a nasty looking move James's
points are sometimes there's sacrifices
in this position and The Rook along the
third rank could be problematic as it
slices across the board and Wesley stops
those kind of threats no more sacrifices
available to Black for the time being
but that's not a pretty move to play
look at that Bishop on A2 it's a very
defensive piece and it's looking into
its own Rook yeah you can just run away
Rook a two Queenie one like I just gotta
do it I got the sheer off book fire on
the board it's all chessable okay I just
have to do it I don't have to bro like
how does he defend this now of course
engine defends it oh Rook B1 maybe yeah
okay just yeah
in this case I'm just like Zach you know
when I fire on the board book definitely
is gonna have you sacking Everything
Chad definitely get its own chest yeah
calculation over everything that's the
first thing he'll be looking for Magnus
Carlson uh he'll be looking at moves
such as Rook takes Bishop he'll figure
out it doesn't quite work the black
checkmating attack isn't quite ready and
then he'll look for options he'll go
back to square one and okay you can
trade Rooks of course but if you want to
keep them on you could just step to any
other square and White's formation is
still looking very very clumsy there we
go he Retreats the whole way back and
Wesley wants to guard his first rank
he's really terrified of that idea you
mentioned James uh he just wants to stop
the black queen from jumping in but how
can Magnus up the pressure is it time to
bring the dark Squad Bishop into the
attack as well bring it to have to bring
it to that G3 Square so many weaknesses
around the white king is it time to
strike with the bishop I love that idea
I really think it's good because that
black queen is kind of a lone attacker
and it can't get it done by itself so
bringing the dark Square Bishop to help
putting in line with the queen on the
same diagonal that will allow black to
deliver some vicious checks and likely
Checkmate in the near future so I
actually don't see very easy moves for
Wesley he might even lose on time just
because of how difficult this is to
defend Yep this looks like a killer
threat I don't really see how to guard
against this for example if white just
moves you can uh for example give that
check and take this Pawn this will end
in Checkmate just to put that on the
board to the white king defenseless
nothing around and okay it's on the
board he has swung its Rook across the
train maybe you've been finding all
these Amazing checkmating Ideas I have
to say have you been doing your puzzle
rush in the morning I actually have but
uh you've been setting me up Tanya
you're giving me the assist and I'm just
putting the ball in the back in the net
and uh here I think this check looks
like the most simple when the king moves
I mean I'm assuming it goes back then
there must be something here it feels
like there's something in the air but uh
what is the killer blow we still need to
find it Wesley defending tenaciously
here but 30 seconds left it must be to
do with some sacrifices on this square
but do you rush it maybe you don't need
to maybe you improve this black Rook
first Wesley's living life on the brink
whoa what a move by uh that's beautiful
stuff yeah that's really nice because if
the Knight captures that Bishop which is
legal Black's not going to recapture the
bishop on A2 is loose so that's why
Wesley slides his Queen over and a queen
trade does not mean the attack is
physical look at this white can hardly
move the bishop is stuck in place the
king will not be able to leave the back
Rank and then black can push those pawns
black is up a pawn I was saying earlier
opposite colored Bishops often gives
good drunk chances not here an attack
persists yeah that white Bishop okay has
just moved with a check but I was going
to say it's the worst Bishop you'll ever
see it was staring at its own pawns here
Wesley's begging for The Rook exchange
maybe that's still strong for black but
you never ever accept you go for the
Checkmate you go for that white king
even with the absence of Queen sir that
white king is a clear Target and uh one
threatened right now on that back rank
on the first Rank and Wesley has to
block with his Rook he has to just cross
his fingers and hope that he can keep
that black Rook out of the game but
slowly and surely Magnus will infiltrate
he will invade is it time to start
moving those King side pawns F5 E4
create a passer he first starts with the
h-bomb and Wesley getting his King out
of the king of the Kill Zone yeah out of
the Kill Zone for now but uh look at the
black king it's coming into the Kill
Zone it's gonna try and uh trap the
enemy King and black is playing with all
three pieces black is playing with an
extra Pawn of course White's Bishop
sidelined
any saving chances no no nothing yeah
James like let's uh hang our heads for a
moment here but no there's just no
chance Magnus Carlson when he knows the
game is over he is not afraid to
liquidate because he has his vision he
sees that this end game that we have
right here it's not just oh one extra
Pawn should have chances no he's all the
activity in the world white can hardly
move staving off all these threats seems
impossible the black king is entering
along the dark squares and white can't
attack anything the one hope that Wesley
has now is to bring his Bishop all the
way around Loop it to the other side of
the board but Black's pawns are all
defended so this just is unpleasant yeah
amazing play by Madness but I have to
say Wesley really impressive how one he
didn't get checkmated in that position
the game is still on he's been defending
a really difficult position for the last
I don't know how many moves playing on
seconds
yep but uh unfortunately he hasn't
managed to fight back or turn things
around or cause any complications yes
he's held on he survived but that's all
he's doing and uh it's not fun he's uh
going through hell right now uh trying
to hold on to this game look at that
black pawn in the center it's a past
Pawn I love how Magnus has used his own
King that black king an active attacker
as well and uh once that black porn
continues advancing that white Rook is
going to be stuck forever you're
sexually playing without a piece yeah
well this does look winning for Magnus
and I see our evaluation bar on the
other game says that it is also winning
for Lavon aronian let's take a look at
that one as things are heating up there
Magnus has everything under control is
our time we have in big trouble
it feels that way of course we see the
evaluation bar the computer says yes
black is winning here but what is The
Knockout blue unlike the other game it's
actually level materials so if there are
a bunch of exchanges if the Queens
disappear then I'll tell you can breathe
a sigh of relief he might just be fine
so the stakes are high in this one of
course the stakes are always high on the
clock the hard time we have but uh can't
live on put the boot in can he strike
while that iron is hot nice move hey
look in the White Queen it looks similar
I mean black right now actually isn't up
any material but we are about to see a
past e-pawn so Magnus has one that wants
to go forward Here lavon's pawn can also
push the white king is less safe than
the black king and many of Black's
attackers going in oh Queen F4 he
doesn't have much time played in I think
LeBron can give a check either on D4 or
C5 but that e-pawn is going to push
let's just find out he made that move
with one second on the clock it's a
three second increment unbelievable our
time yeah with no time on the clock
manages to do this that's what they call
brinksmanship he's uh he's always doing
it I'll tell you just how he has control
over that extra one second as incredible
but as Robert says plenty of strong
moves here for black I think the most
tempting too are queen checks there we
go the queen hits the white king the
white king is going to be forced into
the corner oh big fellow you're gonna
have to relax there my guy Rook F2
that's crazy I mean he already in time
travel and he is in some trouble yeah
this is this is the Rick F2 you had to
go King H1 right yeah it looks like uh
that Rook has walked into a self pin and
I don't think he's lost on time uh
vladis love I'll tell me if that clock
will correct it say D1 but there we go
and The Rook is lost
material gain for black here and this
should be decisive
yeah this is this is one-sided right now
because right now a block has a rook for
a knight and a pawn he's just going
right after the Central Pawn if you
protect it with your king the move F6 to
F5 is played just imagine the pawn going
forward it's going to pin so instead he
brings Knight up but now you're losing a
pawn you don't even have a pawn for the
exchange this is quite straightforward
for a player of Levon uh aronen's
caliber yep if there are more pieces on
the board this material balance you
might have some chances you might have
some compensation but a low night can
never fight against a long-range piece
like The Rook uh The Rook especially
with pawns on both sides of the board
will be able to uh play a multi-purpose
role the White Knight is stuck it's a
short range piece can't
wow and as we expected Magnus Carlsen
has won his first game against Wesley so
with the black pieces Wesley in game two
the final game has to win on demand to
level the score that's going to be a
tough task playing black with Magnus
especially psychologically as well with
not just the result but the way Magnus
won the first game it's going to be a
tough one for Wesley and it looks like
it's going to be the same story in this
match it looks likely at this point our
temmiev knows he's going down he's
crashing down to defeat in this game and
he's gonna have to strike with the black
pieces I don't know what's in the air
what's in the water during this
tournament accessible Masters every time
people are winning with black uh if why
is White's opening Advantage it's just
disappeared those chessable courses have
ruined chess for the white players for
those white pieces in fact he does right
Chesterville does make it where even
lower rated players can keep up in
theory but you do have to do the work
and it is intense and you need to do
more than just opening work obviously
work on tactics and in game two as well
which you can find all of this on
chessables what's her favorite
on the middle game that'd be mastering
middle games by panchenko it's uh
actually a very strong book in fact it's
just a book of 2600 level he was like
yeah we had he put 2600s in the room and
they gave him these problems and you had
to solve them in fact it's a very very
good book on mastering middle games yeah
James ask you I saw that you were
studying chessable you had over a 1 000
day streak about three and a half years
every single day every single day in
fact I mean when I was chilling we was
eating I was doing transferable while
before we were on my phone all the time
I do Festival uh 24 hours a day if I
could
and it seems like this end game I don't
think LeBron needs chessball to convert
this he is up a rook for just a night
and black has a pass Pawn on the king
side so if we cut the board in half we
see white with the best don't take them
on knife Forks Knights are very tricky
if you take that pawn you actually
blunder your rook and that's why Lavon
pins it he's still not going to take it
because the night check yeah but you can
just go after the H Pawn the other end
of the board get your king to safety
attacking the a pawn and then you've
always got the option to slide your Rook
to the king side happy camper pick up H2
Queen the pawn it's Pawn quality not
Quan he just pushed them keep pushing
his balls sacrifice one it's captured
sacrifice the other it's captured then
the H3 Pawn very Advanced is going to
become a queen yup and uh with that
knowledge Artemis does resign this game
is over and everyone takes the lead
wow so we've got two wins in game one of
the elimination bracket both with black
pieces that means that the players with
the black pieces have to now play for a
win in the next one impressive play
James there by both aronian and Magnus
what impressed you the most well
absolutely of course what impressed me
the most was Magnus how it was just
domination I mean that's the Magnus that
you see when he just dominates when
Magnus is informed you better watch out
it's scary as nobody touching him he was
eating a burrito chilling yeah yeah you
can bring it yeah okay all right just
making moves not even really paying
attention here it just felt like it was
very nonchalant it was very easy for him
to take down somebody as strong as
Wesley so yeah let's take a look at our
score line the first game is over this
is a best of two which means that Wesley
slow and vladislav our time have to win
on demand to go into a betting
Armageddon it's not gonna be easy
against Magnus and love on our onion who
were on fire in game one we are going to
be back with the action but for now
we're going to take a shot twitch break
[Music]
foreign
and welcome to my keep it simple 1d4
course
[Music]
foreign
it's a special time in the Chess World a
big month for the Chess World as the
world championship starts in just four
days
at the end of the month we will have a
new world champion Magnus Carlsen played
his last classical chess game as world
champion take a look at what he had to
say after that match
[Music]
I guess that concludes it for your
classical career as world champion is
that correct yeah I think so how does
that feel no that's okay most
importantly right now I think draw is a
decent result for our team and it looks
pretty good on the other boards yeah
obviously it's an honor to be part of
History like that but I really wanted to
put more pressure on I wanted to win I
wanted to send him out you know not on a
high so uh yeah kind of mixed feelings
but I can't complain too much
do you feel you've finished off in style
last world champion in classical chess
yeah it's okay
um I scored this weekend was
um was good play wasn't great but I
might become Norwegian Champion for the
first time for for teams so that would
be nice
Magnus Carlson not world champion buying
this Crossing is that sort of a
different feel I still have two titles
I'm secretly hoping he's going to come
back in like 20 years and show the young
things the lesson and take the title
back but uh but yeah it's very special
and um yeah I just I just hope you
enjoyed it as much as I did
I love that when he says I've still got
two titles and still World rapid and
World Blitz Champion but it does feel
like the end of an era David you and
Magnus are such good friends how was
that did you analyze after that game we
did it was friendly afterwards but
beforehand you know he ghosted me he
didn't talk to me he was uh I think he
was trying to scare me and I was super
nervous I barely slept the night before
I played quite boring chess I've got to
say with white I managed to hold the
drop but uh yeah it was tense and it was
an honor of course to play his last
classical game
to be part of it yeah special moment
there yes yes it was wow and we do hear
the clock ticking it is special moments
here as well in the accessible Masters
as two players will be knocked out and
we are about to start a game two off the
losers bracket the elimination bracket
Magnus Carlsen and Levon aronian have
won their first game or Tammy have
Wesley so have to win on demand to force
an Armageddon are we expecting a
comeback here Robert
I know I'm supposed to say yes but my
answer is no because Magnus and Lavon
get the white pieces they know how to
get the job done they're not going to
play risky chess I just don't see it
happening James when you're in that
situation you're playing against a
player like Madness against a player
like love with the black pieces where
are your chances well in something an
aggressive opening I mean whatever they
play you just got to just take it to him
hey what is the most aggressive that I
can do maybe try to take him out of the
book here but Wesley looks dejected yeah
actually and then he's just sitting back
leaning back maybe listen to some look
at the face there the smirk like all
right let's just make this happen let's
get this over with and we go to Sicilian
yeah the Sicilian we saw Wesley have
some success with this against Nakamura
yesterday he didn't quite win the game
but he got a good position and uh Magnus
do we think he's going to play Bishop B5
check just like Nakamura did bringing
out that white light Square Bishop
uh looks like he's pausing Magnus
choosing that strategy to avoid anything
too risky uh at this early stages wow
that's so annoying oh my goodness that
is so annoying I'm telling you there's a
lot of adjustable courses on this right
now too Bishop B5 check is so annoying
because then you have to play Knight D7
and then like you don't get anything
you're like look he's already here today
come on man I saw it yesterday right but
Wesley actually almost beat hikara in
this exact variation so Wesley he should
have some happy memories he almost lost
later in the game but the opening was a
resounding success but I think Magnus he
looked at the game he devours every
single chess game that's played pretty
much he knows what to do he strikes in
Center he's playing a different
variation than the card did yesterday
yeah and uh Magnus he used Bishop B5
track this exact variation all those
years ago in uh in his match against
Anand just when he needed a draw with
the white pieces he was able to lock it
down and it was a very similar variation
to this one so white has just
established that clamp we call it the
moroxie bind with those two white pawns
on e4 and D4 uh E4 and C4 sorry the
White Queen of course sandwiched in
between and it's going to be very hard
for black to break out black is lacking
behind the development and in order to
equalize this game if not nothing more
of course in order to just equalize you
need to be very accurate so uh Wesley
taking a pause here yeah guys while
Wesley is taking a pause we need to
pause for oh photograph right now
because
there is a big Instagram contest on so
send us your selfies show us how you are
watching the Champions chess tour you
gotta send it on Instagram using the
hashtag chess Champs and you could win a
50 router for uh adjustable course so do
it now I'm sending mine you tricked me
you know I don't like content for the
sake of content you know I don't like
posing for Social Media stuff and you
just put your phone there I know it's a
listen to you so I was like okay okay
I'm doing it you got me you got me if I
told you beforehand you'd never have
agreed zero chance
yeah I know you well well does Lavon
aronia know our tummy are well enough to
decide what opening approach her to take
with the white pieces against a very
aggressive our time you have who has to
win on demand and we see a sicilian
another song
he knows what to do C3 Sicilian for the
Killian that's exactly what I like right
here of course I'm a big fan of this now
of course you can play this very
aggressively but you also can play very
solidly it's a a a very special place in
my heart with the C3 Sicilian guys lots
of chessable courses on this one my
second one on child support will
actually be on the C3 Sicilian so just
to let you all know dropping it already
it's already coming out C3 Cecile David
you like this too don't you I do I've
played this opening since I was six
years old and it's still my main answer
to the Sicilian these days I mix things
up a bit but uh yeah I've seen these
chessable courses come out coming up
with these uh new ideas that I hadn't
discovered uh with the eight of engines
of course just refreshing ideas and uh
okay of course it's got a solid
reputation as well which helps when you
only need a draw I've even used this I
think in 2009 to draw against Magnus
myself I just wanted to lock things down
and that's the case for 11 aronian in
his game here a draw is enough so why
not play a solid opening with some
attacking chances James that's how you
play it oh I play with more of a
aggressive intentions here I do play
Knight F3 here most times
um I also Play Bishop C4 mini lines
there's also I mean uh the book right
now on uh chaturville with uh what is it
Surya sorry again ghouli I think his
last name is but very very strong he has
a lifetime repertoire for semi-terrash
and the nimso Indiana excellent courses
there but here I mean he actually he has
so many new ideas in the series just
saying that I've never seen so his and
great addition to your C3 Sicilian
players out there to grab that chorus in
fact yeah and vladis love I'll tell me
if he will not like this he doesn't like
it when his opponents are trying to go
for him trying to be very direct and
okay he's looking off to his left our
right on the screen and that is the face
that players make when they're trying to
recall something trying to remember
something or trying to pull something
from the Deep recesses of their memory
and okay after a while he has brought
his Knight out still Mainline stuff
James absolutely still Mainline Bishop
C4 rain we just back up to B3 here and
he can take the second Pawn now if you
take the second Pawn on C3 we actually
go Knight to G5 here very strong play so
D takes C3 then we go Knight to G5
forcing an E6 and then after E6 you can
actually Castle or play moves like Queen
to E2 just very very aggressive now you
don't actually need to play this way
from LeBron because I mean he's already
you know winning he just needs a draw
here so he doesn't have to play this way
but it's very very doable here you can
also take with the Knight on C3 too as
well yeah really aggressive stuff
already threatening Checkmate on this
Square that's the type of way you can
play the C3 Sicilian if you are an
aggressive player like James like live
on Iranian and uh already vladislava
tamiev he's hesitating the best move the
main move is to push this ball neither
one or two squares but it does lead to
very forcing lines very direct play and
when you need to win at all costs you
want to take your opponent outside their
comfort zone early that's why this is
such a good opening choice I think from
Lavon he's narrowed opponent's path
taking away so many options taking away
all the tension from the opening the
last of no longer playing chess he's
playing I need to win so the objective
best move may not be best for his
Overall winning chances he needs to take
risks he did just push his Pawn the
center Levon immediately takes on Passat
no that was not an illegal move for
those who knew to chess learn on poisson
it's your way you take it as if it moved
one square and so Lavon he doesn't mind
trading pieces he does not mind that
liquidation he only needs a half point
and well the position is quite balanced
it's a normal development white is about
to Castle kingside and I really like the
choice from LeBron Ronin yes Ma hard
opening approach there by love needing
only a draw he decides not to play the
open Sicilian but the very solid alapan
trades we see happen in the center you
have been talking about how white is
looking to trade more pieces off are you
expecting him to recapture the D4 Pawn
with a piece and he might isolate his
Pawn I mean play in that old school
style it doesn't matter if your Pawn
structure doesn't look great as long as
you vacate Square for your night because
that see through Pawn is in the night's
path but I just feel like LaVon he's
right at home and his time manager
suggests as much he is more time than he
started with he's playing the moves
instantly I think he should take with
the pawn on D4 then develop his a knight
he could try to trade Queens instead
nobody's trading off everything in the
center but look at artemia he does not
want Simplicity yep he doesn't want
those obvious exchanges he's happy to
bypass that white Pawn he takes it back
with his bishop and now we see what we
call an iqp isolated Queen's Pawn but it
does give white a lot of control you
control these quests pretty much forever
that pawn is only going to be weak in
the same answer if there are a bunch of
exchanges later also the Black Knights
are not ready yet to occupy the square
in front of this Pawn in front of this
Pawn the Black Knights want to blockade
of course but they will struggle to do
so so I've actually had this position
plenty of times myself from the white
side and I really believe in White's
attacking chances often James you'll see
this idea sliding back with the bishop
hitting this weak one and uh checkmating
plans attacking plans all over the shop
100 you have Greek gifts sacrifices here
if you are familiar Bishop to C2 and
then sacking on H7 send them to heaven
after King tc7 Knight to G5 check and
lots of nasty things can happen now of
course you gotta be careful because the
king actually walks out to G6 believe it
or not and if you're not able to
Checkmate the king I mean and then
you're you you sacked for nothing
there's it's it's a lot of play you got
to be very sharp here but it is the fact
that we are aiming at that side of the
board in fact you actually see these
positions a lot in the the uh no this is
what is it the um ball Carol Khan the uh
pan off pan off variations of the
Carroll Khan you'll see a lot of this
where like we play against iqp and your
white has the IQ P we play Bishop to C2
Knight to E4 Rook E1 you can even Rook
lift Rook E4 to H4 very aggressive type
of Chess here and uh ronian is
definitely going to find these moves wow
he is looking at all these ideas but
first he brings the Knight to the center
now we've been talking about Levon
having the isolated Queen spawn for
artemia there are two strategies right
you either block the isolated Queen
spawn or you attack it David that Knight
on E7 is it hinting to go to the F5
Square trying to put pressure on D4 as
well as blocking the diagonal that you
have been mentioning with the attack for
white yeah you're quite right Tanya
there's uh two viable options or two
viable strategies in this type of
position one is the first one you
mentioned actually to try and attack
this Pawn the one downside here is that
you might be allowing either here or on
the next few moves this Pawn to step
forward if you do step forward with this
Pawn successfully for white you simply
trade off all the pieces and look how
symmetrical the pawn structure is here
if you want a draw which level on the
road would be happy with then you can go
for this option so again it's Levon
bullying or tell me if he's saying yes
you can go for this but I will happily
step forward trade everything off force
a draw all the pieces will come off the
board that vacuum Hoover and uh yeah
we'll see equality the other technique
is to blockade but here for example if
you blockade again level neuronian might
be feeling cynical you can attack you
can bring out the White Queen for
example but if you just want a level
position you trade off all the pieces in
the center and you say okay are you
really going to beat me from this
position symmetrical pawns again I think
the answer is no so I just love our
Tammy if the two plans he wants to go
for he can't because of the match
situation and the answer is no it's
using both vacuum and Hoover
day five but I also just want to say
that our team if he wants chaos we're
not getting in this game but we are
getting it in division two in that match
between chromic and Maxine Russell Grove
in game four mvl needed a draw to move
on he hadn't even positioned and he
disconnected and lost so we are just
here absolute pandemonium in division
two that's going to arm again with
bidding I don't know if Vladimir if his
um he's playing on his phone I don't
know if that will hold up I don't know
if Maxine's getting his connection back
but whatever is happening in division
two has to happen for Wesley so and
Vlada silver team they need chaos
because otherwise they are going to be
sent home wow so much drama in division
two and there is dramatic action on this
board because once again our Tamia is
down on the clock by almost seven
minutes what is going on here he needs
to make a move he needs to make it fast
but he's struggling to find a way to
create chances in this position James do
you see a way for black to be able to
just create a mess somehow yeah creating
a mess here especially against the C3
system is very hard it's probably one of
the unknown it's the most annoying thing
in fact even there's a tweet you can
actually find it on Twitter you can
Google it Magnus Carlson C3 Sicilian
Twitter Google it it'll come up there's
a tweet that he has that he says I hate
playing against the elephant and that's
exactly I'm like wow world champion
himself says it so of course it has to
be some Merit to it it's a really
annoying opening to face and I mean
especially when you're trying to play
aggressive you need to play for a win
it's very difficult yeah that's awesome
stock chest Champs show us how you are
watching and following the action on the
Champions chest door it has to be in
landscape mode so don't forget that and
we will feature it on our show
now do you want to know a secret that
game I played against Magnus if he'd
played the Sicilian against me I was
going to play the alapin just because I
knew he hated it
and uh actually that's the main
attraction I think that's a good uh kind
of template for all openings choose
lines that your opponents will hate it
might not need to be the best move might
not be the most uh kind of computer
approved move but if your opponents hate
facing those types of positions then it
will work very effectively and um yeah
some nice photos there somebody's coming
in
from all over the world watching this is
uh really nice to see places to the
names yeah you've done going loving it
look what you've done look what you've
started don't hit it don't you robbers I
appreciate I actually do like seeing
people from all over the world watching
chess getting excited by hello everybody
I just you know I personally don't do it
myself but I do appreciate all of you
but I don't think that last summer time
appreciates his current position because
he's just making small moves here and
there and you see the evaluation bar
going up in White's hair there actually
might be sacrifices in the air that
artemium has to watch out for his King
is actually not that safe despite the
fact that pawns are in front of it we
usually like to Castle behind our moat
but that moat can be destroyed with a
couple sacrifices yeah there's
sacrifices to watch out for Robert I'm
not sure whether they work right now but
they're in the air right Knight takes F7
would be really typical really thematic
just wrecking the black porn structure
as we mentioned maybe not here but the
computer says yeah it's kind of fine uh
and uh here there would be ideas for
example taking this porn with your
Bishop with your queen and this black
king is feeling the heat of course the
game goes on it gets really complicated
Levon he's going to be looking at that
but not maybe uh right now he will want
to build up first he'll he's only going
for that sacrifice if the circumstances
allowed David does this work Knight
takes G6 H takes and then rookie six
boom
well getting off the board after Pawn
takes hitting splitting Queen takes and
then when he goes to the corner
hitting with Queen H3 that's for me oh
my goodness but you better be doing your
tactics that's all I'm saying you better
be doing your time gosh yeah this ends
in Checkmate black and throw a queen in
the way but it doesn't change the fact
that uh the king is trapped I think that
there was a hidden idea there a hidden
defensive resource after Rook takes Pawn
black could actually flick his Bishop
back pin and not quite win it's not like
pin and survive oh you play Rook D6 okay
I was like how's the engine not I was
just not just crushing after Christmas
but instead lab just keeps it everything
under control because that is the math
situation he needs just a draw as does
Magnus Carl soon let's head over to the
game Magnus Carlsen taking on a Wesley
saw and wow this looks interesting but
is black the only one who's in trouble I
feel like Black's down like five Tempe
like black pieces are not moved off the
back rank why it's Castle developed all
the pieces Rooks are connected the
Queen's in the center so it feels like
black is several turns behind but if we
do some quick math Black's a pawn ahead
so if you're Wesley you actually
appreciate this type of position you
want chaos you want to have imbalances
and here you he has just that the
problem for him is he has not developed
his King is stuck in the center and for
just one Pawn it's well worth it for
white to go for this initiative so I
actually don't see how black continues
here you want to keep taking pawns
you're opening up files that's the
nature of losing pawns Rooks get open
lines the D file is open the C file
could be open next and if we swap pawns
on B3 that could be very dangerous yeah
and this is a great lesson for everyone
at home I think just when you are happy
with the draw you shouldn't Play Passive
chess you should go for the win anyway
you will get chances later on to trade
off pieces to head into equal positions
head into end games if you really need
to but don't let it affect influence
your decisions early in the game too
much and Magnus here he only needs a
draw but he's playing his best chess
he's playing his open uh World
Championship repertoire and uh he's
going for the kill I'm terrified here if
I'm Wesley so uh six minutes as well on
the clock how is he gonna get those
pieces out you need at least three moves
to Castle White's gonna have something
to say about it in the meantime David
you're saying that Magnus is using his
world championship repertoire I mean
that is scary enough already you don't
want to face that when you need to win
with the black pieces big task ahead of
Wesley but first the big question is how
does he complete his development in this
position
yeah that's you know what's funny the
the thing here is uh the fact that you
know Robert mentioned oh yeah he's up
you know if you do a quick check he's up
a pawn you're like really weird like no
nobody feels that extra Pawn because all
his pieces are on the back rank I mean
you take on B3 I might even have a rook
C1 as an in-between move first and let
you have I don't care you can take
whatever you like you're gonna get mated
in the center of the board here I mean
look at the eval bar go crazy here right
you know I mean what do you even do 97
runs in the Knight D6 Knight F6 damages
the structure Knight H6 oh come on why
is your night on H6 right this is
terrible I mean do you move the bishop
can you move the bishop is the question
Bishop E7 and then hopefully try to get
Knight F6 in Castle yeah it's just
horrible whoops I've jumped to the other
game Sorry that one also interesting but
yeah you're right just look at these
pieces that's all you need to look at in
this position one glance and black is in
trouble maybe the best is to actually
trade off in the center bring the Black
Knight out okay at least you've gained
one move to hit the White Queen but the
problem is after Queen takes porn it's
back to level material while it's still
ahead in development Queens might come
off it's an end game you'll not beat
Magnus Carlson in an equal or slightly
worse end game uh here so yeah it's uh
tough times for Wesley so it's a dilemma
and he knows the best move is probably
not going to help him win this one so
again needs to take more risks but where
are they
yeah this is a nightmare and we've been
talking about the trade on e4 also black
has got no option to even develop the
bishop you put that Bishop in front of
the king and suddenly that pawn on F7
might be following there are tactics
everywhere David and it just looks like
this is going to be a nightmare also on
the clock four and a half minutes will
he survive this oh it's all retirement
earlier the objective best move is not
best for the match it's best for the
game and if your best decision is black
is to take the Knight with your bishop
and then develop as David was indicating
that might involve a queen trade and not
only you're not going to beat Magnus in
that position you're going to be
slightly worse and you have no winning
chances you need really Chancellor you
might have to lose the game in order to
win it that's the nature of being down
and imagine for Wesley he's not castled
he really has very few choices
he landed up in so much trouble out of
the opening that's the same narrative in
this one while Wesley does go for the
decision that David was mentioning with
trying to ease off the pressure but
going into this end game you're not
going to find your winning chances here
James not at all I actually saw a slight
head shake from Wesley before he went
for this line he just you know like you
just kind of composing himself was like
you know hey it is what it is I play
good I'll get some money out of here but
I'm facing elimination I'm playing
Magnus Carlson here I need to play for a
win from this position which is
extremely hard to do and I mean it's
just not going to happen
I'm unlikely to happen and look at what
Magnus is doing he's just removing any
sources of potential counter play he's
traded off his Bishop for that black
knight because maybe the Black Knight
long term would have sat on a nice
pretty Square in the center now if you
compare uh the pieces compare what's
left on the board that white knight is
beautiful it's just a superb piece right
now it is clearly Superior to that black
Bishop White's Pawn structure also much
better black has a couple of isolated
pawns a set of doubled pawns blacks
Rooks not reaching open lines this is
one-way traffic and I think it's very
minimum here equality for white well it
looks like Magnus Carlsen is on cruise
mode in this one let's jump over to the
other game with action still on in Lavon
versus
managed to create some chances in this
position he's done quite well the
problem for him right now is the clock
but the position is good and the reason
I say that we have material imbalances
white has two Bishops black two nights
but look at that Knight on D5 it's a
stallion you can't kick it out of there
it's protected by another Knight it's
protected by pawns it's blocking that
open file for the white Rook whereas on
the other line black has this open B
file The Rook is happily saying they're
keeping the bishop at Bay I really like
the way artemia is playing this he is
trying to pick off those Advanced White
pawns and I feel like it could be
dangerous territory for levonaronien
yeah we often talk about the bishop pan
here White's Bishops look like they have
great potential but surprisingly
counter-intuitively a pair of knights
actually sometimes fight quite well
against the bishop pair as long as they
protect each other as long as they're
both on stable squares and here that's
very much the case as uh Robert
mentioned I like that term stallion that
Knight on D5 uh a real stud there and uh
meanwhile grabbing pawns I don't see a
way white can actually satisfactorily
defend that C5 Pawn the black queen is
simply going to go across two squares
take it off the board you're going to go
material up yes those Bishops will
compensate somewhat but I don't know if
it's enough suddenly Levon aronian maybe
he's been playing a bit too quickly he's
still got more than 10 minutes on the
clock but he had more promising
Alternatives earlier on he's imbalanced
it which is the first sin when you're
trying to play uh safe chess trying to
play for a draw and somehow he has to
back it up he has to switch mode now
level on Iranian no more positional
chess he has to play the position played
dynamically and get those Bishops
working
not easy yeah of course with the bishop
here I definitely favor the Bishops I'm
a big fan I mean even they say sometimes
being down a pawn sometimes even two
pawns you have the bishop pair it
depends on the position obviously but
definitely the bishop pair can
compensate for at least a pawn sometimes
so okay we take on C5 when if he gets
this Pawn on C5 we probably have to play
something like Bishop D3 just to deal
with this bishop right now and we want
to keep it on the diagonal what I want
to do is you gotta try to get G4 G5 in
this Lodge that Knight make some
weaknesses around his King and then
maybe try to you know put the queen on
e4 if possible but Queen A3 I saw that
but I thought that was pretty gross that
was like disgusting what is he doing to
his pawns games oh my goodness that was
the only move that defended everything
but it's disgusting this is a disgusting
move I was just never going to play this
bishopdale just say I'll give you the
pawn but here I mean look at this
there's chances now seriously for
artemia definitely I mean clearly the
best piece in the game is this Knight
it's rock solid it's a statue there in
the center of the board and you're still
going to win a pawn most likely What Is
Love on Iranian thinking about feels
like he's playing too much for the draw
here and a bit of a Grimace on his face
level neuronian on the camera as far as
I can tell look at those pawns horrible
chests you know what he might have been
relying on here is if you play A4 as
white you're trying to defend the C5
Pawn tactically but after Knight takes
C5 Bishop A3 you see if the Knight moves
you lose the Rook behind it the problem
is that black interposed with Knight to
B4 and now it's hitting the bishop on C2
this is a mess and the eval Bar says
that white is hanging right in there
it's a level game but I think for Levon
he was counting on this tactic to win
him back some material he may just be a
pawn down and equality is not so easy
when you don't have the evaluation bar
at your disposal yeah that position that
you showed at the end there I think from
a human point he looks fantastic for
black so he's unlikely to go for that
and maybe he's only realizing now that
he can't save this Pawn also the black
Rook can start running uh forward this
Pawn is doomed and he needs desperately
now 11 Iranian something to compensate
for his terrible structure he needs
tricks he needs tactics but uh where are
they I don't see it I've got to say
right now for white it's very rare that
when you have two Bishops that you're
like yo this position is terrible like
that sounds like it feels like I mean I
have two Bishops and I would love to
have two Bishops in an open position
like this one but this position feels
disgusting I got the double pawns C5 is
hanging yeah okay I have the two Bishops
but I can't even really move them
anywhere the light Square Bishop's doing
well but what is the third script Bishop
doing where is it gonna go to be
effective here it actually leaves nice
and a night of a stallion as uh Robert
has said is a great piece on D5 there
and the other night is going to take the
pawn on C5 and then we're just up with
Pawn all right and the and the double
pawns here it's pretty ugly here for
aronia also remember where do vladislav
I'll tell me have strength Sly mostly in
the end game he's so good at out
maneuvering his opponents we've seen it
plenty of times he took down Magnus
Carlson yesterday against Fabiano often
Fabi was getting into the end game with
an advantage with a clock Advantage as
well and ultimate would outplay him in
that phase of the game and uh okay white
princess ship out a bit of a mysterious
move maybe based on some tricks but yeah
desperate times for levonaroni and you
can tell on the camera body language not
positive anymore for white see-through
Sicilian gone wrong yeah the c36 seal
can get killed sometimes but it also is
c360 for the kill we play it and then
you know if it's good it's good if it's
not it's definitely not yeah meanwhile
Black's gone up a pawn and uh level and
running at least he's mobilized his last
remaining piece he's activated his Rooks
some tricks in the air white is
threatening right now that light Square
Bishop jumping out the way maybe going
to take a pawn with Trek and uh opening
up a attack against this loose Black
Knight on C5 pushes a pawn back nice
symmetry there with whites Bishops and
Rooks nice little bubble of pieces but
uh there we go defending everything
vladislava Pawn up with an advantage and
it looks like a very healthy Pawn yes
Lavon aronian does have the bishop bear
for compensation but those two knights
Activity The Rook on the open file more
activity and it looks like Artemis has
done The Unthinkable by creating chances
in the end game out of an elephant but I
have to ask you guys is this closer to a
draw or an artemia win I would say
practically speaking it's probably
closer to an artemi of wind the issue is
his clock but we've seen time and time
again the way he is able to fend off
those minimal seconds he's like playing
on milliseconds times gets the increment
going he was able to work it back to 10
seconds or so so I think that our time
is very likely to win this game
especially reading levon's reactions he
is displeased about what's Trends are
he's trying to play the safest opening
in the book and now all is going wrong
yeah they often say the worst way to
play for a draw is to play for a draw
you gotta stick to your style if you
have the chance to make a position
aggressive you've got to go for it but
it just looks like Levon aronian tried
to play it just a little 2kg a little
too safe given the math situation but
our time you have once again that clock
he's down to two minutes is that going
to count or the fact that we're in an in
an end game it's not going to be a big
factor that's the one potential banana
skin that's the one thing he could trip
up on later I'll tell me if but it is uh
it is him after all that's his
superpower balancing surviving with one
second two seconds left on the clock so
if anyone can uh kind of not let it
affect their play the clock then it is
him but we'll have to wait and see if if
he blows this Advantage now if he does
crash to defeat crash out the tournament
then he will regret his uh time
consumption and that's so frustrating
it's so frustrating for for the opponent
when you see that our time you have in
this case is going down on the clock
playing on seconds but he's still
playing so strong and you're not able to
beat him on the clock James yeah you
know and you know what's funny here I
mean uh or to me is so so strong when he
gets lower in fact it's almost like you
want to have more you want artemia to
have more time like you're like hey I'll
beat him when he had 10 minutes 12
minutes 13 15 but when he got two in one
minute and then we got 20 seconds that's
where you should fear him right this is
the time where you fear Him the most
because he's precise I mean it's just
like grishek in a way how like it's just
he's so precise and it's like you're oh
it you almost like play on their clock
and you start moving fast trying to flag
them and then you get crushed or you
lose the game and you blunder something
and he's just you know calm cool and
collected with three seconds on the
clock yeah do you want to know one of my
deepest darker secrets I once fell
asleep during a classical game against
vladislav artemia
it was a 9 A.M start all the other games
previously in the tournament had been
starting at like 2 3 P.M uh so I wasn't
in the right Rhythm I played three
tournaments back to back it was the
final round of the final tournament it
was actually for England against Russia
and then uh it was a Berlin as well
which didn't help yeah and then halfway
through the game it was just a balanced
position something happened and then I
kind of opened my eyes I looked at the
clock I was like whoa I've lost 30
minutes what's happened there and then
my teammate was just look at me like
shaking his head what are you doing man
what was the result of the game I
managed to draw but uh I think James is
right there on your point just get lower
on the clock than vladislav he doesn't
know what to do like half an hour down
and he's looking at me like
he started thinking and eventually it
was a mad time scramble and so and he's
probably just too nice to disturb you
during your little nap yeah the worst
thing is like afterwards we were
analyzing an afterwards he's like are
you okay were you unwell I saw you
closed your eyes for a long time
bro I was tired and it was a Berlin
actually I'm tired Berlin was sleep you
know what I mean yeah but uh yeah
meanwhile it is the end game one minute
for vladislav he's handled it so well
though I love his last move I've got to
say he's saying okay we can trade Brooks
on the B file but it's on my terms if
the white root captures the black Rook
black can actually reconnect his pawns
on the queen side but uh yeah I don't
think Levon aronian is finding a plan
right now he's the one burning time on
the clock he's not comfortable at all
trades do not help him because black is
up a pawn and I just want to quickly
note that Magus Carlson has moved on in
the losers bracket he took down Wesley
so they drew their second game no
surprises there but I think what is
surprising for levona Ronin is what has
happened in this one I mean you see the
position he is down upon he's this Pawn
structure is also worse he's these
doubled isolated pawns on the left side
of the board here this is not pleasant
stuff and he doesn't have a plan that's
the biggest issue is you typically want
to double your Rooks but where and he
makes a rook slide just one square over
doesn't threaten anything at all so
black can start bringing the king in use
the King as a weapon in the end game
bring it towards the center yep we seen
Magnus Carlson do that use the king as
an uh as a weapon and I think that's
great advice here Robert for vladislava
tell me especially when you're under one
minute you just want to play kind of
useful uh waiting moves okay wow he
slides across with his Rook pretty much
forcing a set of Trades here Levon he
can't really Dodge this tension any
longer and uh okay set of Trades set of
Rooks off the board maybe closer to
utilizing that extra Pawn Advantage
later in the game ladislav of course up
that pawn for later he pause is he
actually going to take this point wow
there's tricks what a move if Rook takes
there is Bishop A5 I think and Bishop
doesn't need to go Rook B2 there and
then Rook C6 says something I thought it
was just Bishop A5 that's why he took
with the pawn he had taken with the Rook
maybe that would have been an annoying
hit on the black rook and this Pawn
would have dropped next but uh in the
game he took with the pawn instead Rook
takes Rook he took the pawn because Rook
takes Pawn would have been met by a
nasty night Fork look how beautiful
these Knights are hitting this rook and
hitting the bishop you can't defend both
you would win material yeah so uh the
game continues we saw it Levon throw his
a pawn up the board he pushed this pawn
and has captured two points up
temporarily but what is happening here
oh my God ran into it yeah there it is
no he wants to trade Rooks he's deceive
his light Square Bishop but lose the
dark Square Bishop this is over it's
over look at this a Nightfall hitting
the king hitting the bishop and
vladislava takes the win yeah I cannot
believe it he is in shock he just missed
that last move tactic it is Fork it is
is game over that is it which means we
get an Armageddon unbelievable you still
had five minutes on his clock left on a
ronin when he made that blunder when he
gets lower on time he gets stronger it's
a freaking superpower right as he gets
lower on time and then he plays stronger
it's insane artimia does it every time
yeah I think that's good the most
Aim so much action so many things to
learn from it is time for our Lee soweta
learning point
foreign
point is about not playing too timidly
even if you only need a draw
levonoronian had a great start to this
game he actually attained a big
Advantage with the white pieces but
maybe due to the match situation the
match being ahead by one point he was
happy to trade off pieces in the end he
made negative decisions especially
trading off the queens and ruining his
own Pawn structure this was the result
black was actually temporarily two pawns
ahead and because he was still stuck in
that georish mindset Levon aronian made
a careless blunder with five minutes on
his clock he simply captured this Pawn
assuming that more trades were in
imminent here black jumped in he had
actually spotted this double attack he
thought he could trade off the Rooks but
he stopped here he didn't look that one
move further after The Rook trade this
night Fork ended the game Levon aronian
not his finest hour and will he recover
now in the Armageddon
shocking moment there a one move blunder
and it was Game Over which leaves us
with this Cola in action is still on in
the losers quarter final as we move on
to an Armageddon vladislav our tamiyev
punches back in game two creating his
chances and impressive play there by him
finishing in a blunder by 11 aronian the
other one Magnus Carlsen did make it
look very smooth let's bring him on
we've got Mathis joining us Magnus
congratulations
yeah thank you Magnus I have to ask you
Wesley so he's such a solid player one
of the hardest players in the world to
beat you made it look easy today how did
you do it
well I thought it was plain white in the
first game so I was a little bit
surprised to be playing Black
um
I mean considering that
you know the position I got from the
opening was a pretty pleasant surprise I
think he just missed some some mixed
something up and then he started trying
to look for compensation but
yeah uh uh I mean I didn't play Perfect
after but it was really hard to mess
that position out uh and then yeah in
the second second game I think
uh already after
I would say yeah on 94 I moved tomorrow
it was was over so yeah it was was
um clearly my best day so far yeah
nice to hear Magnus and you keep your
Victory hopes alive two back to back
wins in
bracket how important is this adjustable
Masters for you being your last event as
the classical world champion
yeah I don't really care about it being
the last event of whatever era but uh
any of these uh these events are are a
bit big to me uh I try to try to win
them all and I feel like I'm getting
some Rhythm now so it won't be easy to
knock me out a second time or at least
as easy as it was the first
well Magnus as you said you're you're
feeling more in the Rhythm uh tomorrow
you'll face the winner of aronian versus
artemiev would you rather play artemium
and get that Revenge
is that like
I mean I've played a lot against Ari
Tami of Vietnam a bunch beat me a couple
of times as well so like winning one
game would not be reventional with the
over the other
um
yeah I wouldn't mind playing playing
either
um but
um
yeah I don't really have I don't really
have a preference
Magnus say good day at the office how
will you celebrate now will you go back
to those slopes for some more skiing or
will you be watching uh the clash
between Fabiano and Hikaru
uh no the um slopes are are close I
think uh
but I'll have some dinner and uh enjoy
um watching the other others work
actually I mean I made so many mistakes
like I thought I thought there would be
another match
uh today as well uh
uh not uh you know I'm clearly not used
to being in the distance bracket so I
need to need to improve that
Magnus we got to get you a food sponsor
okay everybody was like oh we had people
coming in and they were like oh man what
is Magnus eating now I'm hungry of
course it looked good we got to know
what was on the menu today
yeah it was more or less the same as
yesterday uh except
uh that um
there were some carrots today as well
which I very much enjoyed
um
I don't know if you can see this
okay
okay this is what it says
[Laughter]
well I can catch that what does that say
Magnus
yeah it says uh does Magnus is
pre-dinner snack
fair enough Magna is earlier on in the
show we were showing the video to our
chat with you and David playing uh the
classical game that you did just a
couple of weeks ago and David mentioned
that you actually ghosted him before
that match one is that true and two was
that a big moment for you
the other way around because
um some of the office bed guys were
um at the good night I mean we weren't
drinking we're just hanging out playing
a little Blitz and talking and I I like
I told uh David let's uh do you want to
hang out and uh basically the deal would
be that
um we'd go home at the same time so that
we'd get the same amount of sleep for
the the day after and then I I remember
it was David who didn't didn't reply I
think he was the one who was playing
mind games to be honest I was too busy
studying the Spanish what can I say
never trust David is that the takeaway
yeah he's uh he's a sneaky guy
Agnes for joining us and all that the
match tomorrow
thank you
Magnus Carlson there making it look easy
against one of the hardest players to
beat in the Chess World Wesley so goes
down into games but action is still on
as we will have an Armageddon coming up
between Lavon aronian and our time you
have bids on the other side of the
Stitch break
foreign
[Music]
chess Mastery Magnus Carlson introduces
chessable the definitive solution for
studying chess move trainer uses the
science of space repetition to identify
your strengths and eliminate your
weaknesses there's no need to set up a
board remember which page you're on or
keep track of all the moves you miss get
started now and join our growing
community of over 100 000 chess
enthusiasts chessable take control of
your journey towards chess Mastery my
name is Sam shackland I was the US
champion in 2018. my goal is to keep
things as simple as possible but no
simpler so if I believe there is an easy
solution to Something I'm giving it no
questions asked thanks so much and I
wish you the best for all your studying
if you want to learn an opening we all
know chessable is the place to go but
what if you want to find out what
openings to learn Jessica is now here
for that too find the openings best
suited for your playstyle using their
new quiz that's fun whether you want to
be a booked up positional grinder or an
unorthodox tactical wizard Jezebel has
the answers for you go to chessable.com
quiz or use the command quiz in chat to
take the quiz today
wow it is really important to actually
know your playing style before you pick
the openings that you want to go for oh
it absolutely is I think in this day and
age when so many people are learning
after the Queen's Gambit during the
pandemic they were taught a specific
opening from their favorite streamer but
that may not suit your individual style
so I do think that people need to know
what kind of play they like best yeah so
definitely go check out that quiz and
for now check out the Armageddon
regulations a big match coming up either
vladislav our time you have or
lebonaroni and one of them will be out
one of them will go on in the chessable
Masters the player who bids for the
lower time gets wins the bid and gets
the opportunity to choose the color they
usually choose black because black gets
result odds which means if it's a draw
black wins the match white has to win on
demand the player who loses the bid
starts with 15 minutes the bidding games
are on what are we expecting and we got
the results oh my God level neronians
seven and a half minutes that is is a
very low bid to fight for the black
pieces how do we feel about that James
you know what you need to have lower
time than artemia right to mix it up
because he always has lower time right
so when he has lower time he's in his
element but hey LeBron's like you know
what cool we're gonna play a Blitz game
I'm gonna have lower time and the black
pieces right and got to uh you know when
I win I draw I win so I think it's very
smart from LeBron yeah wow our time we
have will start with the white pieces he
will have 15 minutes on the clock 11 are
onions seven and a half minutes
will play with black our time you have
has to win the match a draw means Levon
goes through or Tamia will be knocked
out Robert what's your take on the bid
that we just saw it sounds crazy at
first because he's bidding half the time
of his opponent or 10 about 15 minutes
LeBron or we'll have seven and a half
but I think that considering the match
Dynamic Levon has played the quicker
chess he's not too worried if he can
keep that speed in the opening and David
opening is on and we've seen our time we
have do this before yeah he has done
this before yesterday against Fabiano
caruana and this time it's a different
spin whoa look at this left on Iranian
only needs to draw but he's sacrificed a
pawn he's allowing the White Queen to go
and get greedy to grab that B7 pawn and
why not okay aronian his bluff was not
called or was it a bluff maybe this is
just great opening preparation again the
gift is offered and Artemis says no even
in a moss which must win situation he's
preferring to dodge his opponent's
preparation not getting greedy with his
Queen are you surprised here James
Robert I would have grabbed that pawn
I've got to say yeah especially with the
bishop on C1 I mean the bishop C1 it
defends B2 usually when it was back
there you take on B7 and you allow him
to play Rook B8 so you can take the pawn
on B2 but that that wasn't the case so
in fact and he could just see he
probably just played Knight D7 I moved
the queen back you get a little bit
initiative but I'm not a pawn though
yeah now it just looks very very solid
for black gotta say I like the Romantic
style that Lavon was playing with he's
like take my Pawn I will have that
compensation I'll get activity but this
is a different Dynamic I actually think
it's quite smart from our tembium
because with the lead on the clock that
he has he wants to keep the game going
he does not want Lavon of any easy
solutions and we see what's the plan for
black he's got his piece in the center
everything looks good but what next
that's the big question yeah what next
and uh just to show what would happen if
white continued uh well actually I'll
say continue but if white did decide to
grab the pawn here and now if he does
take this Pawn with his Queen the black
Rook would simply activate and there's a
big problem on the B2 Square the White
Queen can move actually she might even
get trapped if you're not careful on
this square root takes pawn and uh
simply this Rook too active you cannot
consider it anymore the opportunity is
gone but just the fact that vladisava
tell me I've dodged that capture dodged
that pawn uh with his Queen does mean to
me at least that he's at least speeding
up he's uh very aware of the clock
otherwise he would have spent five
minutes calculating that right he would
have uh at least invested a bit of time
instead he's brought his Rook across and
he's playing position he maybe me to
open things up with C4 later
I just got the feeling that that bid
that we saw by lava narunian at seven
and a half minutes that has a lot to do
with his opponent our time you have
somewhere Levon feels that our Tamia
will burn the clock the time will be
level so why not just get the result on
is that the strategy and will that pay
off I prefer it to his strategy
yesterday against uh Fabiano where he
was really tanking and Clocks Were level
before you know it and of course he
didn't end up winning that game but uh
yeah he needs to avoid thinking now
vladislava tell me a fast start great
start still got almost double the time
but uh he needs to keep that edge on the
clock we all know what can happen if it
does uh get balanced later it'll just be
a random scramble so right now he needs
to make a decision what to do next I
think his big decision is whether or not
to push his C Pawn that would allow some
trades they'll open up the position that
sounds good when you need to win the
game but also make some of lavon's
decisions easier because this is a
position with plans and maneuvering and
right now both sides it's not clear what
they want but playing their Pawn push to
C4 that would make it a bit clearer and
that actually would be good for Lavon
yeah and there we go uh Robert you
called it after a trade of knights first
he has opened things up so easier
decisions for Levon here maybe he'll
slide his Rook across try and trade
everything off on the open file but
White's piece is also more active than
they previously were so uh James you're
a very attacking player this is more of
a grindy style but do you approve I'm
halfway asleep here he's looking at this
position now of course it is very
positional here very solid and this is
exactly what Lavon wants here Lavon just
wants to trade things off hey look you
know what if I draw I win the game
that's it right but of course I mean
artemia being a grinder actually loving
in games and very slow and positional
type chests here um but he's not in his
element yet because he got too much time
so he has so much time right now that
you know it's not going to work he's
going to probably take somewhere in
there it's going to get crazy and
artemiev is definitely going to get a
Little Bit Stronger when that time gets
lower here but I mean so far just very
level very level not too much to say to
both sides we're still trying to figure
out plans and improving our position
slowly like the queen is a little bit
better on D7 than it was on E7 it
defends C8 why he's trying to do his
thing as well maybe try to move the
bishop to a better Square maybe even
play a move like H3 or G3 just to make a
little bit of look for the king very
positional maybe A4 stop a potential B5
so lots of choices for both sides yeah
one of the points you mentioned that
James just pushing up poor near your
king to give your king some breathing
space some Luft some air I think both
sides want to do that quite urgently wow
okay interesting move sliding the White
Queen back trying to conquer the open
file but you say wow Tanya because it's
in the eye line of that black Bishop
it's slightly uncomfortable it does feel
like the fight is very important for the
only open file in the position the C
file I think that will be a deciding
factor who can control it if our time we
have gets control which it does look
like he's managed to do that there is a
slight Edge in the position there is a
pull in this position until Levon is
able to trade Rooks on the C5 I don't
think this position is as simple as it
looks guys not simple at all because
right now as you pointed out that white
has control of the only open file of the
board that means the white controls the
action has all the activity has all the
fun and so if even you play them with
Queen to C7 if you bring your queen up
offering a queen trade we typically
think Queen trade that means it's more
towards the quality but if black takes
that Queen here comes a rook on the
seventh rank that is very dangerous for
black to deal with it's not that easy to
take that Rook out of there and if it
can't be flushed out that means that
black has to sit and passively defend
that's not fun especially with little
time on the clock yeah I'm finding this
very dangerous for Lavon with five
minutes on the clock and there are no
tactics that you're dealing with yes
there isn't an attack that you're
dealing with but very often in chess and
especially at this high level these
strategic questions are equally
difficult to answer James I am I think
our time we have should be very happy
with what he's created with the white
pieces and still twice the amount of
time on the clock Robert your move on
the board
beautiful queen C7 I'm very annoyed by
this move I had to play something like
Rooks a d8 I don't even likes is he
trades it wow he just allows it to
happen and he defends upon and says hey
it's whatever maybe bishop C6 98 King f8
is there wow trying to trap the the best
The Rook on C7 you actually have to be
very careful you called it James right
now there's actually a threaten on on
the board it's this hidden one it is
just to retreat this bishop for example
if the white knight steps back I really
careless move suddenly black would be
winning look at the evaluation bar the
black Bishop drops back and this Rook
caught Behind Enemy Lines no way to save
it simply this Knight is going to
retreat next move hitting the Rook only
one safe square and the king is going to
catch it suddenly black would win
material so huge threat on the board if
Artemis can't deal with this he's going
to be forced to retreat with his head
hanging in shame but what if he doesn't
retrieve but goes forward with the
Knight hopping to G5 instead that hits
the bishop in the center and that pawn
on F7 uh The Rook may still get trapped
I'm not sure but that looks like a
double attack it is a double attack
Robert you're right actually how is
black gonna deal with this you can't
afford this bishop to drop off for
example you can't just bring your Rook
across and defend this Pawn because once
the bishop departs from the board The
Black Queen side pawns will start
falling like flies so here black is
pretty much committed to dropping his
Bishop back I guess yeah the best
defense is offense Bishop if Knight F7
98 anyway and have a nice day right and
then King 2 f8 once you get your Rook to
E7 and that Rook is a trap that's a nice
trick James after board absolutely you
know we like those tricks here but a
nice move from artemia Bishop B5 is
stopping all of that he's like you know
what yeah I know what you want to do not
today not today but what is the reply to
this Pawn stepping forward is he just
gonna step back with his Bishop continue
controlling the square that the black
Bishop wants to use this is really
sophisticated stuff really tense stuff
first level on aronian pushes his other
Pawn stopping that night jump we
highlighted this is uh really really
sophisticated classy endgame player by
uh played by both sides I've got to say
and Levon flexing stretching he looks uh
he's comfortable at all here because
black can hardly move you're shuffling
about and it may be objectively an equal
position but look at the clock artemium
still has a four minute lead it started
with seven and a half it has been cut
into and Levon is playing really fast
chess right now but he doesn't have
ideas he's still just trying to defend
against White's threats and so I think
that our 10 if he decides to speed up
here it's going to be difficult for
Lavon because just start pushing your
pawns for our Tamia maybe your eight
Pawn then your F pawns aren't just
trying to strike in the center I don't
like this position for black yeah then
again I'll tell me if they just kind of
wipe his brow he knows that he needs to
speed up you use that phrase Robert but
he doesn't speed up and that could be
costly in an Armageddon like this one
first he has to decide is that white A2
Point actually attacked Black's Bishop
in the center attacking that pawn if you
have to take her time out to move it
defend it suddenly Levon will get a very
important Tempo to try and trade off or
try and kick that white Rook out of his
Camp I mean while I'm distracted these
are really nice photos coming in
keeps them coming let's go ahead while
Hikaru will be playing later on right
now it is all eyes on this one but the
winners final will be following up well
I have to say I still like our time we
have chances here there is a potential
strike in the center with the pawns you
can start advancing the F Pawn the E
Pawn a Target that Bishop on D5 right
now our time you have moves back with
the bishop his Rook on C7 looks very
active still up by almost three minutes
on the clock things looking good for our
time here but he has to make sure he
keeps that clock Advantage going yeah
it's all about that white Rook if the
Rooks get traded or if that white Rook
is forced to retreat it's going to be
equal it's most likely going to be a
draw uh if we forget about the clock but
uh okay nice move from our time we have
big thread on the board that white
central port now E4 better late than
never that black Bishop is almost
trapped actually in the center of the
board first a counter attack hitting
that white Bishop forcing it away but
now there's no way to trap in cage that
white Rook I think this was an excellent
player starting with King f8 the whole
idea here of course is thinking in plans
right he wants to go King f8 why because
I want to play B5 kick the bishop away
play 98 get the Rook off the seventh
rank play King E7 King D7 and move the
Rook to C8 and wait we gotta draw wins
the game and the match for me but the
problem with pushing those Queen side
pawns you leave squares behind So
eventually that Knight on D2 it's
sitting there it's actually not an
active piece you want to bring it into
enemy camp that A5 Square it looks far
away but it's only two jumps from its
current spot so I do feel like a white
should just try to keep the momentum you
know you could play in the center with
Pawn to E4 to kick that Bishop out of
there then bring your knight forward and
I like what our 10 Memphis did nope
Bishop trades let's keep it on the board
because E4 is going to be a shot with
Tempo and if Black's playing 98 now yes
you're kicking my Rook out but I still
control the C file and I can just
continue jumping forward yeah continue
jumping forward this is a really
annoying move to have to face next move
next turn and still small Advantage for
white but Levon will be breathing a side
of relief I don't like this I've got to
say pushing this Pawn forward it feels
like you're playing on the wrong flank
you should play on the side you're
stronger actually get that King active
as James says but uh Levon tends to be
well it's clearly he's feeling the
nerves now down to four minutes he's
really in a rush yeah and I like this
trade offer by our time we have the
reason for that is that this would mean
the C6 Square would be weak for The Rook
the white Rook to come in and start
attacking those weak Pawns in chess
whenever you make a pawn move you do
create some weaknesses and right now our
time we are trying to get rid of the
strongest piece in Black's position that
Bishop on D5
yeah I have a bad feeling I think Levon
might have been a bit too low this is
not as an easy position it's not going
to be the type of position you just
Hoover the Rooks off Hoover the knights
off it's going to go on for a long long
time in four minutes
it's a Race Against Time and he's not
known as being too fast he's not known
as a bullet specialist levonaronian I'll
tell him we have very good uh very high
bullet rating if you rented Robert
on chess.com I'm gonna make a prediction
that the time the clock is going to
level out in the next couple of moves I
do I don't see our time we have keeping
an advantage on the clock for too long
but yes he will push the position well I
agree that the time may become equal the
position I think will not and the reason
why is LaVon in order to keep equal time
he'll have to play a series of quick
moves the position is more difficult
than initially meets the eye we have the
same material for both sides only one
Pawn is off the board for both but
there's squares Left Behind even that
pawn push to F5 that may make the E6
Square week later in the game and I feel
like White's Rook controls a lot of the
action here it's the only open file but
or tell me if he needs to play more
quickly that's his biggest problem right
now now just make a decision maybe
centralize the white king bring the
white Rook up to the top of the board
with a check do something trade off the
Bishops but do you have to move it's one
nearly one and a half minutes on this
one turn that's too much in Armageddon
no increment remember
wow I was thinking a couple of moves it
might just be this one it is a minute
and a half ahead yes our time you have
does have a very pleasant end game but
it's still far from a sizable Advantage
he needs to make a move James he needs
to do it now what are the ideas that
come to your mind definitely
centralizing the king king E2 King D3
and plain Pawn to E4 I mean you just
want to use this I also have the open
file right now um I have the only open
file under my control so I definitely
like King E2 and King D3 there he spent
nearly two minutes on this one move
there's nothing forcing going on in the
position and look at Levon he's gaining
in confidence now just make them this is
our time you have looking he needs to
make a move the game will be decided
later at the moment it's still
maneuvering just maneuver a piece okay
he decides to trade off and enter with
his Rook but uh same move faster would
have been better of course and uh okay
here it is and he gave himself an
isolated Pawn that was a big decision
and maybe he's just trying to take James
advice he wants a little bit less time
so then he can play his best chess
telling you every time and when he gets
under he like I got too much time how
much time he got let me wait let's
calculate right oh I'm under the clock
or as soon as I can get lower on time
that's when I'm gonna play a lot faster
Knight F6 it's an adrenaline junkie uh
but this last move might be a killer for
his fun unless he finds something now
the idea is that if the white knight in
the center goes to take the black Pawn
on D6 the black king is going to shuffle
across and that's it maybe you get
trapped maybe you can't hold everything
together there what are we thinking is
this a genius move by levonaroni and the
bar did react I think it is a great idea
but the problem is that our tenant has
process of elimination he knows he can't
take that pawn with his Knight which
means he may swap Knights on F6 he just
does that and you have to take with the
pawn and in doing so look at the H6 Pawn
he goes Rook C8 his threat now is Rook
over to h8 he's gonna slide over there
hit this Pawn H6 and also threaten the
skewer along the seventh rank this is
the problem when you're stuck defending
passively now the pawn structure has
changed and white can take advantage
this is this is amazing Playboy tell me
I've just I am so pressed the fact that
he's traded off so many pieces in a
must-win position and happily and just
gone into an end game where he knows
he's got enough chances to get that win
it shows the confidence that he has he's
played flawlessly this Armageddon yeah
nerves of Steel still with an extra
minute and a half as well now level of
rhodium he's realizing that his last
decision was not optimal but again he
needs to hustle Rook end games do have a
very Jewish tendency so it's all about
getting that black Rook active I'm not
sure how you achieve that actually
because you do have so many weaknesses
you would be happy you would love to
give up a pawn right now just to get
that black Rook into the game but how do
you achieve it level needs to decide
needs to decide quickly he says really
telling you either go King F7 and this
is when you bring out your devil rescue
in-game manuals chapter uh what is it
it's um actually Four working game
chapters in there all chanceable by the
way four it work in game chapters do you
understand what I'm saying here chat
four rook in game chapters so it's
probably in chapter wherever right it's
just you just don't have to go read it
right it's very tough here they always
say working games are drawn but you got
to do it you gotta actually do the work
there and this is tough here maybe you
push one of the pawns maybe you go King
F7 to meet Rick h a with King G6 or G7
and it's played yeah he played it but
after a long think and look at this I
tell me if he knows which side of the
board he's stronger he knows that long
term he's going to create a passport on
that King side so why not start the race
now push upon give the move back to your
opponent and live on a running tank in
under two minutes what move that's the
question is if you move your king too
far towards the king side tow the flank
then your central pawns will be targeted
if you move back towards the center then
isolated Pawn on H6 will be a victim of
White's Rook so this move actually
freezes black in place it also allows
the white king to step forward maybe
Venture through G3 up the board I feel
like LaVon could barely move right now
and he does not have much time yeah it's
almost like forcing left to create more
weaknesses in the position and that's
what Lev has done because of lack of
options he advances this Pawn which
means we will have more Thorn islands in
the position the one thing that have has
to be careful about is not giving up
control of that C file not to hurry with
attack on those pawns because then Levon
will be looking for counter play with
his own Rook so he's taking it easy not
moving around with that Rook on seat but
instead brings the king to the center of
the board nice move good end game wisdom
active Rook take active King now tick
and also creating a past Pawn he's
pushing those pawns up the board and
Levon he's had to commit okay so two
versus one advantage now uh on that
right flank and I have a bad feeling for
Levon are only one and a half minutes to
defend this difficult end game not gonna
be easy he's gonna get flagged yeah you
can definitely see that flag coming of
course I mean only there's only very few
people on Earth where you know you get
lower on time and you get stronger and
Lavon is not one of them here so of
course his lore is when his time gets
lower we've seen with Magnus and even
Wesley so like these strong players you
get long time you mean you're gonna make
blunders not earth me have though of
course is a little bit different here I
also like the king activity from white I
mean a lot of times an active King and
active pieces as a as a David house said
with the active Rook active King gives
you lots of chances lots of
possibilities now Black's trying to be
active here now though Rook G7 so what
do we do about this yeah let's defend it
with the king I think though maybe it's
time to be a little bit more passive
right because King F4 is the most
tempting move going forward but that
gives back E5 with check so we don't
want to give any checks to Black to get
that pawn rolling so I think artemia was
thinking at the right moment he has that
lead on the clock and now he's using it
wisely because he may just win this on
the board yeah and uh you're right
Robert you got two two squares the white
king can go to you Shuffle across but uh
okay he has picked the uh safer Square
this move does not come with a check and
now White's Rook can start hunting Pawns
in the next move or two there is plenty
of targets on both flanks so many
weaknesses for black White's Rook so
Superior to its counterpart also one
extra minute time Advantage being eaten
away you do feel like I'll tell me if
wants to win this on the board he's not
even looking at the clock right now and
uh Levon poised you can see Levon he's
itching to play he's probably pre-moved
his next move or two uh he wants a
capture in the center so that his King
can get active the black king can enter
the middle of the board and suddenly
some chances there so still accuracy
required and or tell me if he can ignore
the tension between the pawns right now
and bring his Rook two squares back
attacking multiple pawns at the same
time in the sixth rank so he gives one
to get two and that will be a pawn
Advantage though that gets tricky
because you do not want to hand Levon a
pass Pawn then you have to start
worrying about that Queen I keep saying
this quality over quantity in The Rook
end games but I do think that our 10
will have both yeah look at the clocks
though only 15 seconds in it suddenly
this one is going to be a race to the
Finish Robert's move on the board the
most natural move on the board but it
took him a long time and now the black
king is going to go active nothing for
it gotta forget the material forget the
pawns and Levon is banking everything
gambling everything on his Pawn running
through uh I'll tell me if it's stopped
it but only a one-point Advantage now
yeah but this is just going to come down
to the clock the position might be level
practically still very difficult with
that extra pawn and The Rook activity I
think in a rapid game eight out of 10
times you'd save this but with a minute
on the clock and your opponent out there
to flag you is still Advantage our time
you have I am a little scared as is
LeBron because I mean like well our team
is getting lower on time and you know
what happens when he gets lower on time
it's been proven in every match he's
played that when he gets lower he gets
stronger so it's a little scary right
now and there's no increment right so he
is going to flag him he is up about half
a minute and he's this past Pawn he can
push his Pawn to the board and just make
a ton of other moves and Lavon I don't
know if he's going to be able to
withstand this he is not a bullet
specialist he's quite great at it
actually people underestimate him but
Artemis is better between the two our
time we have has to win this game to
continue his journey in the chessable
Masters if it ends in a draw Levon
aronian takes the match Lebanon down to
about 53 seconds he has time to make
about 50 moves in the game and that's
kind of easy to squeeze in in this kind
of a rook Pawn ending 40 gets move you
make another pawn move that's all you
need to do yeah vladislav just has to
turn off that Mr Nice Guy uh Persona
that he has he just needs to flick in a
few Rook checks push upon another few
Rook checks push report exactly do it
fast white can pre-move here white is
the one on checking what's the one
pushing importance black is the one
reacting and it's so much slower to
react but he hasn't played as quickly as
he should have done and suddenly active
white is stuck white has no winning plan
the black Rook is actually going to be
the one checking the white king and
start trying to win over the board right
now Mr Nice Guy
objectively it's fine for black you
probably hold a draw but play the clock
do not have any shame and now he's the
one who's low on the clock it is Levon
who can try and flag him in this one
oh my God levon's moves are simple you
just react to the checks now and uh
suddenly okay we've had this position
before the black Rook the black king can
move why is he not moving too slow oh he
does before yes he goes for it changes
the position now he might just run his
King over and he needs to flag him he
just has to just move very quickly who
cares what the material is but Robert
who was slagging who in this one 21 20.
oh my God no increments
something moves are being made they will
come in shortly I think that's what
happens in cluster so don't worry Lavon
is not spending all this time we will
have this up shortly but Levant is
playing quickly he's keeping up on the
clock he is not about to flag
Something's Happened Here the board is
Frozen the clock has frozen too we'll
try and keep you up to date uh this is
the current position we'll watch on the
analysis board here and uh okay the
clocks we're not sure about it's gonna
end up King versus King with best play
but it's about the clock of course dead
drone position wow actually black is
winning the British
winning these are the correct times does
have enough time to win or Draw this
game
[Music]
here we go
oh
my God
it was a draw by repetition they
repeated it just in time because Lavon
was actually down on the clock at the
end of the game but he makes a draw
there and what a save
wow love on our onion goes through in to
the next match it is the end of the road
for vladislav our champion it could have
gone either way what an Armageddon this
was
I think we were all catching our breath
the players will be drained as well
and celebrating he's got reasons to be
proud of just keeping control over his
nerves when it mattered the most and
with that let's take a look at our
score line
crazy stuff I mean yeah Lavon goes
through he wins it he made it through
that's crazy what a what an organic
right what number getting and actually
the final position was winning for Levon
so he did it just in time on the board
but also on the clock imagine starting
with half the time and still handling
such a difficult Rook end game just a
show uh near the final stages Levon had
turned it around I'll tell you may have
had taken risks to try and win and hear
if he had more time on the clock Levon
would have brought his Rook across to
any safe Square on the fifth Rank and
this Pawn is running through to
promotion you can give and check Force
the black king away but uh for example
here white is simply too slow next move
the black king moves out the way and
black makes a new Queen it will cost
white his Rook Levon doing the business
in this Rook end game and
congratulations to him
what a match this has been let's take a
look at the scoreline of the elimination
bracket today Magnus Carlsen has gone
further Westy so End of the Road blood
Islam our time you have unfortunately
has been knocked out he is out of the
tournament live onion taking that Epic
Armageddon win with the black pieces wow
what was that I'm still reading from it
and we've got the winner of that match
who will be joining us
really soon guys seven and a half
minutes levon's bid but it worked out in
the end wow fortune favors the bold that
was a crazy bid from levana Roan he's
not typically known as a Speedster but
he had the mouse speed when it counted
he was down to his final three seconds
he forced the draw that's all he needed
just like five minute car wanna did to
our time of yesterday yeah what an
awesome match and we've got the winner
with us let's bring him on level one
congratulations
thank you very much
love the match could have really gone
either way what did it take to win today
uh yeah of course I think it I I I think
I really cannot live without drama I I
created all of this myself I mean in the
second game uh my position was so good I
could play anything I mean in the
opening and then I just slowly uh played
the worst possible moves and lost the
game and the last game of course I got a
difficult position at some point I
really missed this Knight take C4 idea
I shouldn't have captured an E4 and
after that it was downhill I was really
lucky to find this idea with uh E5 you
know E5 before at least creating some
kind of like otherwise it's just look
very losing uh well so to answer your
question Tanya
it took the usual recipe that I always
show the luck
well love they say you make your own
luck on the chessboard and that's what
we saw today but I want you to take a
look at your reaction actually after
winning the match it was amazing to
watch there some celebration just take
us through this what was going on in
your mind was it relief Joy
well I thought he's going to flag me you
know with the
with the Rook but he
he didn't do it you know
so it made me happy you know that I
didn't get flagged
do you think that that is something that
sometimes works against our time you
have he has this psychological battle
perhaps and doesn't feel comfortable in
these Armageddon formats
I think everybody has that problem
generally and that's why I think it's
it's only fair to add a once I can per
move after move 60 which I think
is is necessary for our Megadons
generally
and I'm looking forward you will be
playing against Magnus tomorrow
there's going to be an epic Clash uh how
do you feel about that take us through
it
so far I've been to Survivor so I'm
going to try to do the same you know
just to fight till the last bullet
because I I cannot really say that I am
playing well or playing a stable brand
of Chess I'm blundering a lot losing
unnecessary games but uh yeah all it
takes is fighting
we love to see you fighting lab and it
has been a fantastic match thank you so
much and we will see you tomorrow all
the best
thank you very much case
but what fantastic play by both love and
artemiab our time you have dominating in
that second game Lev took the match took
the game in round one and then
eventually in the Armageddon anything
could have happened slagging could have
happened but levon's the one who
prevailed with better control over the
nerves we are going to go into a shot
twitch break and be right back
[Music]
thank you
while the players have been having so
much fun playing chess we also have been
having a lot of fun playing chess in the
city of Oslo and that has been Thanks to
our lifestyle Partners Puma James Canty
took to the streets of Oslo for some
banter Blitz and trash talking was
allowed
here we go guys I am here Philly Master
James Canty III aka the Jedi we here in
Oslo okay Norway is going down we got
some banter Blitz today as you can see
my goal is to mess you up by talking to
you while we playing okay do you want to
play against James
I'm Daniel James nice to meet you nice
to meet you what's your rating
uh I don't play much but I think a peak
that's about 900 on okay all right now
honey be careful not to be the strongest
not hiding on the planet
oh he quick
100. he 809. now what maybe 1900. oh
there we go maybe that shouldn't be too
quick yeah that's okay for you maybe
yeah I'm just trying to see if I can win
something I don't think so I'm just
trying giving you some pawns yo you
gotta remember for free you gotta relax
bro you don't want to I don't want it
okay you have something here yes you do
whoa check oh no push that man played
excellent
[Applause]
back up bro
I have never seen that type of move in
my life let's do the replay on that
Knight A6 I think it's yeah don't know
the rules that's new yeah the new rules
not with March oh March okay
oh you gonna have to relax my guy
wow
what's this
it's over it's over almost James what's
your rating I'm not quite sure I'm not
even slightly sober since last night do
we have to play with increments uh you
want to play without yeah sir sweet one
minute we play a bullet no let's go boy
hey quick okay
he's actually good guys
okay it sucks whoa Mama Mia whoa
we're moving it oh no no
there's one second left oh my God that
was intense dude he at least 2200 bro I
actually think you're high I'm higher
rate than you
that's crazy
[Laughter]
that's not is that covering
is it this way
[Music]
foreign
yes
[Music]
this is a queen
yes I heard you were a grand master nice
to meet you yeah nice to meet you
for over 75 years we've witnessed
moments that will last forever
records and trophies first and only game
changing Innovations from the heroes we
admire to the joy of watching them play
our history defines us inspires us and
pushes us into the future
celebrating 75 years of changing the
game
Puma forever faster
[Music]
that was crazy we was out there in the
streets having some fun of course I
played Carl Magnuson over here right it
was it was a lot of fun of course I had
that one second game the guy I played
was actually 2400 feet eh I was like oh
he's a beast right he was a young maker
I don't even know what my rating is but
he was 2400. then we had the guy out
there with the new move oh my goodness
Knight A6 did y'all see that chat Knight
A6 that was crazy I never knew that that
came out in March is what he said the
new move right so it's fun out in the
streets of Oslo it was awesome and I was
in a puma trip you know I still got the
Puma on right now you know what I mean
get the close-up you see the Puma here
yeah shout out to Puma for all the drip
we got like 400 worth of Puma gear it
was amazing so I could Puma to sponsor
James
you know look at me right you know Puma
all the way down baby love it and a huge
shout out to our lifestyle Partners Puma
for all the giveaways and the fun that
we have with them right now it is fun
with chess as the big final is coming up
Fabiano caruana taking on hikarina
Nakamura Hikaru world number five Fabi
world number seven the top two players
from the United States very different
styles of play how do you wow we've got
action already the game is on you know I
thought you were about to ask what we
might see and I wasn't expecting this
opening in English from five minute
carwana but I think that's what he wants
to do against hikar Nakamura he does not
want a car to get that opening
preparation to use it to his full
advantage uh but it's early at this one
and we've only had a trade of nights
yeah so it did start as the English
opening the four nights variation one
set of those nights disappearing and uh
Hikaru jumps out with his Bishop this
was actually very trendy about 10 years
ago everyone was playing this line for
black but suddenly it disappeared and
that must be for a reason Hikaru
bringing it back and Kate Fabi is the
first to think just putting his head
down there he knows he studied this
before I've actually seen both players
play this exact line before but uh can
he recall what he wanted to do what is
ahead in development White's Queen is
out why it's castled but black super
solid and uh just one more movie
karunakima if the black king castles to
safety I think it's been a success his
opening uh nothing to complain about
there for Hikaru the players will play a
best of four in the winners final and
there is a lot at stake at this one the
winner goes through to the next
to the next Champions chest or event
they booked their spot in the next
Champions chest story event Robert well
I think their fortunate because both of
them no matter what happens here they
are making their way through the top
division in the third event so that
takes some of the pressure off that's
the good thing but come on we know we
could say everything about the next
event it's about this event when these
two American Superstars go at it because
they have played each other so many
times we saw their head to head and you
know they want to take the other down
wow well that's why Hikaru said that the
main aim is to get to the next one he's
already done it so the pressure is off
but door points are at stake
looks extra chill today I have to say
usually we see him leaning in doing that
head Bob nodding his head Expressions he
seems really relaxed is he very happy
with the opening outcome James
absolutely of course he even has the
pineapple shirt on so you better be very
careful with the pineapple shirt and the
pineapple behind them sometimes it
raises 100 ELO he already 2800 you don't
want that right so if of course he's
already feeling comfortable here I think
he just needs to develop pieces he
already has restricted a little bit of
White's play now we do have ourselves
like a Catalan Bishop here with the
bishop on G2
um in this English here but very strong
Bishop on G2 for foppy so we can't try
to create some chances but maybe a C5
and even like a rook to B1 fin Kettle
the bishop on B3 with B3 Bishop B2 you
know very slow play not something you
really see a lot from Fabi here but
definitely a nice position for both
sides I think uh everything's level so
far yeah you're right actually that last
Point's about it not being fabby's style
usually he does prefer to hit his
opponent's strike early go a bit direct
if he can but uh this one is very much
about the slow Maneuvers and Hikaru
looking super chilled and I love his
position actually as black is Fabby
smiling was that a little smile from
Fabi right there he actually is yeah
yeah you are Italian you see it you see
it maybe he heard my comment about
liking her courage position sorry Fabi
but uh yeah meanwhile a case striking
now this started as an English of course
it does look like a bit like a Catalan
with that white Bishop but more of a
reverse Sicilian and uh In the Sicilian
you often want that extra Pawn advantage
in the center and now fabi's saying you
can bypass my Pawn you can step away
from this but then Black's dark Square
Bishop is going to be locked in forever
or you can trade off but then the White
Knight comes in off the edge of the
board to a nicer Square so first real
question of the game for Hikaru and
sometimes when a player starts thinking
it means that their preparation has come
to an end all or perhaps their opponent
has played maybe not the best move or
even the second best move it's catching
them by surprise but this is a standard
type of idea by Fabiano he's pushing his
Pawn forward to blunt the scope of that
Bishop on A7 he wants to get his Knight
into C5 we just saw that in the game
between artemiev and aronian earlier
today and so it's a common idea the
bishop on G2 that light Square Bishop is
in great position staring across the
diagonal black slide score Bishop yet to
be developed I think now might be the
time yep now might be the time what is
that on fabiana's shoulder I've noticed
this uh come into play the last couple
of days he takes it off again oh man
nice might be yeah it might be something
he might have been working out too hard
to tell him what to do you need to get
your your creatine your glutamine right
your glutamine good he been in the gym
so he might have hurt himself a little
bit got a stretch before and after some
dynamic stretches I'm gonna hit his line
I got this or maybe this is his workout
oh right he's just trying to get those
heating pads going this chest is his
workout right
exactly right oh man that shoulder might
be hurting a little bit yeah
continues
conditions in the
in the way that on Advance once again
once again asking Hikaru to take some
decisions do you want to trade do you
want to fix the center Hikari says no I
want to develop my pieces makes a lot of
sense yeah he covered these days he
really values the center highly he
values space very highly for me this
decision would have been really really
hard but he made it within a minute or
so on the clock and you mentioned the
center at Tanya I'm also fixated after
uh hikaru's last move on this bishop
this bishop won A7 how is it ever
getting back into the game it's just
staring down it gets a really strong
Pawn here the White Knight kind of keeps
this cage locked protecting this Pawn if
Hikaru ever drops this bishop back then
the White Knight will be ready to jump
in so uh yes black has a nice Pawn
Center I'm really loving the space he's
established here but the rest of his
position I'm not so sure about and uh
Fabi here he's ready to take a time out
stepping a pawn forward is he perhaps
going to at some point just tuck his
King away to safety and start throwing
pawns towards the black king later I
think he's getting ready just in case
the position shuts down white will lash
out now on and switch plate to the king
side it's really flexible actually from
Fabiano and Hikaru does answer my
question he drops back with his Bishop
he's happy to allow the White Knight to
jump in and he's saying yes my Rook
might look a bit weird right now but I'm
gonna come for you I'm gonna get rid of
your knight and then the position will
stabilize interesting Clash of ideas
well now there's going to be no King H2
because I Bishop on B8 and then you
can't play you know you'll see this a
lot in the Batman type English setups
it's almost about for Nick like where
like he just you know pushed the C Pawn
from C4 to C5 and we still have D3 and
E4 that you will see in about phonic
English or in fact the chessable course
for that is the iron English by Simon
Williams but you will play King H1 here
and then usually you play F4 and G4 and
everything four push everything up G5 in
there Rook G1 Bishop F3 right and we're
going for an attack on this side of the
board right so it is very possible to do
so if you put the King on H2 you run
right into the bishop on B8 so this is
uh definitely a nice Bishop that he has
their own B8 but if the king is on H2
it'll be a problem for for five so
taking that one all right you know I
think James wants to play F4 right away
he's like let's go forward why do we
have to move our King first walk into
that Bishop's line of fire so I think F4
is a very nice idea for Fabian I'm not
sure if you throw a knight B6 first or
or play F4 right away but that is going
to be the plan to break open the king
side yeah you just have to time it
correctly just to make sure that the
white king doesn't uh become too open
doesn't suffer from uh lines opening on
that side of the board first he does
flick in this Knight attack and I'm
expecting Hikaru okay he's paused but
I'm expecting him to use this Square for
his Rook at least to put some pressure
on this white knight temporarily a bit
of a standoff between those two pieces
but uh nothing too serious yet that
white knight is not on that square
permanently but uh okay Fabio playing
only on the queen side our eyes were
drifting over to the other flank what do
you think of this James B4 that is I
don't really like it I'm not even gonna
lie I was like okay Fabi uh no I just
don't like it the fact that me it just
opens up I mean if he takes it is there
anything like tricky I'm assuming he's
just going to take it back but that
opens The Rook The Rook is now a little
bit better than it was and I mean I can
get this night out of there by Bishop to
C7 and you're gonna have to move the
Knight again and then my Rook has some
Merit maybe I even have Queen A8 or like
just I'm ready to double at some point
um because the rook's already on A6 I
think maybe he should have went for the
F4 plan but he definitely has something
in mind with B4 we just have to see what
it is now yeah it caught with frowning
for the first time in the game surprised
I think just as much as we are here in
the studio by this last move by Fabi I
think the idea is to kind of keep that
root cage forever if we have to go in a
few moves then I guess uh just to
investigate what is happening Here pawn
takes Pawn I think the idea is Bishop
takes and you mentioned this one uh
James but the Knight isn't quite
attacked for now you could make an
argument for pushing this Pawn forward
if the Knight is captured suddenly and
discovered attack against the Black
Brook black takes the time out to move
it then you're just in time to close
that cage again around this poor rook
and uh suddenly white has a great
structure has the bishop pair too so I
think this is his idea he wants to trade
off and then push this Pawn forward as
fast as possible sprinted up the board
just to keep things locked up I like it
yeah that's actually a cool idea he's
protecting his Knight on B6 tactically
and if you can get that pawn up to A5 it
feels like Black's pieces are stuck so
what is hikaru's plan that's the big
question and even though the evaluation
Bar says it's a level game I feel like
White's next few moves are quite obvious
and how black uh responsive those is not
so clear so I actually really like this
B4 push from Fabiano yeah B4 and before
it's too late he does ask those
questions to Hikaru uh first real think
of the game and uh yeah I'm really happy
with the outcome of this opening I've
got to say I was a bit worried when uh
studying the kind of the head-to-head
between these two so many berlins
between them so many really kind of
stodgy games Hikaru often quite liking
this solid start especially with black
against Fabi but uh yeah Fabiano is
known as one of the most ambitious
players on the tour and he's playing
like it yeah he's actually playing like
a squeezer here like more of a you know
a karpovian type you know squeeze here
usually you'll see more aggressive
calculating 5V calculator delay
calculate Prep Prep sack a piece like
you did on mvl after I got a Euro prep
right in the candidates so very strong
preparation but also here I mean you can
see he's saying I have both Styles I can
kind of do whatever in fact he says
there's a quote from cgc we was talking
about you know most most players have
Universal Styles right but the thing
that really uh separates them is the
calculation calculation over everything
he must be a hero for those calculations
of course oh yeah we're sending him a
lot of gear absolutely yeah and that's
on the board yeah it's on the board and
sneaky threat from Hikaru Nakamura he's
actually threatening right now to take
that strong White Knight with the black
rook and after white recaptures the
black queen and the white dark Squad
Bishop a bit of tension there the white
Dart score Bishop not protected black
woodwind material so you have to protect
that uh Bishop right now not sure how
Hikaru intends to continue it feels like
a one move threat I don't know if
there's any further substance there we
go most natural move defend that bishop
and uh just centralizes his work I
really like how Hikaru takes a little
thing and then just blitzes out a couple
of moves in a row and that puts so much
pressure on the opponent is that good
strategy for Blitz I think so it
definitely helps to switch up the pace
of the game you kind of keep your
opponent guessing I think not just Blitz
Tanya In classical chess I'm a time
travel addict I'm well known for it but
the one strategy I hate most as a Time
trouble addict is when my opponents stop
they kind of keep me nervous my
adrenaline's pumping and then they just
calm me down and then speed things up
again and uh it's just hard you kind of
want your opponent to Blitz you because
then you can kind of keep going going
you're getting a rhythm but as soon as
they switch things up you lose a bit of
focus and okay Hikaru blocks the
position
and uh still a bad Rook for him but the
rest looks pretty nice for luck and now
with the center blocked can't uh Fabi
display on both sides you've got this
Pawn on A5 and I start even thinking
about the king side yeah I like the look
of this position for Fabiano me as
you're saying playing on the king side
what does that look like white might try
to strike with F4 not available just yet
that black Bishop is lurking on B8 it's
still aiming towards the white king side
and black may play F5 himself so I need
some space for my pieces or that Knight
this Knight might Gallop that was on F6
to E8 over to C7 and then even up to B5
so don't be fooled that Knight is going
backwards so it could take two steps
forwards yeah that's a really nice post
for the Black Knight if it ends up there
uh can never be challenged and it will
lock down that flank that Queen side so
will we see Fabiano switch Focus we
could well see him just kind of switch
his Rook back and play for the pawn push
but of course that's risky too with the
sniper on B8 appearing over in that
direction
yeah I've got to say I don't know who I
prefer yeah I like the look of White's
position aesthetically but black has the
space in the center
it's very level very level it's just
going to take a few more minutes here
obviously to see you know who is going
to make a concession who's going to
break first in fact like in that Wesley
and Hikaru game that was just super
crazy where Wesley got low on time and
then he dropped the pawn but then it
still ended in the draw that was a wild
game it reminds me of that type of feel
in this position it's really tight it's
locked down lots of maneuvering Here
pawn breaks of course as Robert says
Whoever has the pawn breaks controls the
game so F4 actually is the pawn break
here and there is an F5 break but that
one maybe not so much that black would
like to do it does weaken the king but
F4 is definitely a nice Palm break to
try to get that 5 in Rook F1 also as
well as David pointed out we want to
maybe switch sides here and go to the
king side of the board if possible Yeah
you mentioned it's got similarities
really reminiscent of that game between
Wesley and Hikaru that one was a hundred
move grind right are we in for the Long
Haul here should we strap in our seat
belts and dirt just yeah get ready for
all those Maneuvers really hard to pick
a planet that's actually when the
players spend the most time it's not on
calculation because they're so quick
they practice that so much and they're
really Snappy with their calculation
it's when they're planning that the
players burn most of their clock time it
is these critical moments right we talk
about them so many times it's not just
about calculation but finding the right
path looking at trades looking at
changing Bond structures and that last
move by Fabi is hinting at a potential
Pawn storm on the king side and there it
arrives on Hikaru immediately captures
the position was again reminiscent of a
king's Indian type of setup for white
the center is blocked white plays on the
king side and this is one of the uh kind
of recommended antidotes to the king's
Indian
five break here is F4 with colors
reversed a trade of Pawns and yes it
looks a bit odd for black but as soon as
that black knight moves out the way I'm
loving the dark Square Bishop it's ready
uh to exert its influence into the
center but what I'm loving is the open G
file for white to attack on that's a
semi-open line black has a pawn there
white is gonna start putting pieces
there to attack the black king I like to
move F5 to start with let's just cement
that pawn structure in place the bishop
drops back to F7 then maybe bishop F3 my
point is I'm clearing the G file I don't
actually know where the white king will
end up it's not out of the question we
see a Petrosian King march towards the
center and even to the queen side but
we're gonna get a rook on G1 we're gonna
go Rook up the G file second Rook over
there we are going to attack dang Robert
you play The King's Indian before hey
Robert that's oh that's straight out of
the king's Indian book The Colors
reverse literally everything you would
do there wow that's nasty I don't need a
chain to tell me calculation over
everything I'm going for the attack
Robert S no can't do chess without Hess
you know what I'm saying wow the
hessible Masters okay here we go go yeah
that's nice stuff Bishop F3 F5 Queen G2
run the king over I mean all these ideas
are extremely strong for white here the
problem is the dark Square Bishop as
Robert pointed out too as well and David
Howell the good that dark Square bishop
and you do play F5 you don't have to
worry about those dark squares which are
very very loose here so I mean it's kind
of loose for both sides here I wonder if
you even go F5 yeah I love that idea
Robert but uh I guess Fabiano's decided
to be more flexible not willing to
commit right now that idea is still on
top for later and I'm expecting him to
reroute the White Queen first of all
she's kind of sitting on a nothing
square right now not doing too much I'm
expecting her to swing over and only
when his pieces are in position then
he'll decide which Central Pawn to push
forward he still has options for E5 F5
and of course uh to maybe maneuver a
rook towards that black king a bit later
on on the G file but uh yeah meanwhile
I'm looking for Black's plans and those
are far more mysterious it's definitely
not clear what hikara is doing
especially that Rook on A6 it's uh
basically being canceled out out by the
White Knight so the rest of the wood
white is material up and that's why I do
believe in fabiana's chances and wow he
goes for it immediately not maneuvering
any longer E5 and Fabiano going for it
you know what he might want is that
Knight on B6 that's stopping The Rook
over there if black decides to avoid any
kind of Trades he does not want to open
up the position we can understand that
if F5 is to be played then that Knight
might come back to C4 and into D6 and
look at those pawns on C5 and E5 it's a
clamp and that Knight will just sit in
front of all of Black's pieces and let's
just let's put the Knight on D6 and have
black take that Knight somehow oh gosh a
pawn will be passed and protected and
you see the evaluation is already Sky
High it would be a winning position for
white yeah what a pawn that is on D6 you
open up lines as well uh in the meantime
and look at this piece this is a dead
Bishop this is a dead Rook you're
essentially playing two whole pieces up
and uh White's pawns swimming all over
the black Army and of course this won't
happen Hikaru won't be so kind of
compliant he won't help Fabiano with
this plan but how does he stop it it's
actually surprisingly difficult if you
do take this Pawn you only open lines up
for the white Rooks uh firstly you can
take this Pawn back same idea that
Robert showed there also very thematic
typical for this type of position you
can throw a pawn forward and block
things up because there you go
and he just smiled
yeah I was definitely looking F5 and
then F6 just because I can do it and
then Pawn takes and I don't even know
what I'm doing next maybe Queen F2 Queen
H4 but the open files here let me
explain the bishop over back to D2 I
mean this is nasty the bishop is the
dark Square Bishop for black is in K
it's in caged by its own pawns here
right you play you can't play I mean you
can't play E4 but that's going to open
up more lines for me so this F5 move
followed by F6 is there I can even open
with a and I'm going back to the
original position I can do a D
um e e takes F6 here right so he's he's
under something some fire F5 is on the
board yeah I'm actually surprised
looking at the eval bar on our live
board that it isn't giving Fabi a bigger
Advantage because this is such a
difficult position for Hikaru currently
with that Bishop on B8 essentially
playing down a rook down a bishop all
the white spaces looking really good is
the eval bar deceptive in this kind of a
position is it practically more
challenging it definitely is I think
humans look at this position If This
Were a pure Blitz game if we took five
minutes off each of their clocks to say
black can't do anything White's just
gonna maneuver the pieces plant that
Knight on D6 hopefully and then win the
game but engines they do not have hearts
they do not have emotions they are
objective calm collected calculators and
it says what is White gonna do and
perhaps if white goes too ambitious then
black will be able to counter and that
Knight on B5 that's sitting over there
it could hop forward into the position
it doesn't threaten anything just yet
but you have to look out for some
potential sacrifices where black opens
up the board unfavorable terms for him
yeah still in the balance and Hikaru
keeping a poker face so maybe he's not
too stressed not too worried either
about his chances uh I'm liking this
maneuver I'm just kind of focused on it
right now I'm not sure what else white
can try other than dropping the Knight
back and into that beautiful D6 square
but neither player kind of too kind of
concerned by that right now what is
Fabby thinking about I guess the other
option alludes to something from earlier
on just Shuffle the white king into the
corner Shuffle one of the white Rooks to
the G file and start attacking that
black king immediately so two types of
uh kind of alternative strategies there
which one will Fabi go for I'm slightly
concerned about the clock time we do
know against Hikaru that could be fatal
being behind on the clock I'll be
looking like the thing oh well he can't
afford to think too much because this is
such a pleasant position he needs to
make a decision he needs to make it fast
the critical moment will arrive later
and you do need time when you're playing
against a resourceful player like Hikaru
Nakamura who sets up those tricky traps
all the time these are two giant turns
of the Chess World the top two players
from the United States World number five
Hikaru world number seven Fabi just
brilliant chess by them on in so many
Elite events but I have to ask you James
in this format when it's about speed
when it is about nerves is Hikaru a
favorite Hikaru is a huge favor here I
mean of course he's one of the strongest
people on the planet he even beat Magnus
in the speed test Championship I mean
magnets don't lose in the speed test
Championship but he does see Carl right
it's almost like you know who do you
pick I'll pick your car I'll pick
magnets you don't really know there and
Hikaru showed that I can hang with the
best I am one of the best I'm a world
champion too as well official random
that is but I mean the man is an
absolute Beast right we always say or at
least I say he's half man in the other
half we don't know yet because he is
very crazy when it comes to this chest
right especially in the faster time
controls here you don't want to get low
on time against uh against Hikaru and
right now fopi is actually doing that
has a better position but he needs to be
able to convert as we saw in the other
matches probably get along time it's not
a good thing yeah we've seen Hikaru
gasoline no time just collapses I see
that rapid ratings there isn't that much
difference 28 25 to Fabi 2839 for Hikaru
but it does seem that Hikaru in these
formats just is a stronger player yeah
and if you do take the averages
throughout the years of rapid and Blitz
chess especially Blitz chess which this
game will soon become then Hikaru does
have an advantage over Fabi so it will
be not right now but maybe later when
it's two minutes each or one minute each
where the nurse kick in and hikara's
experience might tell I just I don't
know how he wins all these title
Tuesdays I've got to say it's so hard
even get top 50 let alone to win it
every single time that's how consistent
Hikaru is as well and in order to break
that consistency you need something a
bit magic Fabiano looking for that now
yeah we saw some support there with
let's go Fabi with a selfie keep sending
us your selfies we are loving them show
us how you are watching the Champions
Chester on Instagram remember to use the
landscape mode with hashtag chess Champs
and you could win chessable credits for
your favorite course so keep them coming
yeah what a price nice price and clearly
it's attracting some of our viewers uh
there with their photos I saw someone
was feeling ill sorry hope you feel
better watching the chess but uh yeah
meanwhile mysterious moves on the board
this Rook Shuffle from uh Fabiano just
biding time maybe yeah so what I like to
say the side that controls the pawn
breaks off on the side of the adventure
there it is I was about to call for it
G5 you saw hikaru's previous move was
putting his own King in the corner now
he has to strike with Pawn to G5 because
white committed his Pawn structure in
the center and now black is trying to
undermine its defense you get rid of the
base Pawn that's the F4 Pawn the E5 Pawn
is next it will be under attack and when
the position opens up when things start
exploding actually Black's King is quite
safe and sound in the corner yeah it
doesn't uh look too safe but actually
it's deceptive you're right Robert this
uh there's simply no white pieces that
can attack this black king so there's
nothing to worry about and if we do see
that trade of Pawns I think black's
actually happily going to remove even
more shelter from his black king and the
queen could slide across with some
threats against the enemy King here it's
actually the counterpart that's more
that's in more danger and of course this
Pawn feels like now or never in terms of
this maneuver from Fabi he's resisted so
far but uh either in this position or
maybe after capturing he needs to get
this Knight back into the game he needs
to throw it in to just uh block up the
black activity on the D6 on the D6
Square to plug all those holes but uh
yeah I just worry about the momentum of
this game it feels like it's momentum
Hikaru right now Fabi may be playing a
bit too tentatively and uh Missing the
opportunities here Black's pawns now as
well advancing in the near future
looking good for Hikaru yeah also the
time issue the time issue for five I
mean that's a Kryptonite and they're not
just for Fabi for like really most
players besides grishek and artemia you
know when you get low on time you know
it you it's like a Kryptonite you just
you can't see as much as you would you
start to panic a little bit as he now
has you know under two minutes on the
clock versus Hikaru 649 that's a whole
piece up in a way of course if you think
about it that ways and he's it's
initiative black now Rook G8 maybe Rook
to G7 Rook H7 right we get the Rook
active and put it on H7 there's gonna be
problems with G4 E5 is hanging right now
I feel like initiative is definitely in
Black's favor yeah he's gonna have one
eye on the clock Fabiano one eye on the
board and you can't split your focus
like that against Hikaru Nakamura and
get away with it and yeah it feels like
an important moment now if Abby doesn't
find something magical over the next
couple of moves he could just get
steamrollered by those black pawns on
the king side the white king definitely
in some trouble it's amazing how this
game has turned because suddenly white
is the one without actual plans we your
plan is to defend your pawns that are
hanging to defend your king but black
has many plans including swinging the
queen over as you mentioned trying to
push those pawns I feel like it's a
problematically probably and his time is
certainly not helping that's the 17
piece as James likes to say absolutely
yeah 17th and potentially decisive piece
okay the White Queen has slid back some
ideas of going over to H5 checking that
black king but that can be easily
guarded against the black queen can act
as a blocker and a potential attacker
Hikaru looking up has he spotted
something concrete is he just trying to
raise up weigh up the pros and cons of
sliding that Queen across looks like the
most natural move for black right now
yeah a minute and 10 seconds to Fabi and
this this looks like the kind of
position that you need a good over on
the clock to navigate this is not going
to be easy no and you see Hikaru purse
lips got a finger on them The
pineapple's Shining behind them and on
his shirt but I think right now he's
looking to win this game typically you
go into a match oh I'll draw with black
that's a good result I'll try to win
with the white pieces but he senses the
moment and he does that perhaps better
than anybody he knows when his opponent
is flailing and right now Fabiano
dropping back with his Queen yeah it
threatens the check on H5 he is going to
stop that check for sure and I think
that hikar wants to win this game now
I'm actually surprised by the evaluation
to me it looks much better for black
that's still hovering towards the center
saying it's about level to me it looks
much much better for black simply easier
to play yeah it's insane that even with
the Rook stock on A6 it's been out of
the game for the entirety of the game
and yet hikarus managed to create all
these Chances with his other pawns and
pieces currently leading on the clock by
four minutes I think if Fabi can find a
way to bail out and get out alive of
this game with a draw he will take it
with both hands David yeah I would be
begging for a draw from recovery right
now in this position and the evaluation
bar might say it's roughly level but
that doesn't take into account the
momentum White's position started High
spin again slower slowly uh worse and
worse and also the clock situation of
course so one minute against five if
Hikaru makes a quick decision here which
I think he will in the next few seconds
then uh yeah Fabi back on the defensive
just slide across that black queen I
don't see why not block your king
protect your king and that a queen is a
king's best friend most of the time so
maybe he's contemplating grabbing that
white Pawn in the center that looks too
greedy however surely not it does look
too agreed it feels like it's loose it
just feels kind of loose I mean I
actually get maybe some initiative back
because I mean I play rookie E1 or even
Rook E2 maybe even start with Queen H5
check first then bring the queen The
Rook over to E2 which is a huge problem
for for black here I mean it's too many
weaknesses I also double the Rooks yeah
this is exactly what Fabi wants as
Bishop takes e there so maybe we're
going to see a G4 or Rook to G8 from
from Hikaru yeah maybe G4 actually you
mentioned James that's a very forcing
move one of the first ones we should
calculate just to block this Queen's
diagonal its path into H5 looks nice if
the pawn captures now suddenly the white
king is very very open vulnerable to
some checks potentially this one gets
very complicated hence maybe the time
consumption here from uh Hikaru Nakamura
the other options we mentioned Rook G8
very solid bringing the Rook across to
the right side of the board and also
Queen H7 just lining up and stopping any
checks so those uh okay he's finally
gone for that decision he's brought his
Queen across and big threat on the board
potentially firstly Bishop takes Pawn in
some scenarios and also Pawn to G4 uh
Fabi meanwhile shuffling his queen I'm
really not sure what he's trying to
achieve actually with this last one just
waiting holding some key squares maybe
and what's important is that in order
for black to attack your own King
becomes more vulnerable so hikar will
have to push pawns forward and that
means his King is weak and if you think
about it if that pawn on H3 the pawn in
front of the white king is removed that
means there's a rook that can get on
that line and hit the black king so
sometimes you do not want to win
material in fact that could backfire
completely and so Fabi he's relying on
that in many of these variations yeah so
uh Hikaru can pull the trigger can't
throw pawns for it but is it the right
moment will it rebound will it backfire
on him that's the question and he wants
to build up I think it's a good idea as
well when you're up on the clock as we
mentioned just keep the tension but how
does Hikaru do that how does he improve
his pieces before going for that white
king I'm kind of in James's corner here
just before I couldn't see it he plays
it bring that black Rook across uh maybe
even lift that black Rook down and
across onto the H file Rook lifts right
right that's right do you even Rook lift
exactly can you work live or no bro
exactly make sure you're doing your work
lifts every day chat every day and it
looks like Fabi is going to go under a
minute very soon here and this is gonna
be more of a bullet game than it is
anything else and we know who's stronger
in the bullet format I mean there's very
few people that can even keep up and eat
with Hikaru in bullet chess here so we
don't really want it to be in that
territory but we don't have a choice
here and for Fabi we have to make
something happen right now yeah and it's
Bobby looking at going in with that
Knight to that D6 square that would be a
nice post for this one I see fabi's
position and that Bishop on G2 looks
like the big Defender keeping things
together is that something that black
should try and get rid of with a trade
with his own Bishop getting it to D5
good question uh Tanya and uh okay we
don't have to answer it yet but I like
this move I like the fact as well that
if there is a trade at some point maybe
not in this exact position but later on
through blackrook might be able to swing
across let's go back to the game uh
after G4 wow this Pawn has advanced even
further and what's happened there's no
Rook H2 a lot of ideas with Rook H2 was
coming after like his Queen H3 check
right and stuff like that he that's why
it works on the second rank you can
cover with Rook H2 but now you can't
even play that so because I took that
away now Bishop D5 is a very juicy
looking move it's very strong move from
Hikaru they're playing uh G3 that was
definitely off the radar are you
shuffling around with the bishop he
I've got a feeling this might be the
monster eventually in Black's position
yeah could be a really nasty threat for
Fabi to deal with but what's better at
neutralizing an enemy Bishop than your
own bishop and uh White drops his Bishop
back if black plays Bishop G5 right now
the white Rook will happily step back
trades might actually help white because
you do have this Knight it is a beast
long term this is chaos I kind of forgot
that the knights are staring at each
other so that that white knight may take
the Black Knight it may take the pawn
that is two squares behind that black
knight like at some point so don't
forget that that Knight is actually
attacking things I thought I was just
sitting there hoping to be captured no
it's actually a weapon for white and I'm
starting to like Fabiano's position the
clock is evening up Bobby in time
trouble of course but I don't think a
car's moves are so easy and I could see
his position collapsing that G3 push
that could be an overextended Pawn then
white may be able to be able to capture
at some point yeah long term I like
white that night just nice and pretty
might decide the game what long time are
you talking about why it's got 30
seconds on the clock
it's not going to go on for very long
but Sabi does need to speed up currently
although also running low on the clock
coming to about a minute there
coming down to about it this one is just
going to be a scramble a hyper bullet
game
yeah I was talking long term just
because short term he currently needs
something he needs something now that's
why he's getting excited that's why you
can feel see the tension on his uh on
his face but what is it what can black
try you can try Rook G4 or um okay
Bishop there and then you're gonna see a
bishop trade now Bishop traits should
help white again long term end games
that's right so you want to get rid of
that light Square Bishop in these
positions so F4 oh nice
three yeah go for that white king it
would be consistent now hikaru's lower
on the clock for the first time in this
game will we momentum switched momentum
has turned
20 seconds hey Cara Nakamura this is
anybody's game here look at the clock
all of a sudden Fabi is ahead on the
clock so he has good chances in this
position hikar trying to bring more
pieces into the attack but he may need
to defend soon his pawns are
overextended he does not threaten
anything and I mentioned that White
Knight on D6 it can start capturing
pieces yeah you can take a knight you
can take a pawn you can take a bunch of
things here White's night actually is
spoiled for Joyce he does go and grab a
pawn that's not defended by its Rook has
Fabi just won a pawn for free oh Curry
steps back he's lost two moves the queen
just came from this Square Fabi says
okay I'll go back and I've nabbed a porn
for free same position that we had two
moves ago white has an extra Pawn
however 10 seconds for a Hikaru
okay that's a big Bond how is that a
blunder there might be a knight F7 check
you bring the knight in with check and
that means the King has to react but
that means you could just take this
bishop on I don't actually take the
bishop of the night so complicated G2
the king will take the queen will come
down the white king escapes it runs up
the board and there is no Checkmate this
is not King of the Hill but the king is
going to survive I can't play G2 what
black is attacking with Rook G1 oh my
goodness black is just attacking with
the queen that's not enough you need to
add extra ammunition and Hikaru has gone
down to a couple of seconds he made that
move with two seconds left James has
moved there but it just gets blocked and
you're a whole piece down which way do
you go with the white king four
dominant bunches don't worry buddy when
these moves are happening they come in
quickly and then the clock will catch up
oh my goodness what is that King doing
in The Bishop's line of fire that's a
resignation Queen H5 check whoa it
wasn't a night back with discover checks
are just winning the queen there's
nothing there's nothing he has nothing
that's it
he has nothing it's Rook a five he comes
back for a second is he about to make a
move he gave him that's it he resigns
what a game what a Time scramble there
and Fabiano caruana takes the lead in
his match against Hikaru not a result
that many would have predicted David big
tactical moments there what got your
attention so many moments but I just
want to go through the end in slow
motion to explain the thought processes
uh from each player here it had already
turned against Hikaru Nakamura with the
black pieces but he did make a blunder
he jumped in took upon what could be
more natural but this did fall out of a
simple check a night check hitting the
black king it's actually the black king
that gets hit first and after the Knight
takes a bishop a free piece it turned
out that the white king could safely run
into the center black simply doesn't
have enough attacking pieces we saw a
couple more moves here another check
forcing the white king to the side but
still no way to attack it no way to trap
this King a knight this time is the
King's best friend keeping the white
king nice and safe and Hikaru resigned a
few moves later the material deficit too
much to handle nice win nurse is still
from Fabiano caruana
very impressive stuff there by Fabi Kate
taking his King up all the way to G4 and
not get like made it that really is
something he survives and indeed how
takes the lead in his match against
Hikaru Nakamura Fabi with that win which
means Hikaru has to at least win one
game two level the score there is more
chess coming up but before that we are
going to head into a twitch break
foreign
the partner of the Champions chess tour
and chess.com
World Quant is a global firm in the
field of quantitative Asset Management
if you don't know what that is it's the
job of building complex mathematical
models that seek to identify Market
inefficiency
[Music]
for 2023 World Quant brain is bringing
together its International Quant
championship and the award-winning
Champions chess tour to hunt down the
next generation of Quant Finance
Specialists that sounds very exciting
you put your skills in practice in a
case competition where you get a real
Challenge and I signed up
worldquant is seeking new talent and new
energy and it's looking at the world of
Chess to help because nobody knows how
to analyze a position better than a
chess player right no Quan experience no
problem so do you think you have what it
takes to compete in the international
Quant championship
sign up and be the next Quant champion
[Music]
foreign
carwana famously had a 7 out of seven
start in the 2014 sink Full Cup he also
challenged Magnus Carlson for the 2018
World Chess Championship title how does
a player get there you might ask for
five out of caruana it is feared opening
preparation he is a theoretician like no
other in this 2016 game from the London
chess classic Fabiana Carr won a
demonstrate how deep his opening
preparation can go with the white piece
against Hikaru Nakamura Hikaru
sacrifices a knight temporarily with
Knight takes G4 after Fabiano takes this
Knight on G4 with his Bishop hikara
looks to win back the piece with E5
hitting the queen and the Knight with
his Pawn but Fabiano caruana was a man
on a mission he says you're not going to
get your piece back I'm going to
sacrifice my queen on F6 and after the
bishop took the queen he puts his Knight
on D5 the queen slides back because
under attack as the bishop of d8 and he
plays Knight F5 getting two pieces for
the queen but with a dominant positional
Advantage he went out to win this nice
game and just a great demonstration of
his excellent and deep opening
preparation
[Music]
and we are going to reveal the most
played openings of the chasable Masters
and wow no surprises there at the top
Sicilian that is such a classic such an
aggressive opening love it the players
going there for the attack and we've got
royal Lopez at number two Robert is
there something that surprises you about
this graphic
you know it is a bit surprising to see
the Sicilian at the top because at the
highest level it's not played that
frequently at least in classical chess
but when the time control gets shorter
the action heats up the players they
want to strike and capitalize on
tactical chances yeah I love it I love
the Sicilian I love to see it I love to
play it a Robert James take us through
how it's done absolutely well the
Sicilian starts with a standard opening
you know the King's Pawn goes forward E4
is best by test and when that pawn push
is played Black doesn't Strike Back in
the center instead pushing the Queen's
Bishop pawn two squares forward and the
point of this is that if white wants to
push in the center black will be able to
capture it with the C5 Palm we will not
get symmetrical structures and early on
In the Sicilian white has a number of
options while Knight F3 is the main
second move you could keep it closed you
could play Knight C3 on move two and in
those lines James I think he's gonna be
a fan of this we can get some Grand Prix
attack and fun closed at the start but
they are going to get ambitious and open
in the future absolutely I'm a big fan
of Cecilia myself of course if you go to
Chesterville right now my favorite is
actually the Knight or Cecilia in the
night or Sicilians right you have uh so
many variations that you can go with but
one of the biggest courses on chessable
will be Gary's night of Sicilian you
also have separin off night or Sicilian
which is a newer one more aggressive
they have Raphael Lido Sicilian
adjustable you got colvik nidor front
chestibu you got all these chestable
nightworth Sicilians right this is the
most they call it the Rolls-Royce of
Sicilians it's a really a nice Sicilian
to play lots of tactics positional and
everything that you can get from a
Sicilian Defense I just learned about
every course I'm gonna have to go get
some myself because I haven't brushed up
with a knife in a while I like to keep
things closed so I'm about to get into
those open positions for sure I'm
definitely a big fan of of course so you
guys go get go to Chesterville get the
free short and sweets or just buy all
the courses go get all accessible
courses especially in a night or
Sicilian or your favorite Sicilian many
different variations a lot of fun on all
of them
wow love it
that felt like a 101 on Sicilian that
felt like a mini course on the Sicilian
that you and Robert just gave us David
you gotta grade them on that one yeah a
style for presentation guys
but it's amazing that we got to see the
Sicilian I think as commentators we love
it when we see a 1c5 on the board oh we
absolutely do and you know he mentioned
in these Furious course that's the most
popular course on chest well he's still
alive in division two by the way so
maybe we'll see some neither from Geary
oh yeah you've seen Maxine we've seen
Anish come out with those big night outs
but right now of course Hikaru has to
come out with something big as he is
trailing in his match against Fabiano
caruana Sabi takes the lead
is that something that surprised any
surprises any of you absolutely of
course I mean Hikaru just being the
favorite many times in many matches I
mean we saw it with Fred to say it was
like yo if I say of swinging like he
cares about it on a brink of elimination
and I mean he he was able to uh to to
win that one but with this one here Fabi
starts with a strike there that's very
good especially with the white pieces
that's the way you're supposed to do it
position
at either ways yeah for sure just about
10 15 moves before the end if you pause
there we saw Fabiano with a slightly
worse position and only one minute on
the clock so the fact he navigated it
turned it around and finished it off
very impressive stuff yeah but now
Hikaru starts with the white pieces
that's dangerous Robert yeah but five
out of car won extremely well prepared
and with that one game lead yes hikar is
dangerous but I don't even know what
first movie he's gonna play yeah the
bigger question is what is the festival
that black is going to play is it going
to be a sicilian uh definitely not zero
chance coming from five out of Corona
assistant no way so you think he's going
to keep it more solid well if hikar even
plays E4 yes solidity is the theme of
the day and I think it will serve him
well yeah but we but we'd see fabi's
with the the situation he's got to be a
little careful on that yeah if he keeps
struggling like that he's going to give
his car a lot of chances absolutely I
mean of course he was lucky enough that
that position was very tactical he was
able to calculate him for calculation
over everything he's a healing
calculator right he was able to
calculate his way through that with a
little bit of time that he had on the
clock here but in this next one or these
next few matches in these next few games
if he's too low on time and he car was
definitely going to be able to strike
him he had a huge time in Chicago that
is and you cannot give him this every
single game
whites left in his match against Fabiano
caruana he needs to score at least one
point to level that score David what's
the strategy in such a situation do you
stop the bleeding or do you take your
chances with white
in such a short match I think you have
to take your chances you can't just take
your time out you can't just allow your
opponent to get one step closer to that
Finishing Line and uh yeah Hikaru he's
gonna go for it here and now if he can
smiling he looks like he's in a good
mood yeah that's not a that's not a
happy that's not that was more of a I
can't believe I messed that up I'm a
when you see Fabiano he's heating
up both on the chessboard and literally
I'm pretty sure that's a heat pad and I
wonder if there's some Mortal Kombat
because he might have taken artemi of
soul and started playing like him in
time travel get over here and you know
Bobby well Robert you know Fabi well you
called it out a very solid approach by
Bobby in response to the king spawn
opening he starts with E5 and we have
got a royal Lopez a Spanish on the board
yeah Spanish with an early D3 so this
last Pawn push that white has made
prevents Fabiana from capturing a pawn
in the center of the board going into
very forcing lines Hikaru may be trying
to dodge some early exchanges and Fabi
looked away for a second there he looked
a bit annoyed at himself maybe he okay
looking down this time maybe he's just
not predicted correctly Hikaru
nakamura's opening strategy but it's
rock solid for black of course you've
got this nice solid structure you can
just get developed get your pieces out
castle that black king and it can't be
too bad white does have nice space now
it's that Phoenix structure you
mentioned earlier James with the white
pawns on e4 D3 uh C4 making that nice
little triangle with that nice little B
there and uh what do you think I think
this is I think this is a new a newer
type of Roy that you will see here you
usually don't see with the C4 I mean
that's just one that is played rarely
but it is it has some Venom to it
because it stops B5 the problem is we
can't actually go D4 or the way we want
to because obviously the forest is on
clamp right now by the black pieces
right so usually I'm actually surprised
by this Choice from 5v2 as well by
playing the D6 is usually more of an
aggressive player and with the Roy he
plays more of the Archangel variations
with an early Bishop to she's to C5 has
tons of great games with that so
definitely different here he went for
the more uh slow slightly not passive
but slightly uh worse because of the the
structure here and Etc but I think it's
it's interesting that Hikaru played the
C4 4 line here try to maybe take him out
of prep he did look down like Bobby
looked down and was like looked away
like wasn't expecting this one so I
think that's a good choice for me Carl
yeah it feels like Fabius freestyling
slightly I'm pretty sure Fabi would be
happy on the white side of this position
with the black side slightly cramped
maybe less so and uh for Hikaru it's a
win in terms of opening strategy just
because he's kept all the pieces on the
board and that's uh step one if you want
to win a game and while we're deep in
the action here in division one I just
want to give a shout out to Vladimir
kramnik I keep updating you on the match
she had with Maxine vashilagrove and it
turns out after Maxime he lost on time
he disconnected in a drawn position that
would have won in the match Vladimir
Comics said we don't have to go to
Armageddon I concede the match to you
you would have won fair and square so
great sportsmanship by both these two
players and I think they deserve a
tremendous shout out from everybody so
Maxima Sherlock moves on in division two
but both players they are real champions
wow what a guy gave him the match and
just because he's so here you go bro you
take it right I mean it just tells you
the character of these guys right that's
that's fire yeah you can still be a
gentleman even if you're a world
champion and a nice touch there from
Vladimir kramnik uh yeah well played to
both of them and uh degrava does
progress to the final of the winners
bracket in division two meanwhile uh
this one's still a maneuvering face last
move just defending everything I think
Fabi here would love a trade of at least
one set of minor pieces because he's a
bit cramped uh black lacking space here
so any traits would free up his position
somewhat meanwhile my car is just ready
to kind of improve his pieces at will
every move slightly improves the scope
and eventually we will see the position
open but uh yeah who will take that
first step in terms of clock times very
much as expected Hikaru slightly ahead
at this early stage
quite a closed position right now and
we've been talking about brakes while
one of the central breaks that white
does have potentially in the position is
to strike with that deep pawn and that's
something that you've got to always
watch out for is Fabi in this kind of a
position ever thinking about a king Side
Pawn roll move that night away start
pushing that pawn in front of the Rook
is that an idea that Hikaru needs to
watch out for it's this is more of a
king's indian-esque I mean it feels like
a king's Indian with just a knight on C6
it actually is sort of the same
structure you have a bishop on G7 the
Knight on F6 right the the pawn on E5
right now the Knight on C6 is a little
bit different but you do have that
option of playing Knight H7 as David
pointed out or 98 sometimes even Knight
H5 but you have to be careful because
the queen is x-raying through the Knight
on F3 that you may have problems if you
play F5 and try to take back with the
pawn the Knight on H5 may have some
issues there so the sword of King's
Indian s here but you do have to be
careful because this is not a case in
here it is right pieces are a little bit
different but you can play it uh
definitely a king's Indian like yeah you
got a break we do just before the center
gets blocked before black can go for
that type of play uh Hikaru he strikes
forward with uh Pawn to C5 and yes maybe
he's allowing some porn traits but he's
saying my pieces are more ready than
yours and for example if Fabiano
captures this Pawn the white Bishop will
step forward recapture and now again
questions do you step forward why white
has more Central pawns white has the
pawn breaks and as we know often you
prefer your chances if you have access
to these types of moves maybe you start
getting ready first maybe the white Rook
slides across the white Bishop steps
back on the same diagonal as the black
king plenty of options plenty of
flexibility and Fabiano instead chooses
symmetry Above All Else he says you know
I just want to keep this position close
for now I do not want to give Hikaru an
extra point in the center of the board
and this is what the players can do
there's this tension between the D6 and
C5 pawns as he car shuffles his Rook
over to C1 he's anticipating the opening
of that file he could choose when that
happens but look at Fabiano's Foundation
it's very solid here there are no more
inroads I don't know what movie makes I
don't see a plan for him but I just
don't see how white crashes through if
you were to give Hikaru a free turn or
three yeah that's fascinating this
tension it's like both sides want that
capture to happen but they want it on
their own terms black wants it on their
own terms in terms of white making that
trade white uh kind of making the pawn
structure symmetrical black is saying
okay I don't want to take you because
then you get more Central points and I
think that's just good conventional
wisdom for chess uh fans in general
don't trade unless you really have to
unless it's on your terms it has to be
either forced or fantastic for your
position and uh I see so many players
who are new to the game they see a trade
they go for it just because they assume
it makes the position more simple and as
I say that
Knight H5 and we live he's trying to go
Knight F4 for the score baby you want to
put that boy right on F4 and even uh
there's a Gary Kasparov quotas that says
uh a knight on F5 wins games right so
you know it doesn't actually win the
game but what he's saying here is it's
just very close into the position and
very annoying to face which is uh hence
the move Knight D5 I'm going to snap
that Knight off F4 as fast as you put it
there because Knight F4 will be very
annoying with some type of attack on the
king side but is that something that you
consider anyway because after a trade
you do end up opening that Bishop on G7
and we know what a monster that Bishop
can be on the long diagonal also
targeting that Queen side weakness so a
big decision critical moment here for
Fabi to decide if it's worth it to
destroy the pawn structure but in return
open up your Bishop yeah big gamble here
the downside is that white does have
Central pawns and it will rest on the
fact that white maybe can stop this Pawn
forward if black can strike now on these
two Central pawns then of course you can
go for this but if not then you have to
avoid this and wow okay he moves his
Bishop he's allowing his own structure
to be shattered here Fabi but uh if the
bishop captures the Knight The White
Knight will be forced back and maybe
then the Black Knight can jump in maybe
not the right direction as well yeah the
B2 Pawn as well maybe you jump back in
this direction before I was thinking
hacking some pawns but oh it's risky
these top players don't like giving up
their Bishop pair but her car is clearly
thinking about it look at his face it's
an ugly continuation and first looks
like it's ugly for black because those
pawns but if black were to ever step the
queen up one to protect the pawn you
also thread Bishop takes H3 as a
sacrifice with Knight F4 to follow this
is standard attacking style for black
and pawn structure is often overrated
Daniel nerdinsky Don just says all the
time that that's maybe one of the things
that people talk about too much in chess
is how the punk structure looks it may
be aesthetically unpleasing for black
but tactically I think it is quite
dangerous very dangerous uh I know
there's some famous quotes out there by
former world champions it's like forget
Pawn structure Checkmate ends the game
players forget that I forget that quite
often I'm so carried away with all these
little details these nuances the uh the
way the position looks but I forget to
go for checkmate and uh I've lost so
many points because of that and these
top players they're able to switch from
the Strategic uh considerations to the
dynamic and that's why they're so good
uh someone in it as it says on the
feature chat Bobby spending too much
time at the gym he got that thing on his
shoulder there I told him hey look man
you're gonna have to like you know we
can hit in but we got to stretch before
and after make sure your protein is
correct right 80 nutrition I'm gonna
call them I'm gonna call them after this
I'm gonna call them probably gonna have
to get right look like he has some pain
there but that's okay he is in the gym
so hopefully you're doing the same chat
at home yeah it's because he was flexing
too hard in the last games
no pain no gain
you know but he's he's playing a good
match thus far right game one that was a
game where you would expected hikara to
come out on top he had the lead on the
clock it was his type of position but
Fabiano he held steady when he needed to
he kept actually uh steady on the clock
as well and he did not flag he did not
fall on they're too much time to rest
and here in game two he's playing great
moves he's countering White's jumps in
the center and akaro needs to win that's
the problem he doesn't necessarily need
to win this game but he needs to get
back on the scoreboard and that puts all
the pressure on akara Nakamura
yeah you can't lose Hikaru if he loses
he's on the brink so Bishop takes Knight
for example the move we were discussing
earlier it's risky it imbalances things
as Robert pointed out black has the
foundations the skeleton of an attack
against the white king potentially
especially if that Black Knight on the
edge of the board gets into that dream
F4 square that uh James was pointing out
leaning in what is he what is he seeing
in the position he's definitely
calculating some lines there he's seeing
something that we don't maybe exactly
that's scary will he lean in like that a
lot of times he's like oh shoot okay
hold on but I mean really hey the
probably honest playing this position
very well but should be six was a move I
think he did not anticipate here because
you have to make some type of concession
you got to do something now you either
take on C6 and if you move this Knight
the Knight F4 is definitely going to be
coming so you have to do something right
now so that's why he's using his time
now to figure this thing out I mean if
you try to defend the Knight Bishop B3 I
mean he takes the Knight right on D5 and
then he puts the other he comes back
with Knight F4 I mean once again that
Knight on F4 is extremely strong super
annoying right in this case so you're
gonna see where you come comes up with
in a few minutes here yeah he's about to
make a decision his hand is back on the
mouse and wow he Retreats immediately
wow not going for that trade of pieces
first but this feels like a step in the
wrong direction after a capture we don't
see uh any complications yet it's just a
trade but there is a threat against that
black rook and Fabby deals with it
easily that black knight is coming in
and that was a nice trick David if you
could just back up and you can show us
why Hikaru did not have the time to
actually pick up that Rook on it when
Fabi traded the knights yeah yeah he
could not capture this Rook because Fabi
does have time for an intermediate move
there are actually a few moves here
there's a bit of choice but maybe the
simplest is to take this Pawn with the
Knight and now this is a fork a double
attack and this bishop of course is
loose as well yes white is up a rook for
minor piece right now but that would
last long so uh here uh Fabi did have
the time after Bishop takes Knight to
just solidify just to block this threat
and now as we mentioned this Knight is
coming in how do you prevent that if
you're Hickory camera not easy anymore
and whoa he takes a time out to push his
Pawn you say I don't care about none of
that he's like yeah put the Knight on F4
were you about to show us because I'm
definitely putting that I don't F4 drop
it in and this is a monster threat
Knight takes porn backed up protected by
the black queen he puts his Rook on a
really weird Square to defend but I fear
for Hikaru it definitely feels like this
is the position where it could spiral
out of control if black can just move
his Queen get the Rook into the game
this opponent is a massive Target that's
very simple Queen D7 I also like you
know we like aggression G5 and then G4
and it takes right and then I mean it
even opens up lines here Queen F6 Queen
G6 is there too as well the fact that
hey you're in a pin you can be pinned
here G5 G4 is nice Queen D7 is nice I
mean there's all kind of stuff here yeah
looking good for black I've got to say
Robert what do you think no I don't like
this at all for a car and I think part
of it is the match score he really needs
to get this game I think he's feeling
that pressure because Fabiano extremely
well prepared you need to maximize your
chances game one did not go hit Cara's
way despite the good position and the
lead on the clock here in game two
Fabiano has no problems whatsoever not
just on the board but also on the clock
with the downfall that could have been
in game one was on the clock he's
keeping steady there his position is
better he has more activity he's more
Harmony between his pieces of White's
Bishops over there on the queen side
they're not really doing anything not
threatening anything whereas black May
sacrifice a bishop on H3 for an attack
and the pawn on D3 is backwards and
threatened by numerous black pieces I
think the next few moves should be quite
easy for Fabiano to play and I like the
start I like this first move kicking
back white start Square Bishop from its
active post just hey Karu okay he steps
back now I wouldn't be surprised if
another Pawn follows there we go play
with the momentum you step back I step
forward and uh all of those white
Bishops being kicked now Hikari trying
to trade things off but suddenly there's
stuff to calculate suddenly there are
tactics in the air and I'm wondering
whether Fabi can get greedy here to try
and grab a pawn some tricks oh I'm
trying to work this out what do we think
here there are some tricks to take but
then if you take on D3 I mean is there a
rook D1 but then they C5
what is going on here yeah this is the
first thing you calculate right it works
great you win a pawn if it doesn't you
can rule it out and move on to more
positional uh decisions Knight takes
Pawn Rook to D1 it looks like a pin and
here I just stopped here the Knight can
Retreat attacking the White Queen and I
thought okay this is too complicated
let's let her family work it out but I
guess the whole uh kind of evaluation
here rest upon Rook takes Queen Knight
takes Queen and we head to the end game
and at the very end white does take this
Pawn so I'm not sure that that would
have been a good idea Fabby says nope
don't want to calculate it why not just
Advance all these pawns forward look at
the pawn storm incoming on the queen
side wow it's like Space Invaders over
here they're going forward and they're
actually creating threats because now
the pawn on D3 is actually under attack
and black and pushed the B Pawn push
that forward to it kick that Bishop out
of its nice perch on C3 so I feel like
Fabiano just gaining ground in this
position we saw Hikaru drop back to
defend that pawn on D3 but that is a
permanent weakness it's what we call a
backwards Pawn you cannot push it
forward and a pawn can't defend it so
this is a big problem for Hikaru
strategically Fabiano caruana planting
that night on F4 a pawn star on the
Queen's side this is the second game in
a row where Fabi Has Come On Top after
the opening phase of the game currently
the clock is level Fabiano putting the
pressure on Hikaru he's definitely
feeling the heat right now James well
100 he's feeling the heat here he
actually needs to kick this Knight off
for f42 as well I mean I think I
remember even Robert talking about
halves of the board which is very
important to understand like this Knight
is on the half of the board right side
of the board and this Knight is very
strong right so you need to kick it
there's something in fact at a panchenko
book actually I was talking about in
mastering middle games this was actually
one of them I think it was in a
prophylaxis chapter but it was about
King H2 and you've seen karpov do this
King H2 and petrogen actually the king
H2 Knight to G1 and you play G3 you kick
the Knight away and then eventually you
start pushing forward but that takes
some time and you have to do this
because this Knight is so annoying and
you have to kick it away yeah is that is
that super important for Hikaru right
now to get rid of that Knight on F4 I
think it's important but it's also very
difficult to do we just saw by James
denounce it takes a few moves to get
that done and even once you kick the
Knight out of there you still have other
problems across the board that pawn on
D3 long term weakness that I mentioned
black and continue pushing pawns on the
queen side we saw him play A4 look at
Fabiano he's just saying you're not
going to push any of your pawns you're
not gonna gain control of key squares
I'm going to push when I'm good and
ready and the position looks excellent
for black on the queen side as well you
said you're not going to push any of
your pawns hit Cardwell answers it by
putting pushing the pawn on the king
side H4 on the board is this bravery or
desperation
I think it's a bit of desperation and it
needed to be done it's similar to what
James pointed out the white king could
have also gone to H2 basically identical
the plan it was to kick back this Black
Knight but now the Black Knight is going
to relocate itself into the center and
still this is maximum control this is
domination I've got to say from Fabiana
caruana he's just controlled all of the
important squares in the center all of
the pawnbricks at White's disposal and
white is stuck white has to play purely
with his pieces while black is going to
start ganging up against the weaknesses
that Robert has pointed out I'm looking
at that white Depot and that backward
Pawn easy target all of the black Rooks
are actually going to line up against
that weakness and they might well just
overwhelm nakamura's defenses he does
not look happy at all Hikaru right now
with his position the ugly position very
ugly position and uncharacteristic in a
way from Hikaru here I mean really Bobby
is taking it to him in this match right
now something that we all expected uh
Hikaru to be just better here but in
fact Fabi is is turning it on its head
he's also doing great on time from the
previous game and he was down so much
time now you know he's doing way better
on time here with the black pieces too
as well and really trying to assert the
dominance here and say hey look you're
going to be very close to elimination if
you lose this game yeah is creating a
bit of a mess here right now he is
provoking Fabi on the king side it's
going to be a bad idea to capture that
pawn yes it's a free Pawn but you can't
afford to give a nice Square to the
White Knight so hey Carl here Robert
really trying to make the position as
messy as he can he is he's doing a good
job of it as you're saying if you take
that pawn think about the squares that
are left behind anytime a pawn moves the
squares that were previously under
control no longer that's what GTX H5
will be met by Knight H4 into F5 that's
a light Square you have a dark spot
Bishop it means you can't compete with
it and that's going to be a problem so
there's no way Fabiano is going to take
that pawn he has two options either he
pushes his Pawn forward in the starting
position so your Knight's not getting
over there even if I weaken the square
or he says what's the big deal you're
actually you take me on G6 I take back
that opens up the f file and maybe I can
use that with attacking chances so I
feel like Bobby he slides his Rook over
he understands it's not the end of the
world to see that capture the I said E5
Pawn you're not gonna be able to attack
it very simply yeah yeah and uh
Potential Threat on the board the Knight
could jump in due to some tension now
between the BlackRock and the White
Queen so hinting at something along that
line hikara instantly drops back and
still the tension remains between these
two pawns I'm not sure what I would do
to be honest I would love to push this
Pawn forward but long term you could
imagine the White Knight somehow
sneaking into this square and punishing
you later it takes a while to get there
but uh all these top players they're
hesitant to create those long-term
weaknesses and uh Fabi again just
keeping control not changing the Status
Quo defends the pawns with his King the
one thing I do see potentially going
wrong for Fabi is after the white king
steps up some Brooks or Queens are
sliding across if things do open up the
black king maybe not entirely safe but
uh yeah for now it's all under control
and the white Knights actually jump
jumped back I'm not sure where it's
going from there but uh maybe opening up
a path for the White Queen
now Hikaru it's hustle mode I feel like
and he wants to at least scare Fabi with
some ideas
I don't even know where we're going what
is the idea this is a sub maybe King G2
Knight G4 like you mentioned or like
with the uh the idea of Queen H1 or
something like that this is very hard to
make anything work in this position I
don't have any pawn breaks right so I
can't play F4 it's on lock the only
thing I have is like the H file my Rook
is strangely placed on E3 I do have to
defend the D3 Pawn because it's backward
um I'm always worried about a B4 push at
some point I have to move the bishop out
of the way then the D4 Square opens up
and it's annoying now A4 will be hanging
in some cases there so maybe I would
like that but here it's definitely
difficult for white so to make some
ground here I hope if I'm white I'm like
Bobby please keep thinking right because
like so you can get lower on time and
that's when you start to make mistakes
yeah but that's a big question what you
just said that is before a possibility
or not and James you called it Fabi
agrees it is time to push that Bond but
pressure and control the D4 Square for
his own night but now he's gonna watch
out for that A4 Pawn which is a little
tender yeah look in a car he drops that
Bishop back to E1 he does so quickly
that's the most important thing he's
doing you look at the clock the two
minute Advantage for the moment and
Fabiano he has a nice position but the
A4 Pawn is targeted he might need to
defend he says no I don't need to but
can we grab it
why not exactly he's grabbing and then
what's the next move F5 I don't
understand what did he what are you
doing this is okay okay Queen D1 I'll
take take yeah
yeah and take the juicer right we have
the juice yeah this would be the outcome
of or that uh taking or that uh little
transformation that and at the very end
black does have active pieces so okay
rather than investigate this Hikaru has
simply put his Rook on a newfound
Outpost this C4 Square wasn't previously
available to White and cannot be
challenged by Black's pieces nice little
move and this one is not going anywhere
anytime soon still a target for later on
that was a great move that was great
white Robert yeah no it looks good I
mean James just using a square that was
previously unavailable and now I feel
like black he's on the clock again yeah
yeah he's back on the clock again Rook
C4 was very nice he's also attacking B4
for real like I'm going to take it twice
and actually get my pieces active A4 is
hanging you go B3 A4 still hangs that
actually is a very nice move it was very
precise here and you need these of
course these counter punching moves or
Tempe you know a Tempo extra time right
you need this and that was a time
grabbing move there and it also makes
poppy think here Rick C4 was very nice
we do have to deal with the B4 Pawn
actually hanging now it was so tempting
for Fabi to push those pawns but is it
turning around right now Robert
I think the position objective is okay
for black but it is starting to get into
scary territory because you had
everything under control but the last
couple moves have gone White's way your
Pawn is hanging directly on B4 and on A4
White's rook and queen they're teaming
up on those pawns and black you don't
just want to go defensive in this
position so fabi's played very well to
this point but the trajectory is going
in hikara's favor yeah it was the last
game the moment the momentum the
trajectory was going up and down up and
down and here it's all been Fabby until
the last few moves he's lost control and
now he steps back with his Queen we're
all leaning forward here because is he
not just losing opponent is he not
picking up a porno before I think it's
just about activity just trying to keep
your pieces active yeah
can be taken immediately here and now
and uh okay why not just go for it what
is the big idea is it that uh here for
example there are tricks the Knight
would now jump in with a double attack
if white takes the other way however uh
then there might also be tricks I'm
looking for them now I don't see
anything immediately but it feels like
there's tension between the Queens after
Rook takes Rook there's no way you can
jump the night out effectively to attack
this White Queen it looks a bit scary
before it looks a bit loose but you are
a pawn up and there's a lack of
coordination between the B2 and C4 Pawn
so this is what strong players do they
give up material saying it's not the end
of the world for me to be down upon look
at all of the Practical play I get the
C4 Pawn is lose the B2 Pawn will also be
a Target I think that's what Fabiano is
relying on maybe just Queen C6 Rook C8
team up on that C4 pawn and perhaps
there's no way to defend especially with
that White Knight on H2 it's out of play
very strong he doesn't go for it instead
he makes a small little move on the king
side just stepping up with the king so
easy to even miss that this move has
happened on the board doesn't pick up
the B4 Pawn avoids the complication and
now Fab he shuts it down on the queen
side yeah now Fabi has a beautiful
Square for the Black Knight to jump into
really disturbing the harmony between
White's pieces maybe Hikaru being too
brave there just keeping the tension one
move too uh too long and the top plates
they're not greedy they prioritize peace
activity over everything uh other than
calculation
but yeah suddenly fabi's got control
again what do we think
yeah that's exactly where I think
probably definitely has control now he
may have had to try to go for that pawn
but me Rob had a great point there of
course so you just give up the pawn you
should you may be getting the backline
pieces are so active here I mean in this
position I feel like I'm just suffering
now I mean look at this past this boy's
past and then if Knight C2 happens I
mean that's super annoying maybe exactly
exchange but that's not necessary like
it's my pieces just feel very strange
here but I mean okay A4 we couldn't
argue that A4 is very weak the queen is
tied to it right now we also have C5
that maybe we can attack at some point
um it's gonna be difficult but chances
for both sides here definitely I think
Bobby has a slight Edge yeah can Fabi
try and reroute that Bishop make that
dark Squad Bishop a little active bring
it to G5 somehow I see the Rooks that
Hikaru has and it just feels like
they're a little shaky there does this
sound weird but I think Fabian doesn't
want to win the game not that he's
trying not to if it presents himself but
he just wants to make a draw he
understands with a full point lead in
this match he'll get white in game three
he could end the match with the draw
here and then a win with white in game
three but he can play it safely
likeliest outcome between two top jams
is a draw so why take unnecessary risk
and the position is closed now Hikaru
himself didn't want to capture that pawn
because it felt like it actually allowed
Fabiano to make an easier path towards
equality with some liquidation with some
easier moves especially in time travel
but we see a backfiring a car is already
in for a deep think and his position I
think is worse than Fabiano's yeah the
main thing is not to lose control if
you're Fabiano and of course he's lost
control slightly compared to what he had
earlier he's slightly behind on the
clock but things are moving back in his
direction we mentioned the momentum
going up and down it was all Fabby then
suddenly Hikaru now back to Fabi and
that is a very positive thing for him
but okay the nitrate imminent now white
hoping to be able to capture Knights
Black's Knight is of course his
strongest piece does Fabi say yes or no
to that which one Hikaru which one is
Hikaru gonna fear most keeping Knights
on the board or trading them off
be a good question now yeah big question
and there was a big question in chat
that I saw we've been talking about all
the trumps in fabi's position and chat
wants to know what is a good plan here
for Fabi position looks great but what's
next
good question improve the pieces it's
very much moved by move and you very
much have to adapt react to your
opponent's ideas too so this last move
you have to react if you're Fabby either
you agree to the nitrate and you have to
weigh up the pros and cons there or you
do jump in we mention a very juicy
Square for that Black Knight on C2 a few
moments ago and you can jump in gain
time there we go there it is it does it
and uh David yeah the white Rook has to
step back it's trapped unless you
sacrifice but I don't think you'll get
enough compensation there
maybe oh it is a bit sad retreating
though so what do we think here is he
going to sacrifice Rook for night he's
thinking about it Hikaru he's definitely
thinking about it because there's
something that we've forgotten about and
I think the players might have forgotten
about that pawn on H5 that Rook Pawn
that's all the way over there it can be
captured right if the Rook goes back to
E2 maybe it's time just take this Pawn
on H5 because yes your knight can go to
H4 but then I'm gonna play Bishop F6
I've cleared some of the path in front
of the black king and maybe it's the
white king that's going to be in grave
danger so I actually think Fabiano oh
he's done it his captain
wow he might be going for the white king
suddenly switching Focus completely I
forgot about this side of the board I
assume that attention will be there
until the end of time but uh suddenly
black could be the one throwing pawns
forward you want a pawn why not give it
back open up the white king and look at
this the white king under huge trouble
this Black Knight on its own paralyzes
at least three of White's pieces and you
switch focus and go for checkmate
looking good and then make it hard
backwards to kick that white knight out
of there as well so I feel like black is
just holding all the cards here this is
not a fun position for Hikaru and I'm a
little bit surprised by Fabiano's last
move but he's just going for the brute
force method he's going for this D3 Pawn
they're actually tactics in the air
because the neon C2 can also capture
that bishop and he wanted some moment
it's a very very careful of your car
this is
though he's just lost
Aqua that Rook to C3 to keep it
protected but it's not a happy move the
C Pawn can potentially Advance down the
board putting more pressure on that
pinned D3 Pawn is this how bad is this
for Hikaru this position oh this is ugly
this is very ugly you don't see this
type of a car all the time usually
you're used to Caro dominating having
good positions or having chances you
know what I mean like it felt like I
think he had a strategy here in a way of
like you know Fabiano that is of like
actually just keeping things very solemn
sort of a Wesley soul type thing here
where like I mean there's yes there's
tactics but at the right moment we go
for the tactics I mean both positions
have been like positional masterpieces
from Fabiano it feels like here I mean
very good position there were slight
tactics in this game but I mean
everything's locked down look at the
control same way in the last game he had
a knight that was controlling all the
pieces right the night in the pawns on
the queen side of the board and then we
move to the other side same situation
here he put the Knight on C2
everything's clamped down and he's going
to the other side he's just playing on
both sides of the board he's playing
brilliantly right now he's the car with
the head shake on in a minute 30 here I
mean this is rough this is very rough
yeah I'm slightly surprised that the
evaluation bar is not drastically in
Black's favor it's slightly in Black's
favor if I uh if I'm seeing it correctly
but there must be a way for Hikaru to
keep the game going at the moment we all
seem to think he's about to lose a
second pawn and no compensation but
where is uh yeah where is that idea
there must be something sneaky so what
happens on rig D2 like what whatever
you said I mean he was like no please
don't Jin because you were thinking the
same thing James is like Rook D2 let's
defend it we're like
Shield my eyes
yeah you're right because it's so ugly
this bishop would not be happy oh man
that Bishop can slide up to G5 targeting
that Rook on D2 but instead Hikaru
actually hits fabi's Rook on d8 but he
still has time to pick up the D3 pawn
and he does it it's an end game with two
extra pawns for Fabi Fabiano caruana has
won nine games against
16 games to him Hikaru considered by
many a favorite in this format but Fabi
so far dominating this match yeah
dominating he is two pawns up however I
will say that black does have some
weaknesses black has those doubled H
pawns which don't make a great
impression also don't forget about that
black a pawn the white Rook on the
fourth rank is gonna go and grab it at
some point maybe not yet but uh that one
is on tap for later so I think it's just
about keeping control we mentioned that
word a few times but now wants
to consolidate often when I watch his
streams he's always saying okay let's
just consolidate let's just keep control
let's be solid the opponent will make a
blunder make a mistake later anyway it's
better not to lose on the spot yes your
two pawns down but it's not the end of
the world and uh okay can Fabi wrap this
one up can he Force things I think
that's the big question if he can't
force things then White's position is
actually strategically sound so uh yeah
the fight's still going on it's a great
point there yeah of course even on down
these ponds I still can get them back I
mean H5 is that's the same Pawn as H6
right so and it's a very weak pawn and
A4 is on top to take at some point so
that's actually a very good point there
um even though I am down some material
right now so there's hope buddy and the
end times getting lower for both of them
I mean under a minute for ikaru and Fabi
is very close to being under a minute as
well sort of even on the time there just
a few second difference that was a good
move right there by Hikaru because he
wants to trade Rooks and I think he'll
take with the pawn though he kicks that
Knight out there that Knight is just a
force and in fact he kicked with his
Knight because he wants to head into the
D5 Square it was two difficult choices
there yeah help him at all if you
compare the remaining pieces whites Rook
better than the black rug White's night
just as good if not better than the
Black Knight and Bishops looks like
White's Bishop pretty decent too so
compensation and white also going for
those Queen side pawns the White Knight
is headed in that direction fabi's
position full of weaknesses I don't
think the two-point Advantage is fully
felt right now uh also the clock time
Fabi behind this time yeah but there's
under a minute but Fabiano 30 seconds
big threat on the board the Knight
jumping onto the queen side attacking
the rook and the A4 Pawn as you pointed
out Fabi steps It Up With The Rook to
stop that idea keeps it under control
Tommy is really holding on to each of
these pawns with their life right now
Tanya check this out Fabi has no time he
has no time right now
yeah he is threading a night sacrifice
with that move and Nike take on A3 in
the past one wait whoa he's just ignored
it take that pawn why not he does 93.
there's 93 though that might be Knight
C3 but now the black Rook can come in
I'm not sure which Square you use
wow okay we didn't go for this the White
Knight holding things together instead
we see Fabi go for a different Pawn now
this bishop is free hitting the white
Rook this Knight is on a nice Square
still two pawns up but how do you deal
with the threat against this bishop you
have to be very calm he guards it with
his King suddenly Anything could happen
here both sides going active but look at
this pawn it could become a queen later
on in the game if white doesn't have
something now this Pawn will win the
game 20 seconds to Fabi there's always a
sacrifice on A3 that Hikaru has to watch
out for he attacks The Rook to have he
attacks The Rook in return
hit him with a move
I'll take yours that was a big blunder
by Fabiano he did not have much time and
that was relentless counter play by
Hikaru Nakamura so right now a car is up
a piece but that B3 Pawn for black it's
very far Advanced so look at fabigo he's
going right after that pawn he wants a
passer of his own if I'll be shaking his
head he doesn't know what the evaluation
of the position is we see that eval Bar
says it's still liquid but in fabi's
head he's just made a big blunder yep he
basically had this exact position but
with an extra Bishop so he's thrown a
bishop off the board and he's still
fighting and uh here he just has to keep
moving keep Pace 10 seconds on the clock
it's not easy but fabi's plan is simple
at least he's going for those white
pawns at least it's one way kind of uh
one track mind right now go for that
what are those white pawns with
everything you've got and the White
Knight is actually trapped back there
that move then I can't get out of here
so maybe the black king will go
backwards and where is that Knight going
to the answer is nowhere and he does it
so actually white might be frozen here
wow yeah what Bishop is stuck defending
pawns the white Rook stuck defending the
White Knight which is trapped white can
only play with the king I saw this
coming Knight A3 and then Rook C1 right
and then now you can't move the road
well you can still move the Knight now
it's coming back right exactly and I'm
getting pawns I'm like hey whatever I'm
about to go get the a pawn oh my
goodness I go grab the a right take on G
and grab maybe there's a B2 push at some
point because the Rook has to go back
for white and that means the night oh my
goodness
with two extra pawns for black but the
king is getting very active
yeah White's King very active two pawns
down though Fabby trying to trade off
trying to mop up and that white a pawn
doomed Forget About It Go Active with
the white king everything's disappearing
I do think white should be just in time
to save this game Rooks pawns are not
the best pawns uh to be pushing when you
want to win but okay nice classy move
down from Hikaru he ties down that black
rook and he guards across the fourth
rank the white king will deal with that
that button the black white Rook will
deal with that one and it should end in
a draw but you still have to be careful
that's true that's true that's the white
king back and it's just in time the
white king will sit in front of that
black pawn and it's a draw look at your
car is so annoyed it's even a draw if
white did not have this F2 Pawn that's
how theoretically drawn it is you could
throw that pawn off the board it doesn't
matter the white Rook will go back and
forth the king does not take that pawn
if that King ever took the pawn though
black Rook would leave with check along
the first Rank and then black would
promote yeah and the players there and
exactly what you're talking about uh
Robert with that it ends and wow Hikaru
looked a little angry at the end but I
have to say he has to be relieved he was
in so much trouble so much pressure that
even after Fabi blundered an entire
piece it was still fine for Fabi and
Ricardo there probably a laughter of
relief he knows he still stays in the
game but such an epic fight and that's
what we see in his expression after all
those complications after all that
navigating through the scramble that we
just saw it was a big fight ended with a
draw David what a game take it take us
through it yeah what a game and in the
end it was a tale of two blunders first
it was Fabi from a dominant position he
blonded a piece it was here maybe he
thought that his Rook was trapped
there's actually not too many safe
squares for this piece he needed to
bring it the whole way across the board
black is two pawns up and should go on
to win this game not an easy move to
find he instead however he dropped his
Knight back forgetting perhaps that this
attack from the white Rook could be
evaded with a capture Rook takes bishop
and if the Rook is taken now white has
time to gobble up the black Rook
emerging with an extra Bishop if we fast
forward a few moves we see that Hikaru
also blundered a piece here the White
Knight could get out the way could start
running back dropping back with a check
instead he pushed a pawn forward and
maybe forgot that the black pawn could
step forward deflecting away the white
Rook from the defense of this Knight so
many twists and turns a roller coaster
draw in the end
did a roller coaster really nicely
explained that end game David and with
that nail biting finish what an up and
down moment it was it finally ends in a
peaceful result a game that wasn't
peaceful at any moment and with that
Fabiano caruana still keeps his lead in
the match against Hikaru Nakamura one
and a half to half Hikaru has to win a
game the next game Hikaru starts with
the black pieces he's got one more white
left in the match can he do it we will
find out on the other side of the twitch
break
[Music]
thank you
interested in becoming a chess streamer
like your favorite creators such as
Hikaru Gotham chess and the botan
sisters come on look at this
chess.com is excited to announce the
community streamer program
whether you're just getting started with
streaming or already established and
looking to expand your audience you can
now connect your account to chess.com
and have your stream promoted on the
game's largest platform
simply link your account at chess.com
settings slash connected accounts set
your category to chess on Twitch and
start streaming you'll get an ad free
experience on chess.com you will pop up
on our list of live streamers your
trust.com profile will feature your
Twitch stream
and your stream will be linked to your
games on our play server type command
Community streamer in chat and start
growing your stream today
[Music]
this whole concept of just bulldozing
the black king jumping in there with the
queen and making sure the Rook comes in
with a ladder mate is everything this
chapter is about everything this chapter
is about
the point is I don't want you to get a
move that's not in the course and go I
don't know what to do
92 of games get to this position from
this position white is winning about 60
70 of the time and I think if you learn
these lines that very easily could be 75
or 80 for you
[Music]
hi my name is Dina valenkai I'm from
Israel I am one Grandmaster also chat
streamer YouTuber content creator and
here I am as a participant of Reykjavik
open 2023. when I play openings when I
study open is when I choose the opening
lines for myself I definitely prioritize
the the logic behind the moves the
connection between pieces some Harmony I
try to create Harmony on the chessboard
so obviously today seeing my opponent
playing King F7 kimchi 16 G5 was not
making any sense so I was just trying to
find a way to punish my opponent for
that and that's why I sacrificed the
piece just because it was logical it was
making sense you know the opponent was
not developing pieces and you know the
rule number one for openings develop
your pieces and Castle my opponent
didn't Castle today he got punished for
it
a fantastic performance at the Reykjavik
open by women Grand Master Dina
balenkaya she gains 28 rating points
along the way defeating two grand
Masters we saw Fabi employ the King of
the Hill taking his King up to G4 but
when Dina's opponent did that it didn't
end too well for him James yeah that was
Gregory actually in fact he has two
chessable courses in fact
one on uh both on e4 I mean I was like
oh yeah Greg's playing like Gregory
that's nice and then I saw he put his
King on G6 and H5 and I was like he has
lost his absolute right what is he doing
and Dina punished him for
what a game that was and what a game two
it was between these two players and now
the pressure is really on Hikaru
Nakamura with the black pieces Robert
what is his approach in this one keep it
solid go all out in the next one
for everybody who was not here in the
studio I was saying probably don't play
a Sicilians five Mana karawana but he
says if Magnus Carlson does it it's
probably a good idea he's doing the same
exact opening that Magnus chose against
Wesley so and here you see Fabiano
sitting in for a think he plays the same
Pawn push we'll see how quickly he
follows up because Wesley went in for a
two-minute Journey after this and
probably plays instantly yeah he's got a
smile on his face because both of them
know that this has happened happened
earlier in the day today I have a
feeling Hickory nose I don't know Fabio
no you think so he was watching the show
yeah he he sent me some messages ah okay
behind the scenes inside info there nice
oh I forgot they weren't playing at the
same time of course yeah staggered
starts and uh okay Pawn sacrifice who
has done their homework better that's
the question so rather than a capture of
nights a trade of knights in the center
that we saw earlier in that game between
Fabio uh between Fabiano between Wesley
so and Magnus Carson Abby has dropped
his Bishop back that feels like there
should be some tricks against the black
king black is very severely
underdeveloped white is already castled
but uh I don't see anything yet how is
he gonna justify this Pawn sacrifice
yeah I don't understand this this
project race does not feel correct it's
just you usually when you do pawn
sacrifices you have rapid development
like gambits right of course Queen's
Gambit is not a real Gambit in a way
because you get that pawn back many
times Scotch Gambino Scotch Gambit one
of my favorites right you know you get
you get rapid development and you get
things back here I don't see us getting
that pawn back I mean I was looking at
Knight G5 I was like oh maybe Knight G5
but then 96. it just stops everything
and then okay C3 but then I take the
Knight on F3 you take back and I defend
the mate and I'm up upon so I don't
understand this but upon sacrifice here
I was like maybe there has to be
something with
a knight takes E5 Bishop F7 but you're
sacking two pieces for that I don't even
understand what this is about so this is
a very weird Pawn sacrifice that we're
going to see we need to see the
justification for what's even more weird
is that Fabiano caruana gives up a pawn
and then goes into a think tank he
should be on Blitz mode right now I am
worried Sabi not very prepared in this
position it's possible that they saw
this line and hikar's like this looks
interesting if I need to win a game with
black I'm going to take that pawn and
run with it and Bob Brown was like well
this can't be a serious line Magnus is
just being Magnus he's playing dodgy
stuff he'd look at five on a go he goes
Knight G5 out of the fried liver attack
he's going for F7 this is a principal
way to play and one of the big questions
that white must have is he has firm
control over the D5 square the square
right behind that Knight that's blocking
the White Queen so do you put a knight
on that square do you kick the night
with Pawn to C3 there's one of these big
questions that need to be answered but
first things first hiccardi's a defended
F7 Pawn Yeah
spend it for your life there's two ways
James mentioned one dropping back that
black knight from the center to block
the white light squared Bishop's
diagonal or you can bring out your own
Knight the undeveloped Knight to the
edge of the board the second one looks
ugh ugly flimsy uh gross yeah that's a
good word for it but uh Hikaru I'm
slightly surprised that he's pausing now
because this is the most natural move
for white in the position so if 96 like
what happens after 96 this is a question
I mean I was trying to get F4 to work
try to open the f file but I mean I feel
like I'm giving up a second power now
and we saw what happened we gave up all
in Pawns in the other game with Wesley
so this wasn't working so
no I don't know it works I mean the
engine is like hey you can do it okay
well that might be it then F4 I just
don't know what happens after Pawn takes
Knight East no but then I don't
understand maybe bishop E6 whoa I've
cheated here I've checked the engine do
you want to know what white plays here
in this position Knight F7 boom Knight
takes F7 and you just play six just give
up a piece get out of here that's too
much the game goes on you're a piece
down but look at this black king out in
the open and of course the engine says
0.0
so this could have been some preparation
instead Hikaru maybe scared of this
brings his Knight to the edge of the
board but this looks superficial yes you
defend this Pawn but long term now white
will have great compensation because
there's one terrible piece in the black
camp this Knight is stranded it's not
where it wants to be yes it's defending
but uh I think white here is going to be
very happy nice Outpost this is the
square you mentioned earlier Robert on
D5 and he's gonna get the best of both
worlds he's gonna bring his own Knight
forward and then kick the Black Knight
out of the center that's the good thing
when you don't push your pawns too early
then after the night goes into D5 there
the white pong go up to C3 black cannot
kick the Knight out of D5 there's no
Pawn to attack it with whereas white can
attack that black knight sitting
healthily in the center so I actually
think this is a very Dynamic game I
think both players are not particularly
well prepared and put that air quotes
this is not a regular position it's not
typical of the top level chess and James
maybe we need a chessful course on this
exact variation I'm gonna look it up
I'll cook something though I'll cook
something up for it yeah I'm definitely
in my adjustable of course grind right
now grinding and I'm making them eating
them sleeping right with them next to
the bed every day okay every single day
here so it is definitely a spicy Pawn
sacrifice that I am not too familiar
with so it looks cool I like the queen
H5 type ideas the queen H5 you see this
a lot and really well this isn't before
opening so you see this a lot in like
fried livers and Knight G5 with Bishop
C4 you put the queen on H5 to attack F7
and and keep him pinned down here and
then you just bring every piece to the
party sacrifices and F4 or open up lines
and diagonals for the pieces so that
we're able to uh to win this game yeah
it looks like Queen H5 is just that
feels good but maybe there's a oh yeah
yeah you can't play D5 I was thinking
about Bishop G4 in there but yeah Queen
H5 might be straight I just love these
ideas it brings back memories of playing
like these under 10 championships
players just put they're not in G5 they
go for checkmate they don't care about
anything else and that's the strategy
that fabiana's uh embracing here he
knows that when would clinch the match
for him so why not go for the kill uh
James mentioned the White Queen coming
out dropping that white knight in the
center as well the D5 Outpost super
tempting uh some beautiful moves here
but you are reporting down so you need
to be quite accurate very energetic to
keep the initiative going you also get
nabbed upon on C2 too as well Queen H5
we don't have anything immediate it's a
win H5 he could take on C2 you move the
Rook then he goes back and you like down
two pawns and you still have to justify
the fact I mean the engine says it's not
even that bad I think it's an initiative
I have everything developed like this is
a super Gambit in a way just gambiting
everything here but then maybe bishop
somewhere or after you move the Rook I
need to get a rook lifted and then go
crazy from there right you need to
somehow lift this rook and that's it
around and it's made in Maiden five you
know what I mean so that's how it feels
but it's a definitely a long way there's
one thing to note that black wants to
play D6 in many of these positions but
as soon as you do that you block your
own Bishop on C7 and that only
encourages white to push the pawn up to
F4 so I think this is a game of Tit for
Tat a little bit like white is waiting
to see what black does and then if D6 is
played then F4 so I think that Fabiano
he's just trying to find a waiting move
like A4 actually might be the best move
yeah the reason I mentioned A4 James
I've been doing my Rook lifts I've been
lifting
three I want to swim
boy he'd be lifting them Rooks I
actually love that that is a sick right
towel does that kind of stuff A4 or K3 I
remember we had a game like that that's
it grandfather tell at a game with Rook
A3 also I mean if the Knight jumps in I
do worry about black pushing this Pawn I
want to prevent that kicking my Bishop
away from its dream diagonal so yeah I'm
not sure if it's the best move uh of
course Knight to D5 immediately looks
beautiful too but uh Fabiano will leave
him with the decision for now it's uh
yeah sport for choice for white yeah
it's a big moment he has sacrificed a
bond but a lot of initiative and piece
play if Fabiano caruana is able to make
the most of that he wins this game he
will win the match which would mean
Hikaru goes down to the loser's bracket
but of course it's a far way off now for
Hikaru playing with the black pieces
trailing Fabi this is also the kind of
position that he wants right because if
Fabi isn't able to make the most of his
initiative he might have a couple of
moves to do that Hikaru will just end up
an extra Pawn so he could be the one
that takes this game away as well
yeah and that move it's slow that was
terrible it's reminiscent of the world
championship between Magnus and Fabiano
H3 was played by Fabiano and hikar did
his very Infamous like you know head to
the side but H3 I think he wants to play
Queen H5 he's worried about some his
Queen getting under attack over there
but a carp was King AJ very smart move
now the F Pawn is mobile yeah and I
might that might have been this is this
could turn around really quickly James
absolutely I mean now we can just play
F6 is coming I mean maybe Queen H5 could
try to temporarily stop it I mean but if
I play F6 anyway I guess
Knight F7 I want to sack on H7 but it
does not work I mean like I don't have
anything right now this is what we want
maybe Knight F3 takes it like yeah what
happened to the initiative when you have
an initiative initiative is the time and
the time is very important H3 felt like
it wasted a little bit of time it's so
slow uh it's so counter-intuitive
there's so many ways to improve the
position I guess the idea was to put box
in this black knight stop it from ever
getting back into the game okay now he
goes for this idea pushing the a pawn
but it feels like he's lost a move black
has certainly gained from this little uh
this little uh kind of swap here black
has gained a very useful move King h8
and I'm pretty sure he's gonna kick away
this white knight out of his half we're
talking about halves of the board and uh
squares you occupy why not kick it back
while you can and at least now black
will be able to save himself with some
trades later on you don't even need to
rush you can even bring your knight back
into the game first of all and uh yeah
Hikaru breathing aside relief he's
probably the best one of the best
defenders in World Chess and I wouldn't
be surprised if he manages to
consolidate an extra Pawn later as you
mentioned Tanya yeah mysterious move
there by Fabiano caruana pushing that
King Side Pawn wasting just a little
time for that initiator which is so
important in these positions Hikaru is
upon up David you mentioned push that
night out it has been played and now
Hikaru that's a very smart thing he
starts improving the position of of his
own night rerouting it all the way back
to the center where it can challenge the
biggest weakness in Black's position the
D5 square is the Black Knight headed to
E7 it certainly is but I think five
months kind of playing the long game at
this point that he knows he's made a
mistake he doesn't feel like he has an
advantage but he thinks he can just shut
the position down and try to make a draw
he is down one Pawn but where is that
pawn it's the pawn in front of the black
queen and guess what White's pieces are
in its path the dark Square Bishop for
black is staring into its own pawns so
black does not have activity for his own
pieces so what Fabio is trying to do is
just sit on the position keep the status
quo and say I'm materially down but my
pieces are more active and that should
keep me in the game yeah they should
keep him in the game but he will start
to sweat at least and he'll start to
worry about that pawn count coming into
effect a bit later on Hikaru I think is
going to be loving life especially after
these last few moves I just want to say
as well the match situation had an
impact on earlier decisions in earlier
kind of match-ups but uh in this one if
Fabi was one point behind no way would
he have played H3 he would have gotten
on the attack even if the scores were
level he would have gone on the attack I
think he's influenced by the fact that
he's leading he didn't want to take any
risks but you've already sacrificed a
pawn why kind of take a safety first
approach when you've sacked a pawn
already absolutely you think he was just
wanting to keep it solid David feels
that way H3 I've I've got to say chess
Karma the chess goddess Kaiser she's not
going to be uh smiling on Fabi after
that last move he is pushing the Knight
right now so picks up the momentum again
do you fall back to the center of the
board on E6
yeah and then he pushes B6 and like I
mean I'm down a pawn like I just don't
like it I'm down a pawn and I don't have
an aggressive type position I can't even
Rook A3 anymore I mean I can't do really
anything I'm just I'm really just down
upon it very surprising that the engine
only says like it's equal here which is
I guess it's 55 square and like I have
good positioning of the pieces but I am
clearly down upon yeah one square for a
pawn it's like which one would you
rather choose most people would choose
the pardon normally I like the squares
but uh yeah here I have to take the
black side too and okay he's developing
Fabi I think the question for Naka uh
for Hikaru is how does he make use of
his extra Pawn the extra Pawn is that
very backward d-pawn and until deep into
the end game it's never going to move so
uh how does he trade pieces which pieces
does he trade big questions we call it
Turn Style Square D5 is just that for
white if you take one piece the next
piece goes in there so unfortunately for
black he cannot push his own pawns
backwards that would be the best choice
for black Z5 back to C6 let's go back
there kick the night out but for now
every single trade we have on D5 the
bishop will replace the Knight The Rook
will replace the bishop and you can't do
any more trades for black because
there's not an open board so I think
that's what Fabiano is relying on he
doesn't like his position but he may be
thinking well how does black actually
make progress you need to open files for
your pieces so if there is going to be a
pawn trade that will benefit Hikaru yep
suddenly and look at this black piece as
well big point because if he's playing
checkers everything on dot squares in
this position actually I'm going to make
one more move everything on dot squares
wow for black H6 wow beautiful
okay he has put his Rook on B8 so maybe
we'll see that variation a bit later on
meanwhile Fabiana okay he's not happy
sit still he's pushing forward with his
pawns Robert mentioned opening lines
would help black but here I'm not sure
it feels like Fabi is getting a bit
impatient let's go back to the game he
stepped forward with his Queen last move
he's just dropped back the White Queen
losing time
it's very much of a type of position
where Tempe isn't so important but you
have to come with a clear-cut plan and
here it doesn't feel like a Fabby has
stumbled across one yet still evaluation
bar still in the middle uh still in the
middle here yeah that Bishop on C7 is
definitely pretty gross but I do oh yeah
exactly right it looks like a pawn
especially from back here we got the
lights yeah that look like a pawn there
but for that one of course I think we
can probably play F5 at some point it
looks like we're hinting at it F5 to at
least open some lines up get the bishop
and then if we can play F5 then we now
at least have some type of diagonal for
the dark Square Bishop we can move it to
d8 you see there's a lot Knight or
Sicilians we rather than the Bishop from
like a gross E7 to d8 around the B6 but
in this case it's the other way
rerouting from d a from C7 to d8 over to
F6 or G5 that whole diagonal the Bishops
actually look very nice that way as
they're both on the same uh they're both
pointing towards the king side
so definitely this is the pawn break for
black whereas white is trying to make
some magic happen on this side of the
ward I'm not sure exactly which pawns
he's going to push which pawns he's
going to capture but uh I'll be keeping
his his options open and uh this one
will take a slower Pace now uh at least
in terms of the Maneuvers I don't think
we'll see any direct attacks any tactics
but uh Fabi he's found a nice Square for
his Queen again not sure what it does
there but it looks nice and pretty all
right just uh yeah just gaining at least
aesthetic points for his position uh for
the placement of his pieces it's kind of
living by the adage that the side that
controls the pawn breaks is the side
with the advantage now black is up a
pawn here and black is trying to push
the F Pawn the one in front of the king
side Rook but white could push Pawns of
his own on the queen Side open up some
lines and if black is not careful that
could actually be beneficial for white
so I think that five is doing the right
thing he's anticipating hikaru's Pawn
break and he's saying that I'm ready for
it my Bishop my queen and my Rooks all
are doing something and I just don't see
how hikar keeps it up but you know hikar
wants to open up that's why he played
his opening he's playing for ambitious
chess for dynamic play and he wants to
win yeah but with that Bishop on C7 with
no future ahead of it it's kind of hard
to imagine black actually making
anything off that extra Pawn you've got
to try to break somewhere David James
you've been pointing out the break on
the king side but I still like fabi's
control over the position yes it's an
extra Pawn but one can understand why
this position is so level just simply
black doesn't have an advance and he
does it immediately good call there
James
he does it immediately and now big
questions right how does white actually
react to that do you allow black to go
further with that F Pawn that looks like
a bad call do you take it allow activity
this is a big question to fabina yeah f
for Ford I don't think you should allow
that port forward any further just get
it off the board yeah you got to get rid
of that because if not with an F4 and G5
H5 everything five and you're looking
scary it's very scary that way and then
the bishop rerouts the d8 now it has a
job which is defending the G5 Pawn if we
allow that and then everything's tied in
there as uh he actually captures it
allows Bishop at five here it's just
gonna say yeah porn star mess if James
mentions you can't allow this so he does
get it off the board absolutely hey Caro
this is heating up five at least one
active piece for Hickory this light
Squad Bishop for him looks pretty decent
for now but uh still control for Fabi
um thus control the light squares he
does bring the Rook to bring that last
piece into the game he will slide it
over to the center of the board and
start attacking the weaknesses in
hikaru's Camp on that D6 Square on the
Queen's line okay dude it also kind of
keeps everything defended on the king
side nice little move there
multi-purpose move and it's kind of like
game one in order for hikara to attack
he may have to make his own King more
vulnerable because right now white is
defending everything all of White's
pieces are doing something that black
Bishop on C7 it's such a poor piece and
where are you going to attack from
that's the big question even if you
could open up the king side look at the
bishop on D5 and the Queen on C4 they're
taking away access along that diagonal
to prevent a rook from joining the party
so I just feel like 500 has things under
control for now he's also doing decently
on the clock that's a vital importance
remember in the game between artemiev
and aronian in that time scramble and
Armageddon levenge you know he barely
got away with it I mean it looked like
he was going to lose the game but time
was not undecided that's start to happen
so 500 needs to keep love on the clock
Robert you know Hikaru well if you have
the option to switch colors right now
right take the white activity then black
gets the extra one will he take that no
he's taking the black piece the extra
Pawn here is very valuable because white
doesn't have a plan that's the issue you
choose the site with the plans White's
just going to shuffle back and forth
that may be enough in this game it's
just not particularly fun
and our chat saying that they're
focusing so hard that their faces are
red well there is a lot at stake in this
one if Fabiano wins he goes on to the
Grand Final while Hikaru will go to the
elimination bracket they really do need
to focus as the position is heating up
you've been talking about the value of
the extra Pawn finding that play on the
king side James do you see Hikaru going
for the G5 G4 break yeah I mean this
bishop is probably the worst Bishop I
ever seen since a couple blink of winter
back in the whole back in the day if
you're familiar with that game that this
is a pretty gross Bishop it's so bad and
it takes a lot of moves to get it active
so we need to do that like G5 G6 Queen
G7 bishop d8 and we gotta we gotta deal
with his this yeah the D6 Pawn is very
weak so we have to sit it on E7 I mean
okay we have the extra Pawn but it's
really hard to to do anything right now
especially with this bishop I know uh do
you know which GM said uh with one piece
well one piece is bad your whole
position is bad now of course there's
not a that's not always the case GM
James Conte
now in fact uh there was uh there's some
Grandmaster that said you know when one
piece is bad your whole position is bad
that's not always the case but this
bishop is very very bad on C7 and we
need to deal with it at some point or
it's just going to sit there and just
you know be a piece right and try to be
a piece and a draw would be fine for
Fabi you know because Bobby it just
gives him another Point here and then go
into the last game right so this is
tough that Bishop is very gross even
though we're up upon
I'm was it I saw you googling there
Robert was it tarash yeah yes that was
gonna be my guess yeah I wasn't gonna
cheat and say it I just want to look it
up for my because it usually is tarash
any quote I hear I'm like it probably
was that that's funny he's got a good
question yeah well we've just seen a
move by Hikaru it is a small little move
on the queen side but does it have a big
idea of advancing that beep on further
and dislodging that White Queen yeah
this should be okay it's better it's
still gross but it's better it's like
better grow it's like you know you got
hot garbage and then garbage you know
it's a step up you know what I mean like
it's not hot it's hot garbage now you
play B5 it's still good it's garbage
like you're moving in the right
direction
yeah and at least he's asking a question
of Fabi he's saying okay please burn a
minute or two on your clock uh thinking
about whether you push a Pawn on the
queen side whether you fix the structure
on that side of the board and uh if you
can't come up with a decision at least
I'll have the option next move of
throwing my pawns forward it's the type
of move that's really useful especially
in rapping and Blitz chess where you
just ask your opponent a small question
and uh Fabi we do see it spending over a
minute now so it's not the most scary
move as uh James mentions the black
bishop's still gonna struggle for space
for air but at least Fabi now in the
tank and I'm expecting him to move his
Queen somehow the white Queen's done her
job she was kind of just setting up just
posting up there but uh I wouldn't be
surprised if she drops back and passes
the move to NACA uh here just status quo
keep it you already says status yeah he
said that before too even a rubber
status
I'm not trying to call it every
difference between American and British
English but you know I'm just listening
and it just sounds as pleasant as a
Hoover just you know
[Laughter]
yeah nice but uh meanwhile okay lock
things up a big decision there just
asking questions on the queen side A5
now does Fabi push the pawn and really
close down on the queen side or will you
trade one of these two pawns one thing's
for sure it's gonna make Fabi think and
that's part of the strategy right get
him low on the clock
yeah get him low on the clock again
asking a question and what do we think
is probably going to lock it down or is
he going to open up that side I'll
probably lock it down I mean I Bishop's
so bad I just want it to be bad forever
but then again like Robert pointed out I
don't have a plan bad plan is better
than no plan at all I don't have any
plan at all I'm just trying to react off
of you and and try to you know I guess
improve I guess the plan is just improve
the pieces maybe play Pawn C4 lock it up
and then at some point I mean maybe you
know maybe play F4 myself at some point
but it's gonna take a long long time to
do anything he keeps attention instead
he just slides up with The Rook
defending that B4 Pawn defending the
Pawn With The Rook but also saying okay
I might open it up in a favorable way
later on if you neglect this side of the
board the downside is you do allow black
the option of capturing for example and
now black does have a past Pawn long
term but then so do you potentially with
white apron so pros and cons here and uh
Fabi bring all of his Rooks over now
this Rook tied down to the defense of
this Pawn very much again the status quo
status quo
oh that was great that was great it did
sound awkward yeah for him saying status
right it sounds better when he says data
I'm trying guys
oh well I think this position is one
where as James was just highlighting
like you could have played B5 you still
can do it for white and you close
everything down but the issue is then
you just are reacting and that's never
fun and I think Hikaru he sees these
last call moves and he's just like I
respect them this makes sense to me but
at some point it might be up to Fabi
just shut things down even if it's not
fun yeah at least it's him making the
decision right uh Hikaru every move he's
gonna say okay I'm gonna wait and wait
and wait and that tension over there on
the queen side is going to build and
build and build and as the clocks tick
down it's going to become even more
uncomfortable for Fabiana to make a
decision at some point as Robert says
maybe you just have to close it switch
Focus just be practical you only have
three minutes left on your look at least
spend that three minutes focusing on one
flank on one side of the board but of
course it's difficult to do that it's
difficult to just rid yourself of all
counter play and essentially just play
for the draw meanwhile sort of lightly
improving his Queen centralizing there
how does Hikaru improve his pieces
that's the question it's all about that
dark squared Bishop if Black start
Square Bishop gets in the game he's most
likely going to win if not and then that
question is where do you want it when
you want to answer where to place it
you've got to ask what is the most ideal
square and it's kind of hard to even
find an idol Square for that Bishop to
reroute it to which means that as long
as that Bishop stays back bad Fabi does
have compensation can't find actually
look at setting up some attack on that
diagonal where he's placed the queen but
I do see hikarus decided to improve the
light Squad Bishop get it to that G6
Square hit that Queen on D3 I like it
that's another one reroute re-root
sorry but uh you're right he's trying to
reroute his uh Bishop there and uh wow
Fabby steps onto the line of one of the
black Rooks I think this is fine
the car is just looking up and saying
did you really play that move that was
the expression he had very evocative
it's a trap but being provocative is
good because it might cost a horror
sometimes so I think Bob I don't know if
he recognizes everything's under control
then it's a good decision to be made
yeah for example here the first move
that came to my mind maybe the move that
made Hikaru frown was Bishop takes Pawn
trying to set a nasty trap if the pawn
is captured of course it is a mistake
we'll show why but if the bishop is
captured now then it's actually a double
attack you hit the queen you hit the
rook and you win material of course
though uh the Trapper gets trapped here
Bishop takes important and your Bishop
has no Escape squares now Fabby locks it
up here this bishop is caught in prison
so uh Fabiano playing provocative chess
forcing as Robert says Hikaru to burn
time on the clock looking in this
direction and actually this isn't really
a threat at all because this bishop is
so bad it's in the way yet again and uh
yeah still looking balanced to me okay
that's a great trap that you pointed out
and it's so easy to miss that pawn move
to B5 and to fall for it it took Hikaru
a little time to realize that the
tactics just don't work and now he's
back to thinking how he can
strategically improve his possession
hard to find an answer to that question
and he's down on the clock now because
the onus is on him to win this game he
wants to level up the score for Fabi
he's just gone back and forth back and
forth he's not doing much of anything
and he's waiting for the right time to
open up the position and if a car gets
greedy we just saw her pay the full
price and if he just continues moving
back and forth with his light Square
Bishop he's not actually making any
progress so he does just strike with B5
and now five minutes will see some
trades happen and yeah he took the Rook
he wants that activity that dark Square
Bishop isn't so bad anymore James you're
right it's it's not it's not hot garbage
no more it's just garbage I guess it is
still garbage but you know it's a little
bit better than what it was before rugby
Fox was thinking Bishop but that
actually is really nice keeps control
over everything and maybe we can now
double the Rooks and have some pressure
you can't even really deal yeah B2 is
loose that is a very nice move Rick P5
is better than the bishop B5 I was
really into that tempo of uh Bishop B5
I'm a big fan of the tempo but Rook B5
this kind of is with some type of tempo
in a way because B2 actually is uh is
hanging now we may be able to do CB4 and
Bishop to B6 in some cases of course our
Rook is hanging on C8 right now so we
need to deal with that first but there
are now some x-rays on the queen that we
now can start looking at yeah and now
it's
critical as the pawns get traded and
things open up David does it feel like
we are going to reach some position
where calculation will be critical and
the clock situation will count so it's
critical uh Tanya calculation is the
most important thing as we know over
everything but uh yeah definitely the
clock is going to count and I don't like
this ton of events for uh Fabiano okay
he's brought his Queen across attacking
a loose black Rook at the top of the
board but essentially it's the worst
possible moment for him look at his Rook
on B2 as James mentioned undefended the
white Bishop in the center now on that
beautiful D5 Square undefended Hikaru
loving life laughing to himself there
but it definitely it feels like the
tactics are going to work in Black's
favor because white pieces are not ready
for things to open up add a different
read of the hikar reaction I think he
actually missed something oh and he's
laughing at himself because the way he
is following it up with holding his head
he wants to double his Rooks in the open
file but I think he's seen that Fabiano
has an option here and maybe it's
because that Rook on B5 can be attacked
and five and it goes with it he brings
his Bishop back where is that Rook going
how is it going to Escape The Bishop's
attack is it going to be a repetition
then when the Rook falls back will Fabi
just pursue it further with a light
squat Bishop are we going to see Bishop
D5 I think so why not yeah
Fabi says I'm happy with the draw but
there is no way to avoid it Rook B6 the
A5 Pawn is hanging you see hikari's
laughing at himself and he's shaking his
head because he knows that he could have
kept this game going and at least he had
more pressure on Fabiano wow so actually
just this one moment your car room maybe
slipped up uh Fabi really capitalizing
on this fleeting opportunity where the
black Rooks just don't have enough
squares to run to no safe squares to
hide from the tension with the Bishops
and the pawns the Rooks whoa David how
much is Rick A5 Rook B4 how much is that
wow okay let's check it out James what's
going on there you know we always got to
check it we have the luxury of doing
that here over here Rook A5 rookie six
yeah and then Ricky Feinberg before whoa
all the tactics wow I mean but it seemed
like you could play it I mean but that's
there's something apparently we're
missing here I don't see what we're
missing unless it's Rook takes Rook
maybe but then you do you just how do
you consider taking with a pawn and keep
taking I'll give you my Rook on B2 and
I'm gonna have a past Pawn over here
look it says still Advanced right
there's something clearly better but
even this is available to White because
black is tied down I love that yeah very
dangerous practically with that eight
Pawn advancing this could be a big
disaster he refuses repetition he says
game on and is taking big risk kill
what's happening if you just Shuffle
across look you're pinned along the a
file and you're pinned on this diagonal
oh wait you're right about that whoa
doing a little hat trick he realizes
that he is in trouble now he could have
just repeated at that moment he had one
more white left yeah it's still very
very tense okay Fabiano drops his Queen
back but black is tied up you still
can't take the pawn and because of this
pin and this pin and okay he's created a
past Pawn but suddenly things are
opening up no Fabian is actually closing
things down brilliant because the pawn
A4 has stranded it's gone too far yeah
this Pawn is going to drop off the board
Fabiano needs one more move to close
things down and actually this Pawn on
the B5 square is going to decide the
game and okay light squared trade of
Bishops it's not going to help it's
still this terrible Bishop uh on C7
against this beautiful Bishop on E3 and
uh Fabiano Advantage white this is
terrible like man I'm up a pond like you
know they're hurt it hurts up upon the
whole game and then again you know one
bad taras right one bad piece in your
whole position is bad like even being
down the pond and we were up the pawn or
black is he had he could never I mean
the Bishops stayed there on C7 since he
got there the rest of the game the whole
game the bishop has been on C7 that's
barely been a bishop and now it just
looks like a car was pushed too far
he wins this
is
hanging right now coming to Aid can you
take the A3 Pawn immediately I think you
first defend this Pawn on B5 and he does
it C4 take your time the Pawn's not
going anywhere why can't you bring
pressure on it and the black work on
being is stuck because white has a pass
Pawn of his own Hikaru he's just moving
left and right he doesn't really have
options here and 500 is going to win
this pawn and he does it you can even
just trade queens and pick up that A2
Pawn you're never losing that end game
as white
the question is can he win can he decide
this match here and now and uh until the
last couple of moves I want to point out
every single one of Black's pawns and
pieces won dark squares now he's put his
Queen to challenge for the light squares
challenge White's control there but uh
okay he's gone for it Fabiano not maybe
going for the most direct the most
decisive uh continuation because black
can now break on the light squares break
the bind oh and he should be safe still
a bit scary but uh Fabiano can he win
this one still Hikaru looking very
rattled there he goes D5 once again just
trying to create a mess on the board
that is what Hikaru does best in worse
positions he makes it so difficult for
his opponent but the good news of Fabi
is that he's up on the clock he's got a
minute the bishop is spin can you take
on C5 right now
you can it does go down to a rook and
porn end game where a draw is maybe more
likely than a win but why not it might
be your one chance you can push your
Central Pawn forward as well but the
black king is coming towards it so uh
big moment just in time to hold this
game critical moment for Fabiano will he
go for the Deep on push or will he grab
that C5 Pawn but that would inch it
closer to words a potential draw I think
he has to take the pawn and there's yeah
he has to secure an advantage and then
press from there pushing the pawn too
soon probably would have lost that pawn
as the black king is close I think you
just Retreat his Bishop because that
pawn on D5 cannot be captured so long as
the white rook in the corner is in
contact with that black Bishop so
Fabiano can reduce Bishop maybe back
towards the A3 square that way he can
push his Pawn forward in the near future
and this is not going to be easy for a
car to defend you're right yes
wow yeah three there it is Robert
calling out the action the bishop
[Music]
okay that was close
yeah breathe they don't blunder mating
one very often and uh Fabiana does give
his King some breathing space really
really nice move there and again can
Hikaru hold the draw that's the question
now Fabiano cannot lose this game he's a
portal 10 seconds dude yeah two points
up wow but a horrible Bond structure
yeah but it's all about the white Deport
if he keeps the Central Pawn alive
oh my oh my god oh you said they don't
blunder checkmated one and then a car
immediately does you commentator's curse
wow I did it sorry Hikaru David I jinxed
him you dirty dog just believe that
I cannot believe it either
is going to cause Hikaru the whole match
Robert you are in disbelief right now I
am shocked I thought fabino he was
working it well but I thought it would
take a taxing effort and then suddenly
hikara you could sense he was not happy
with his position he blow his Checkmate
in one move Wow real Cafe it came over
what a match we've just witnessed and
with that Fabiano caruana wins the
winner final going ahead to the Grand
Final Hikaru Nakamura drops to the
elimination bracket what a game we had
ended abruptly David what was the
critical moment it was just one move
before the end Tanya I'm still in shock
I've got to admit it was this position
just one move ago I said players these
top players especially don't blunder
mate in one very often it was Hikaru who
was threatening a Checkmate the white
king nowhere to run to and uh very
nicely here Fabiana pushed his Pawn
forward and Hikaru maybe on a better day
in better form he would have moved his
Bishop out first the same move he played
next move and this is not Checkmate now
the white Rook can come across with a
check because the black king has an
escape Square the game goes on black
should make the draw however first in
this position he pushed the pawn forward
and actually what he hadn't spotted is
that after Pawn takes Pawn this Pawn
takes away the Escape Square for the
black king So when he does move his
Bishop this is Checkmate heartbreak for
Hikaru what a turnaround what a roller
coaster game but Fabiana karawana
congratulations
and with that Fabiano caruana moves
ahead to the Grand Final which will be
played on a Friday this was our score
line what a match we had what a
fantastic Game ending with a Checkmate
and there we see Fabiana carwana taking
down one of the best players if not the
best player in this format in just three
games a phenomenal performance there and
we've got the man of the moment here he
is Fabi congratulations
thank you
so I mean really well played match that
but that ended extremely abruptly
yeah you know I so I saw before we
played H5 that if he plays Bishop before
that I I win the bishop and he can play
Bishop B5 and I thought I would give a
check on A7 and we would see uh we'll
take it from there even though it's
probably a draw I mean it's still some
work for him and then he played H5 so
without thinking I I thought okay I'll
take the pawn it's usually safe
like it usually can't be a huge mistake
to take a take the pawn
and then I thought okay Bishop before
again I win the bishop with Rook f8 and
so when he played rookie Bishop B5 then
I realized that it's actually not
winning anything it's just Checkmate
because he I mean he helped me to
himself which was
um
kind of ridiculous kind of unexpected
obviously very lucky for me
um but but yeah it was probably the
funniest way at least from my point of
view that it could have ended the
daycare a little time to just register
what has happened or were you watching
out in Real Cafe it immediately play it
there how shocked were you
no I immediately saw that it's mate um
because I had the Rook of Fate idea in
mind but I I had it in mind more as like
an option to win the bishop if he plays
Bishop F4 and then it was just lucky
that it's also Checkmate in this case uh
but yeah I immediately saw it and it
took me kind of half a second to
register that he car blundered made one
because normally he doesn't blunder at
all
um but yeah I have to say today
uh I had my
fair share of luck to put it mildly
wow Fabi I have to ask you not just
looking at the score line you wrapped up
the match in three games but to us it
also felt that you were better
throughout the match you played a really
good match were you pleased with the
quality of play today
well I I felt like in the first game I
was on the verge of losing I was getting
outplayed I thought I had a very
promising position at some point when I
got denied on B6 supported by the pawns
on A5 C5 I was very optimistic but then
he found this maneuver tonight Knight to
B5 and suddenly I realized that he he
has a lot of good squares for his pieces
and and I actually have a lot of
strategic risk probably more so than he
does because my pawns are extremely weak
and it's much harder for me to find a
way into his position than for him to
find a way into my position and then at
some point I was just like found so much
on the clock I thought my position is is
more or less losing very close to it and
um I was just very lucky when I played
Queen D1
my idea actually with Queen D1 was not
to play Queen E1 but to play Knight C4
but then he thought for like more or
less three minutes and I started to
understand the position a little bit
because I was very long time but this uh
this hesitation that he had it helped me
come to groups with the position and
then I saw that I have this cleaning one
move which is uh basically
like a a very multi-purpose move it's
tops and I see three ideas It prepares
Knight C4 defends E5 and at that point I
already felt like the game was was very
unclear and then in time scramble I
somehow came out ahead uh again very
lucky because like
I wasn't 100 sure that my king running
into G4 is not getting mated but I
didn't see anything else to do I was
down for like four seconds so I kind of
just went with my gut end and it worked
out that the king is safe there
um so yeah that was a very lucky first
game second game also like I was
definitely
definitely much much better and I felt
like I was at some point winning but it
was always very difficult to keep
control of all my weak pawns and then I
blundered a piece and somehow uh
normally I would just lose on the spot
but I I somehow managed to
um to keep the game not completely dead
lost and then even at some point I was
close to winning again so
yeah overall it was very strange first
two games
um third game again I was on the back
foot I thought at some point I was
getting outplayed
like I I didn't expect him to go for
this opening uh in general even though
he's played it a lot but I noticed that
he doesn't really seem to like I think
he played it sort of without much work
done on the line because he he played it
many times against Wesley against
Federal save and he always plays this
very bad line putting the bishop on E7
says C5 C7 I know he wins all his games
but the position of the opening is bad
and so I thought he he this was more or
less just a weapon like to try to play
for a win so I didn't expect it in this
match Unless somehow I was getting ahead
and he would have to play for a win
um and I kind of have prepared this D4
idea and then he he played a bad hoop
Bishop C7 but I couldn't figure out how
to punish it and
so yeah at some point I was getting much
worse and it was only he could have
taken a draw it was only his ambition
probably over ambition that led to a
difficult position for him and Bobby
congratulations they say better lucky
than good but best I say to be lucky and
good and your performances recently have
been improving in quicker time controls
but what does it mean to you to take
down Liam or Timmy and then finally
Hikaru back to back to back are you
feeling good about your rapid play
you know yeah overall the result is
amazing
um I mean I all the time matches were
tough uh I definitely needed a great
deal of luck and and also I guess I am
fighting quite well and keeping the
matches close like all the matches have
been very close uh so so yeah it's been
a dream run so far I still think that
it'll be very very tough final but I I
have a rest day tomorrow right am I
right about that yeah
so that's great I I have one day to rest
um because like yesterday I was feeling
physically uh like I injured myself and
I was feeling physically terrible today
so I was starting to recover so uh the
rest day is is um
much needed
Bobby congratulations that was crazy
epic match congrats to you and of course
I knew I think something was wrong we
wanted to know what it was up with the
shoulder and stuff like that but first
off get some glutamine and some protein
my guy okay definitely we going to the
gym we lifting heavyweight we're gonna
have to recover correctly but what
happened uh with the injury what was
that a ice pack or something
um well this this thing is uh I don't
know if you can see it but this is a hot
pack but I I've been using my ice pack
on it I used for about half an hour last
night and that that really helped
because yesterday it was like
um it was it was seriously painful uh
and and this morning I woke up and it
was it was much much better so I'm glad
that it wasn't like
um I probably didn't hear anything if
it's recovering very quickly so it was
probably just like
overused or something I wasn't even
lifting I just I think I slept on it the
wrong way and I woke up and it was like
in in really really bad pain but uh
thankfully it's recovering rather
quickly
and uh Fabio Fabiano I'm just curious uh
during these games do you have the
cameras on were you watching hikaru's
Expressions during some of these matches
no no I I never check because it feels
more like a distraction from the game
and I already feel rather overwhelmed
especially when it comes gets into the
time travel phase so I don't want to
distract myself with uh
with hikaru's Expressions although I'm
sure they were very entertaining
you're absolutely right on that Fabby
but after I have to ask you before we'd
like to go there tomorrow
air the Grand Final for you how are you
gonna spend it how will you unwind
yeah I think I'll just try to get some
uh
some nature in like some walking I I've
been spending most of the past few days
inside because usually after playing I'm
I'm not in like uh I don't have all the
energy in the world to to do something
physical so I might try to go outside
and enjoy the good weather here it's
it's been getting seriously warm after a
really cold period so like yesterday was
over 80 degrees and today similarly so
I'll probably do that and um and I'll
watch the games very closely uh the
matches I guess it'll be a couple of
tough matches
um I guess Levon and
uh Magnus are playing to to decide who
plays Hikaru right is that the yes yes
okay so yeah it'll be it'll be very
tough matches
um
but one thing that I'm glad that I uh
disrupted is that there won't be another
Magnus he cover final at least that's
out of the books for this one
final between Magnus and Hikaru that we
have to ask you do you have a preference
who you'd want to meet in the Grand
Final
um well okay I mean generally speaking
Magnus has the is the strongest player
but he hasn't shown like his best chess
in this in this event so far I think
although he's still in it and uh and won
a bunch of good matches and including
today I think like he the first game he
played against Wesley was was very very
impressive
um but you know I always enjoy playing
love on the most and he's also a
personal friend so I do uh hope he does
well also because I I generally hope he
does well and also because we've had uh
some close matches and the last one was
in the American Cup where we
probably like the worst chest that
either of us have ever played but we
ended up in Armageddon and he won so I
also would like to take a little bit of
Revenge for that
Bobby you played awesome chess in the
chessable Masters so far have a good
rest day and we'll see you in the Grand
Final
Fabiano caruana with a big result that
taking down Hikaru Nakamura in just
three games he advances to the Grand
Final Hikaru Nakamura drops to the
elimination bracket he will be playing
against the winner of Magnus Carlsen
versus Levon aronian what a day of Chess
we've had Robert what was the highlight
for you well I think we just saw a
Checkmate in one move and that does not
happen at the highest level pretty much
ever David himself was saying this
cannot possibly happen and it did with
the colors reverse so I think that of
course is the highlight and as Fabiano
said it was impressive display of Chess
from Magnus Carlson and Lavon aronian
that feels like forever ago but that
still was great chest today yeah James
what about you the internet about to go
crazy there's about to go crazy off The
Rook f8 they want I mean it's it's nuts
you never ever see that especially from
a player of your college caliber Rook f8
was the huge highlight is that the most
shocking moment of the day maybe the
most shocking moment of the tour of all
seasons of the tour combined but uh yeah
I'm hoping for more of the same tomorrow
just still we're gonna have Magnus
Carlson involved we're gonna have uh
Hikaru Nakamura involved at some point
and Fabi waiting at the end the big boss
now uh still plenty of action ahead
so much action coming up tomorrow to
decide who will play against Fabiano
caruana in the Grand Final and we've got
the division two results coming in as
well not a back of the Saturn won his
match against Dennis last week he will
be playing against Maxim vashia lagrav
in the finals there what are you
expecting from that I just once again
want to say shout out to MB on Chrome
the great sportsmanship abdusa tarab he
is using his muscle he beats another
teenager he makes it through and Anish
giri and Yu Yang Yi don't count out the
Chinese Grandmaster he made it to the
Grand Final against Parker carwana in
the air things Masters division two Yu
yangi still afloat in division two this
time around as well yeah this is going
to be a fun one also we're getting an
update with the action on division three
and it is
blue bomb who take their matches Robert
yeah Serana he's still in it he lost him
match earlier he was in division one the
last time around he is still going in
the losers bracket so he is floating up
he will make his way towards the means
having to buy and the one last thing I
want to say and I just thought of it now
is that Fabiano loves the f8 square both
yesterday today that was the key Square
for him
big action coming up tomorrow and oh my
God what a way to end the day we've got
a Checkmate in one Rook effort that's
one for the history books and tomorrow
we start the day with Magnus taking on
Levon that's going to be fun as well
James oh absolutely LeBron aronian of
course that's my guy and and what's
funny is who don't understand he made it
very far of course now he's about to
face Magnus and if he wins that match he
goes to face Hikaru and I mean that's a
crazy matchup too Levon has made it very
very far here right but Magnus is
definitely going to bring it to him
super excited about that one and I'm
also super excited to reveal our winner
of our social media Instagram contest
where we asked you to send us your
selfies and these are amazing ones you
do win a 50 chasable voucher so
definitely get that course going the
whole family is enjoying accessible
Masters
yeah what a photo the chess is a family
sport he's in there smiling all smiles
and love guys bring it in guys
wow those are some amazing final
Thoughts by David with that hug we are
going to say goodbye for today but of
course we will be back with all the
action as a Magnus Levon Hikaru battle
it out tomorrow to see who will face
Fabiano caruana in the Grand Final see
you then
oh Curry steps back he's lost two moves
there it is
over sorry about look at this
[Music]
oh my God
it looked good we gotta know what was on
the menu today this Magnus is pretty
dangerous night
[Music]
thank you
wow
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign